On screen. I'm First Officer William Riker of the USS Enterprise.
Du hast doch auch so ein IT-Background, oder kennst da so Leute und so.
Wir sind enttäuscht.
Ja, ich bin auch enttäuscht. Da haben wir ja immer noch so prekäre 50 Megabit und dann läuft die Scheiße noch nicht mal 24-7.
Do you need help?
Irgendeiner sägt hier gerade im Keller der Leiteprobe oder so.
Sensors indicate engineering problems. They are experiencing total guidance system failure with less than 24 hours reserve power.
Oh, hier ist gerade ein Paket durchgekommen.
Jetzt bricht es hier auch wirklich am laufenden Meter ein.
Es ist wirklich schlimm heute. Das ist alles total digital.
Und so. Ist nämlich Mobile Max.
Muss man halt einfach ein bisschen lauter brüllen, ne?
Die 101 an 12, 12, 12, bitte.
Ja.
Soll ich das bewusst?
Wobei ja eigentlich 20, 12, 20, 12, um 20 Uhr 12 noch viel geiler wäre.
Ja, ihr könnt ja dann alle nochmal reinkommen, ne?
20, 12, also sozusagen jetzt in Amt Tagen.
Ja, also überhaupt die gesamte Podcast-Szene macht sich jetzt auf ihre letzte Sendung gefasst, ja, unmittelbar von dem Weltuntergang, so auch wir.
WMR gibt es noch mal vom Weltuntergang.
Nicht zu knapp davor ansetzen.
Wann ist denn der Weltuntergang?
21 ist er, glaube ich, oder?
Ich hab mich nämlich gar nicht im Kalender eingetragen. Dennis, sag doch mal was.
Du kriegst dann die Warnung eh nicht mehr, weil das ist ja schon vorbei.
Aber ich kann mir 15 Minuten vor einen Alarm setzen.
Wie blöd ist das denn? Was machst du denn die letzten 15 Minuten?
Oh, weiß nicht. Kühlschrank leer essen.
Du kannst doch jetzt einen Timer in 15 Minuten setzen. Kühlschrank leer essen.
Na, bei Tim haben wir das ja schon gemacht. Ich versuch grad hier noch die letzten Hörer glücklich zu machen mit ihren Soundproblemen.
Genau, weil...
Die soll mal klarkommen.
Naja, ist halt hier alles im Fluss, ne? Ihr wisst ja, wie es ist. Ohne Änderung kein Fortschritt. Und nichts wird hier mehr angestrebt als......der Fortschritt.
Aber wie ich ja vorhin schon im Vorgespräch meinte, als ich hier letztens beim, also gestern hier beim Hans war, der auch so ganz viel Elektronik-Equipment rumstehen hat, ging es so, ja, er spielt auch ein bisschen Gitarre und macht aber alles am Rechner und so. Und dann ging es so darum, okay, was machst du, was mache ich? Und dann hat Hans halt angefangen, so sein Zeug zu konfigurieren. Das war halt auch so ähnlich so wie hier, immer so, ja, hier die Ableton-Spur, da kommt aber nichts und hier ein Regler und da nochmal Powercyceln und ja, ach so, jetzt wo kommt das Rauschen her? Und mhm. Dann hab ich so gemeint, Hans, guck mal, weißt du, was ich machen muss, um mein Zettelband starten zu kriegen? Hab so den Switch beim Amp angeschaltet, meinen Stecker für das Effektbord eingesteckt und schon kam da dicker Sound raus. Und dann meinte Hans so, ja, stimmt, hm, ich hab sowieso schon überlegt, meine ganze Elektronik-Equipment zu verscheuern. Also, ähm, der Trend, kann man nicht ja auch Podcasts wieder analog aufnehmen? Also, Showen so mit der Brücke dann ins Internet und so, aber so die ganze Technik hier, so ohne Ableton, so ohne Computer. Das geht? So mit extra, einfach nur so dedicated Hardware ohne Software, ohne MIDI über Ethernet oder was auch immer, dieser ganze Trödel.
Ich würde sagen, das kostet 10- bis 100-fache von dem, was du jetzt hast und weniger Stress hast du damit auch nicht.
Ich bin halt oldschool, ich bin halt auf der Suche nach dem Volldigitalen.
Ja, das geht schon eine Weile, ne? Also ich mein jetzt so generell, weil ich hab irgendwie letztens bei meinen neuen Lieblings... Also eigentlich kündige ich es fast schon als Startseite für meinen Rechner einrichten. So am Audio Equipment rumnerden, das geht gar nicht. Jeden Tag dreimal. Da gibt es ja auch so tolle Ratgeber und da habe ich mich jetzt...
Hat er wieder geschafft, der Hucke, mit dem Thema, ne?
Voll reingefahren hier. Habe ich ja hier irgendwie digital Audiowandel, also Audio Interfaces, recherchiort, ne? Und da gibt es halt bei Tomann auch so schöne Guides, da stand halt auch so Historie der Computer Audio Interfaces und damals mit dem C64 und dann irgendwie auch mit dem Soundblaster und... Ach echt?
Soweit holen die da aus?
Ja, und dem einen machen sie das ja. Na, ich dachte, ehrlich gesagt habe ich da total an dich gedacht, als ich diese ganzen Sachen gelesen habe, weil das erinnerte mich so auch an als guter Startpunkt, du kaufst ja auch bei hast bei Tomann wahrscheinlich auch schon Millionenbeträge hinter......gelassen.
Ich gelte da als guter Kunde, glaube ich.
Und die Ratgeber, da werden sogar Podcasts erwähnt, als Anwendungsfall, also wenn man jetzt nur podcasten würde wollen, dann würde diese Setup sich empfehlen.
Was ist lachend, bei Tomann werden Podcasts sogar gehört. Weiß ich aus mehreren ersten Quellen.
Aber jetzt lache ich gar nicht, was machst du denn nun?
Später reinschneiden.
Wir grüßen auf jeden Fall unsere Hörer in Burg Rehbach. Ich war da auch schon mal.
Nein, von Erlangen. Ich war da letztens auch mit Google Street View. Und hab mich mal vor die Haustür gestellt und war ja ein bisschen überrascht, dass ihr Laden von außen ja doch, also du meintest ja, irgendwie ist so ein bisschen gewachsen und so. Das sieht ja aus wie so ein mutiertes Einfamilienhaus, wo irgendwie immer noch was so dran gedängelt ist und ihr großes Versandlager, das ist halt ja dann so auf der anderen Seite vom Acker, das ist auch episch groß. Ich dachte halt ihr Store wäre halt vielleicht auch so, wie das Musikstore in Köln, das ist doch auch so ein großer...
Ja, jetzt seid Neuesten. Ich kenne die Alten ehrlich gesagt nicht, aber die haben ja alles komplett neu gebaut und bei Thomann ist so diese ganze Verkaufsabteilung total gewachsen. Das ist so richtig so, wie so eine Pilzkolonie so hinten, diesem ursprünglichen Haus mal so hinten aus dem Arsch rausgewachsen. Und der ganze Logistikteil ist dann natürlich komplett clean neu da auf die Wiese gesetzt worden.
Ja, vor allen Dingen war das auch so, da hast du so eine Tour auf der Webseite auch, so irgendwie so QuickTime VR-mäßig oder irgendwie so. Du kannst immer so durch die einzelnen Stationen durch und dann noch ein bisschen 360 Grad. Stimmt, Java. Dann kommst du halt auch so in diese PA-Abteilung mit so Licht und so weiter. Dann bist du plötzlich in so einer Geisterbahn, wie so eine kleine virtuelle Geisterbahn, fahrt da auch so durchs Turm an. Dann warst du in einem Verstärkerproberaum, der ganz eng und...
Ja, die Räume, wo so viele Gitarren rumhängen, da hab ich natürlich schnell gemieden und dann hab ich ehrlich gesagt sehr viel mehr fürs Hochregallager begeistern können. Also das fand ich irgendwie geiler. Da stehe ich wirklich fasziniert wie so ein kleiner Junge irgendwie.
Darf ich auch mal mit dem Roboter fahren?
Ja, das ist so total voll automatisiert. Also die haben da so drei, haben wir da schon mal drüber geredet?
Naja, dann lass mal das.
Und was mich ja eigentlich überrascht, ich hab dann überlegt, gibt es denn in Berlin vielleicht irgendwie auch mal so ein irgendwas Vergleichbares? Aber in Berlin ist echt, außer dieses Just Music oder Sau und Dummland, wie es früher immer hieß, gibt es ja nicht so richtig was, ne? Das ist echt krass, also ich meine Hauptstadt. Es gibt keinen Apple Store.
Kein Flughafen.
Kein Oper.
Es gibt kein Audio.
Audio kann man sich ja woanders bestellen, ne?
Ja, aber gerade für bestimmte Sachen, so Gitarren oder Instrumente, die will man eigentlich gerne ausprobieren. Und dieses Just Music ist ja so ein...
Naja, aber das kannst du doch da auch machen.
Wo?
Oder kann man da auch... Ist der Gitarrenbereich auch nicht zumutbar?
Bei Just Music? Also ich weiß nicht, ob du schon mal Just Music Erfahrungen gesammelt hast. Und waren die positiv oder negativ?
Nicht in der Gitarrenabteilung.
Ich glaube, die sind so generell so eher uncool. Also ich weiß nicht, die sind...
Der Laden ist so groß.
Ist der?
Nee. Der ist nicht klein.
Aber auch nicht so wahnsinnig groß. Im Vergleich zu Thomann oder sonst was.
Ich weiß nicht, was die da noch hinten raus haben.
Es wäre ein okayer Laden, wenn die Leute sich auch so kundenorientiert und bemüht und so weiter. Manchmal kann man Glück haben und man gerät so an den einen, der gerade so den richtigen Kaffee getrunken hat oder so, der richtig gebootet ist, und die anderen sind aber alle in so einem komischen Modus.
Latent ungefickt.
Um es jetzt mal mit Tims Worten zu sagen.
Welcher Verkäufermodus ist das? Also wodurch drückt sich das aus?
Ich weiß nicht, ich hab das immer schlimmer verglichen. Wenn du da reinkommst und sagst, ah ja hier, ich hab ne tolle Band, ich brauch jetzt geiles Equipment. Dann hast du immer so das Gefühl mit so gescheiterten Ex-Musikern zu reden, die dir nicht gönnen, dass du auf der Bühne stehst und nach dem Stage-Dive auch tatsächlich aufgefangen wirst, die sich da irgendwie auf die blutige Nase geholt haben.
Ja, die sind halt auch wirklich nicht so kundenorientierte, lösungsbemüht. Also es ist halt wirklich, gehst da rein, sagst immer, ja kannst mal da hinten gucken. Zum Beispiel bei Thomann, ich hab letztens was bestellt, da war das Netzteil scheiße, hab ich denen eine Mail geschrieben, kam sofort der Anwalt, hier ist dein Retourschein, mach mal und schick mal und wir schicken dir ein neues, oben raus nicht den ganzen Scheiß zurückschicken. War sofort irgendwie da, wenn du dahin gehst und sagst, ich werd dir was zurückgeben, aber da ist aber schon das Label ab hier. Geht nicht, ne?
Da ist was dran, also man merkt das echt, ob die Läden so auf Kunde getrieben werden oder nicht.
Da wurde auch nicht geklatscht bei der Öffnung. Aber auch nicht gekuft. Ja, ich fürchte, das kriegen sie doch noch hin, dass der Leute kommen. Aber auch nur aus purer Verzweiflung, weil es halt nichts anderes gibt in Berlin. Ja, und so was wie Just Music. Wäre es nicht schön, auch für die Podcasts, du hast jetzt deine Kopfhörer gefunden, aber damals hast du dir die einfach so blind bestellt und im Internet recherchiert? Die Kopfhörer? Die hier, die Headsets zum Beispiel.
Die habe ich entdeckt bei Fritz seiner Zeit, bei einem Gang durch die sonstigen Studios, die da noch waren. Da habe ich irgendwie die Teile irgendwo bammeln sehen. Und da bin ich überhaupt erst darauf gekommen.
Verstehe.
Und jetzt ist das der Podcast-Industriestandard?
Ja, ist das so ein bisschen. Wobei ich hier auch gerade Teststellungen erhalten habe von der anderen Firma. Es gibt ja, wir haben ja Country und Western.
Was ist das denn?
Das ist ein Sennheiser HME 26. Das ist das Headset, was Domian trägt. Laut Heugi, ich hab's nicht verifiziert.
Trost ist nicht noch anzufassen.
Den gibt's noch?
Das ist, das ist Domians Headset?
Nein, das ist nicht.
Darf ich's mal anpallen? Darf ich ihn damit mal anrufen?
Du darfst dich mit dem Headset unterhalten. Also das ist auch auf jeden Fall ein sehr, sehr, sehr gutes Headset. Es ist allerdings auch echt sehr teuer. Ich weiß jetzt gerade nicht genau, was der Listenpreis ist, aber ich glaube, diese Kombi, wie sie hier liegt, geht so für 550 über den Tisch. So, und im Wesentlichen kriegst du jetzt auch nicht sehr viel mehr als bei den Teilen, die wir verwenden. Nur, dass das natürlich extrem viel kompakter ist, ne?
Ja, aber so auf den Ohren, das macht doch noch mehr Dampf auf die Ohren oder noch drei Stunden?
Na ja, also ich hab ja auch das HD 25, das hat so ein ähnliches Prinzip, obwohl die Dinger hier sind nochmal ein bisschen anders, deswegen weiß ich das jetzt nicht so genau, das muss ich erstmal testen. Aber das geht schon. Also das ist auch sehr puffig. Also willst du mal anfassen? Domians Hetzer.
Also, ich hab ja nicht kleine Ohren, also irgendwie nicht, ich glaub so eine Kopfhörer...
Kannst du es auch mal aufsetzen? Ich kann dich auch über die...
Na gut.
Das ist eine Falle.
Warte mal, halt stoppt noch nicht.
Ich kann es auch einfach ablegen, dann hört der mich trotzdem.
Ich kann dich einfach hier mal...
Kannst auch einfach abgestreht werden.
In meinem Multimedia-Studio müsste ich dich eigentlich auch über die 6 reinnehmen können. So, jetzt kannst du mal wechseln.
Hört ihr mich auch? Also, es klingt schon mal nicht schlecht.
Ich will auch so eins.
Oh, ich habe Max ausgeschaltet.
Ja, du hast mich ausgeschaltet, das kann ich ja.
Aber das ist toll. Also, es klingt gut, aber ich glaube, mit diesen Ohrteilen, die auf dem Ohr liegen und nicht um das Ohr drum gehen, da werde ich nach einer Zeit...
Was weiß man alles nicht vorher.
Aber ich kenne, ich hatte früher schon andere Kopfhörer und jetzt bin ich erst so richtig glücklich geworden, wo ich diese Bose-Kopfhörer habe, die so schön smooth ums Ohr rumgehen.
Auf jeden Fall ist das Mikrofön schön klein.
Das Mikrofön.
Mikrofönchen. Man sieht euch mal so richtig.
Gibt es das nicht vielleicht auch mit großen Ohrmuscheln?
Schade.
Aber es rumpelt mehr, wenn man am Hals fasst.
Ja, aber da fasst man ja nicht so oft hin, außer man wedert. Ja, also es klingt gut, es hört sich gut an, aber ich würd's nicht gerne drei Stunden lang oder vier Stunden lang auf den Ohren tragen. Ja, das ist mein Fazit.
Sag das mal Domian. Ach, jetzt bist du schon fertig. Willst nicht noch länger ausprobieren.
Nee, es nervt mich jetzt schon, ehrlich gesagt.
Wirklich? Ja, was meinst du, warum Domian auch immer in so einer Sendung macht?
Ja, du kannst auch wieder wechseln. Dann nehme ich dich hier raus.
Kann ich?
Ja.
Willst du das Thema wechseln? Achso, du willst das Mikrofon wechseln?
Also das Ding ist halt...
Heute ist wieder richtig geiles Programm für unsere Hörer.
Ja, sie hören doch immerhin was davon.
Immerhin, immerhin.
Das heißt mal.
Genau. Nein, das Ding ist ja, vielleicht hat Domian einfach ganz kleine Ohren.
So, Dennis, können wir dich besser hören darüber?
Was brummt?
Was hat gebrummt gerade?
Die Lampe.
Nee, die Lampe brummt nicht.
Also, sag mal was, sonst hör ich ja nix.
Das heißt, sag mal was.
Hat mehr Bass, das Ding.
Du musst sagen. Findest du? Hat mehr Bass. Mehr Bass im Kopf, hör mal.
Mehr Bass und ist klarer irgendwie. Also, zum Musikern wär's besser. Aber da brummt wirklich was.
Was?
Kann aber auch sein, dass ich's gehört hab, weil das halt nicht so einen tiefen Bass hat, das andere Mikro, äh, der andere Kopfhörer.
Du meinst, Tim hat hier ne Brummschleife?
Aber ich hab irgendwie das Gefühl, dass das Mikrofon irgendwie nicht...
Aber das hier direkt am Lichtkabel hier lang zu legen, ist ja vielleicht auch...
Lichtkabel?
Na ja, hier von der Lampe. 50, 50 Hertz brumm.
Oh, da, wo kommt das her?
Das Problem liegt woanders gerade.
Das liegt hier rum.
Pass mal deinen Rechner an. Das ist der alte Witz. Das ist zumindest ein echtes McIntosh-Problem.
Hörner und so, höre das jetzt auch eigentlich?
Im Livestream vielleicht, aber auf Honig nimmt das wahrscheinlich alles wieder raus. Das ist zumindest ein echtes Ding.
Aber beim Touchpad nicht, ich kann also schon noch die Maus nehmen.
Das ist ja auch Glas. Was passiert denn, wenn du das Netzteil abnimmst? Dann ist das weg. Ja, musst du einfach mir das Ladegerät geben.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das Netzteil schuld ist, oder?
Aber es ist ja bei den Beyerdynamik-Kopfhörern nicht zum Beispiel.
Doch, ich hör aber auch was.
Na du musst mal sein Laptop anfassen, nicht dein.
Da kommt aber auch was.
Ja.
Aber es ist nicht so stark.
Aber ich hab...
Das ist bestimmt heute wieder eine richtig interessante Sendung für die Hörer, oder?
Ich find schon, immerhin sind sie jetzt sehr live hier bei einem... Also sie scheiden doch eigentlich ein für diesen kleinen Computer-Kaffee-Klatsch, oder nicht?
Ja, aber dieses Brummen und Strom fließt über Laptops, kennt ihr das eigentlich auch?
Ja, wenn das auch so vibriert, wenn man so den Fingern rübergeht und macht so...
Ach, diese Vibration kommt vom Strom.
Ja, man wird da einfach direkt geladen.
Ich dachte, das hätte...
Das ist sozusagen Power-Mac mal auf einer ganz anderen Ebene gedacht.
Stimmt, ich hab mich immer gefragt, woher das kommt. Ich dachte, das wäre so eine Material-Eigenschaft, quasi von dem Alu da oben drauf.
Nur insofern als das... Ich meine, wie gut leitet Alu Strom? Gut, eigentlich, ja. Also irgendwie frage ich mich natürlich ernsthaft, warum... Warum fließt da Strom durch mich durch, wenn ich einen Laptop anfasse?
Aber vielleicht änderst du auch nur das Potential so ein bisschen und also du, durch dich fließt dann der Strom vielleicht gar nicht, sondern du machst einfach so ein bisschen mehr irgendwie...
Doch, da fließt doch irgendwie, da spürt man doch. Also manche spüren es mehr, manche spüren es weniger. Ja, ich kenne Leute, die konnten irgendwie mit diesen Dingern dann auch nicht arbeiten, wenn die irgendwie am Strom waren, weil einfach die ganze Zeit...
Was ich neulich hatte, ich hör, da saß ich im Wohnzimmern, es war sehr, sehr leise und vielleicht lag es auch an der Umgebungstemperatur. Und dann habe ich sowohl beim MacBook als auch beim iPad die WLAN-Karte gehört. Also ich hab so ein leichtes, gar nicht mal, also sehr leises, relativ hohes, aber jetzt nicht fiepsendes so Geräusch gehört.
Ein Zirpen.
Und das war ganz eindeutig mit, sobald ich irgendwas geladen habe, kam das. Und dann habe ich auch mal so einen Blindtest gemacht, sozusagen, nicht hingeguckt und ich konnte es tatsächlich raushören. Also es war jetzt nicht eingebildet.
Aber das macht auch das Netzteil manchmal.
Es war kein Netzteil angeschlossen. Und wie gesagt, sowohl beim iPad als auch beim MacBook.
Der Wahnsinn. 21. Jahrhundert.
Also ich gucke hier gerade diese Doku, die jemand im Chat gepostet hat von diesem Tomaten Hochregallager. Größter Musikversender der Welt wohl.
Es gibt ein eigener Doku über dieses Hochregallager.
Und das ist ziemlich cool.
Ab in die Show Notes damit.
Meinte ich ja.
Das solltest du auf jeden Fall mit aufnehmen, damit die Leute dann auch wissen.
Das schau ich mir nachher zum Einschlafen an.
Ist schon längst in den Show Notes.
Schon längst verbottet.
Schick doch mal jemanden einen Link bitte.
Ansonsten muss ich ja nachher Show Notes legen.
Ja, also das geht nicht, ne? Also entweder du ziehst jetzt einen Strom raus oder setzt dir wieder die Biodynamiks auf.
Nee, ich find die voll toll.
Dann machen wir einen Strom ab.
Aber das Mikrofon klingt doch blecherner, findest du nicht auch?
Ja, das ist ein bisschen dünner auch.
Klarer halt, also das ist nicht blechender, sondern ist jetzt viel deutlicher als vorher.
Findest du das wirklich klarer?
Ich hör mich ja nicht so gut.
Das klingt irgendwie...
Also da fehlt halt der Bass, selbst wenn du Bass über den Kopfhörer gut hörst.
Als Hucke das von aufhat, da konnte ich nicht feststellen, dass der irgendwie blechender klingt.
Also ich finde du klingst ein bisschen so, als ob du ein Bart wärst oder so.
Ja, das könnte ja schon sein. Wenn das Mikrofon dir bessers kommt, kommt auch natürlich das Echo schneller durch.
Also da wäre ich jetzt auch mal wirklich, da wäre ich jetzt wirklich mal dankbar für hier Feedback von den Hörern, wenn ihr das jetzt hier hört, wie ihr das so empfindet.
Ist jetzt der Darth Vader besser oder schlechter als vorher?
Mag ich nicht, klingt viel dünner.
Ja, ein bisschen. Ich meine, da könnte man wahrscheinlich ohnehin, also das Einzige, was ich ja hier noch nicht mache, mit meinem ganzen Setup ist, mit Equalizer zu arbeiten. Wo war nochmal die Musik drin?
Der Braten ist bei 300 Hertz.
Der Braten ist bei 300 Hertz. Auf meiner Party war irgendjemand, der dich leider nicht mehr getroffen hat, weil er dich unbedingt danach fragen wollte, was es denn damit eigentlich für dich aussieht. Aber was heißt das, dass ich bei 300 Hertz am meisten falsch machen kann oder dass man da ordentlich aufreißen muss?
Da muss man aufreißen, also um das nochmal aufzuklären, weil die Frage hat sich tatsächlich auf Twitter auch schon einige Male gestellt. Also die Geschichte ist folgendermaßen, ich kenne so ein paar Leute, also Freunde von mir, die haben eine Band und die hatten lange Zeit einen Soundmann, der sich liebevoll und gratis um die halt immer gekümmert hat bei Konzerten und der auch schon damals bei Jemmy Hendrix und so, da hat er halt auch schon irgendwie mitgemischt und wissen schon, ne so, also ein Roadie mit sehr viel Roaderfahrung oder ein Soundmann mit Roaderfahrung. Und der ist jetzt halt schon ein bisschen älter und erzählt halt auch sehr gerne halt seine Weisheiten, wie das wohl auch bei diesen Soundmännern oder bei allen so Leuten in ähnlichen Jobs so ist. Also auch... Vorm Krieg, genau. Und einmal saßen wir so neben ihm, wie er gerade ein Mischpult rumkonfiguriert ist und dann kam halt einfach dieser Spruch, dass der Braten halt bei 300 Hertz liegt und er hat das auch mit so einer Autorität halt, wie das mit so einer Altersweisheit. Also hier, richtig, also der Braten, der liegt ja bei 300 Hertz, das ist ja bekannt, ne?
Bei 300 Hertz, der Braten liegt.
Hat der so spitze Ohren und so?
Sendungsnamenvorschlag.
Und es bezog sich halt auf Gitarrensound und so. Mehr kann ich dazu nicht sagen. Also wenn ihr mal, also die E-Seite, die tiefe E-Seite bei einer E-Gitarre, oder bei einer Gitarre ist es glaube ich bei 80 Hertz. Und ich glaube, die höchste ist auch nicht irgendwo in der Nähe von 300 Hertz. Das heißt, ich weiß ehrlich gesagt gar nicht genau, ich kann es euch nicht sagen. Wenn ich ihn das nächste Mal sehe, ich verspreche euch, ich frage ihn. Falls jemand da draußen Soundmann selber ist und was damit anfangen kann, könnt ihr das auch gerne versuchen in den Kommentaren zu erklären.
Der Stream huckelt.
Stream off. Ach ja. Immer wieder der gleiche Spaß. Schon wieder?
Wir sind auf jeden Fall schon wieder reconnected, aber das finde ich hart.
Schlimm, schlimm. Bei NSFW ist das nicht? Also du hast bei keinem anderen Podcast dieses Problem?
Nein.
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Es ist ja auch schon auf die letzte Sendung jemand aufmerksam geworden. Da gab es auch schon eine Analyse. Ich weiß nicht, ob die jetzt gerade auch noch läuft oder ob die schon wieder ausgeschaltet ist.
Eine Analyse?
Wahnsinnig, ja. Es wurde da mal hier so meine Leitung etwas analysiert. Ich hatte heute eigentlich vor, da nochmal reinzugehen, aber leider ist mein Arbeitstag heute gestorben. Sodass ich das nicht weiter vertiefen konnte noch vor der Sendung.
Schlimm, schlimm, schlimm.
Also im Chat wird sich jetzt jetzt auch ganz regehaft beschwert, aber Meckert mit der Telekom. Oder bei AVM?
Ja, wir streamen. Also sagt mein Streamer, sagt er streamt. Also was soll ich, ich kann nicht mehr machen, als da rein sprechen. So, aber wir nehmen ja auch auf. So ist es ja nicht. Und die meisten Leute...
Oh, mach mal das andere Headset wieder, klingt wirklich deutlich schlechter.
Gleich erzähl mir das gleich nochmal.
Ja.
Mit einem anderen Headset.
Ob das jetzt schlechter oder nur ungewohnter ist, ist jetzt richtig die Frage.
Nee, das war jetzt wirklich schlechter. Red noch mal ein bisschen, das eben gerade war es nochmal deutlich.
Das trau ich nicht mehr.
Aber was ist denn daran schlechter? Ich hör mich ja sowieso selbst auch noch so, deswegen kann ich es nicht verurteilen.
Das ist halt dünner.
Also ich finde, es klingt schon mehr nach Telefon so.
Also es ist weniger Bass drin.
Nicht nur Bass, sondern es fehlt auch.
Eins merkt man oft noch bei diesen Farbtemperaturgeschichten, dass wenn man sich an eine Farbtemperatur gewöhnt hat, dann ist einem die andere Farbe gleich zu viel. Es könnte natürlich auch sein, dass da zu viel Bass ist und wenn dann natürlich jetzt plötzlich fehlt, obwohl es korrekt wäre, fehlt ein Bass.
Ich setze jetzt noch mal das Teil auf und dann hast du ja den Unterschied zu mir.
Aber mal ganz ehrlich, so bassig wie deine Stimme jetzt über Kopfhörer hört, sich anhört, ist die in echt nicht.
Aber so blechern und dünn wie deine jetzt klingt, ist ja auch nicht.
Ja, du klingst schon so ein bisschen schiffmangig.
Du hast zu viel Trebble oder zu viele Höhen oder weiß nicht irgendwie.
Jemand meinte, du hast zu viel Kompression drauf.
Die können sowieso das gar nicht beurteilen, weil die kennen meine echte Stimme ja gar nicht.
Da ist ja so.
Du hast immer zu viel Kompression drauf.
Ich muss ab und zu Druck abbauen.
Nee, ich hab hier definitiv nicht so viel Kompression drauf. Die Kompression, die ich hier drauf habe, ist wirklich sehr entspannt.
Okay, sagt noch jemand, der meine echte Stimme hört.
Mein Bein ist einfach scheiße.
Die Kompression greift erst spät und dann greift sie aber.
Live-Feedback-System.
Okay, naja, dann mach ich jetzt mal das.
Kann ich ja wieder auch meinen Strom reinstecken.
Jetzt setz mal den Kopfhörer auf, dann hörst du mich noch mal, wie es vorher war.
Ach so, genau, mach erst mal.
Weil sind ja jetzt auch andere.
Genau.
Max kann ich noch mal ganz...
Ist noch minimal bassig, so, okay.
Ich bin minimal bassig.
Na ja, so, also...
Ich dachte, ich hätte so eine Elmer Gunsch-Stimme.
Er ist Elmer Gunsch.
Gunsch.
Elmer Gunsch.
So ein bärsiger Typ, was noch immer der gemacht hat, ich weiß gar nicht.
Elmer Gunsch, der war früher im Fernsehen.
Jaja, das ist schon klar, aber.
Im was?
Ein Österreicher. Ach echt?
Ja.
Und der hat irgendwie so eine Fernsehsendung gemacht, die jeder kannte. Ich weiß jetzt bloß nicht mehr ganz genau, welche das war.
Herzlichen Gunsch.
Elmer Gunsch liest Wolfgang Petri, meinste das? Das geht ins Ohr.
Durch seine markante Sonore und weiche Bassstimme wurde er einer der beliebtesten Radiosprecher und er hielt den Beinamen die Stimme. Neben seiner Tätigkeit beim Radiowahlmoderator, etc. Blablabla.
So, jetzt setzen wir hier einen Kopfhörer auf, dann können wir mitmachen.
Genau, setzen wir jetzt auf und dann gucken wir mal.
Also Elmer Gunsch ist so derjenige, den möchtest du an das Mikrofon rufen, wenn die Bundesregierung den bevorstehenden Atomkrieg verkünden muss. Ja, um einfach maximale Beruhigung zu erzeugen.
Wo man sich dann so denkt, Scheiße, wir sind alle tot, aber geil, Elmer Gunsch.
So, ok, also hast du mich jetzt so ein bisschen gespeichert?
Ja, ich hab dich gespeichert.
Was soll ich noch mehr sagen? Dann wechsle ich mal das Gerät.
Das Mikro ist halt weniger bassig im Vergleich zu dem anderen, aber ich hab fast das Gefühl, das ist halt der echtere Sound.
Ich will das Bayer Kopfhörer-Dings hier haben. Ich behalte es.
Ich will, dass du mir auch so eins bestellst.
Ich hab das nicht bestellt, das ist eine Teststellung.
Na dann will ich, dass du für mich auch so ein Ding testbestellst und dass du dann beide nicht zurückschickst.
Also die Hörer sind nicht begeistert.
Solange wir jetzt schon einen Tomann-Werbung gemacht haben, können sie mal so ein Ding springen lassen.
Das ist ja nicht, das ist ja Sennheiser. Ach so, Tomann könnte das sein.
Das Problem ist, dass du dieses Headset überhaupt nicht kaufen kannst bei Tomann. Weil es zu scheiße klingt.
Ach, das ist ein Sennheiser? Ich fand Sennheiser schon immer cooler.
Also es ist einfach so.
Sennheiser macht halt so die eine Hälfte des Marktes besser und Bayer Dynamik macht die andere Hälfte des Marktes besser.
Und du meinst Sennheiser macht Kopfhörer besser und Bayer Dynamics Mikro?
Das kann man so nicht sagen. Also es gibt...
Mach mal ein bisschen lauter das Ding.
Dieser HD...
Kann ich wirklich kaum verstehen.
Was, meine Stimme?
Ja, ist leiser auch.
Ja, ist nicht ganz so sensitiv. Ich kann ja hier mal ein bisschen...
Du bist jetzt gar nicht die Einzige, du bist die Sechs.
Ich bin die Sechs, Entschuldigung.
So, ein bisschen mehr Gain.
Ja, da kommt nichts.
Vom ganzen Ansprechenden her ist anders. Vielleicht muss man es einfach nur anders positionieren. Das ist halt eine Niere. Was wollte ich hier jetzt sagen?
Hab ich jetzt vergessen.
Ach ja, genau. Das Headset kannst du gar nicht kaufen bei Thomann. Weil die das da nicht anbieten. Also nicht Thomann, sondern Sennheiser. Weil die sind halt irgendwie Fachhändler besessen und so.
Sie haben Tim geschrumpft.
Also ich finde das irgendwie auch...
Ja, ein bisschen schon.
Ich geb's zu.
Das klingt irgendwie anders. Aber vielleicht ist es halt auch eine Frage der Equalizer-Geschichten. Aber ehrlich gesagt, ich mag das Bio-Dynamik auch mehr. Deswegen werde ich jetzt auch wieder umsteigen.
Sehr gut.
Haben wir also nach gefühlten dreiviertel Stunden das Audio-Setup gefunden.
So, da bin ich wieder. Hallo, ich bin's, Freunde. Ihr merkt schon wieder, ihr seid bei Mobamex, der unter der ersten Ausgabe dieser Sendung wohl immer ausführlich über alles diskutiert wird, was Apple betrifft. So auch dieses Mal.
Oh ja, da hab ich auch noch einiges in petto, was in die gleiche Richtung, was genauso viel mit Apple zu tun hat.
Ende des Jahres ist alles so ein bisschen mehr so rantig, oder?
Nee, ist man voll pießig und so.
Aber jetzt haben wir erstmal gelobt. Thomann, Lob.
Ja, das ist ja einfach.
Sennheiser, Klo.
Nein, Sennheiser macht hervorragende Sachen. Ich bin auch scharf auf ein paar Sachen von Sennheiser. Ich will unbedingt mal diese Funk-Teile. Es gibt da nämlich so eine ganz neue Serie, die nicht mehr dieses bekloppte Frequenz-Zulassungsproblem hat. Allerdings sind halt die Marken- und Typenbezeichnungen bei Sennheiser dermaßen wirre, dass man sich das nicht merken kann. Ich kann es mal nachschlagen, weil wir sowieso schon bei dem Thema sind. Weil vorher gab es halt so Frequenzbereiche und du musst halt für bestimmte Frequenzbereiche für jede Aufnahmesession dir dann noch mal eine Ausnahmegenehmigung oder eine Hauptgenehmigung oder eine Anmeldung.
Oder so was. Weil es in der Nähe des E-Plus-Bands oder so lag?
Ja, beziehungsweise, weil es einfach generell Frequenzbänder sind, die dann eben Anmelde pflichtig sind. Moment, müssen wir kurz hier nach dieser Mail suchen. Gibt's da noch die, die dann mit diesen Deck-Telefonen konkurrieren? Et cetera. Es ist so verworren, dass ich das jetzt auch nicht weiter beschreiben kann.
Leute, erzähl mal weiter. Hier sagt einer, Gain führt Tim wieder ein bisschen runter.
Ihr habt's aber auch wirklich. Ja, finde ich auch.
Nimmt euch zurück.
Ne, eigentlich fordert ruhig mehr.
EW 1G8-Serie.
1G8-Serie, genau.
Das sind die Dinger, die jetzt irgendwie unproblematisch sind. EW100, G3, 1G8. Das geht einem doch von der Zunge.
Ach, das ist ja ein Nachfolger von dem EW1 300 G7, oder?
Tralala. Ich glaube, dieses 1G8 ist jetzt die Extension hinter diesem ganzen Kram, die anzeigt, dass man das nicht jetzt auch kaufen kann. Na ja, mal gucken. Das mache ich aber dieses Jahr nicht mehr. So, na ja. Also ist halt so ein bisschen immer so eine Sache hier mit dem Audio. Man lernt, ne? Ich bin ja ja auch Novize und habe da auch keine Ahnung gehabt bis vor wenigen Jahren und ehrlich gesagt habe ich immer noch keine Ahnung.
Also du brauchst, also ich so als der analogen Audio-Fraktion sage ich ja, du brauchst auf jeden Fall Röhren, Mikrofon, Pre-Ems, ja? Also ohne Röhre geht ja mal gar nicht. Die Wärme, das warme Schimmern von so einer tollen Röhre. Leuchtet die auch? Ja klar. Schon schick, also kannst du ja mal bei Tomann oder bei jeder anderen Seite, wir verdienen kein Geld, oder wir kriegen kein Geld von Tomann dafür. Wir sind einfach überzeugte Käufer. Kundenfröhliche noch dazu. Da kannst du ja mal diese Röhren, Mikrofonen, Pre-Ems dir anschauen.
Moba Max, nur echt mit den richtigen Rockröhren.
Ich kann noch so ein bisschen weiter hier die Themenperlenkette auf... Jetzt kommen wir wieder zur Internettechnik. Jetzt wo hier gerade der Stream wieder weggebrochen ist und dein Internet flaky war. Ich hätte euch ja beinahe zu mir dann einfach zu Hause eingeladen zum Podcasten. Aber bei mir ist das Internet auch scheiße. Das kommt aus dem Kabel Deutschland. Ihr wisst noch damals, als es toll war.
Kübel Deutschland. Ist das nicht mehr so?
Naja, Folgendes ist geschehen. Mein 60 MBit DSL, was es schon lange nicht mehr so gibt. Ich habe so einen alten Vertrag und ich bezahle auch viel zu viel, wie ich kürzlich festgestellt habe. Auf jeden Fall habe ich 60 MBit auf dem Vertrag. Aber es fühlt sich an wie 16 MBit. Und das ist konstant. Und das ist jetzt viel zu lange. Und dann habe ich mal angerufen und mit dem Techniker gesprochen. Er meinte, ja, sind zu viele Kunden auf dem Knoten. Wir wissen das. Wir bauen das bald aus. Aber alles, was ich jetzt erstmal tun kann, ist den Monat nicht zu berechnen. Das ist ja schon mal eine Ansage.
Von sich aus angeboten?
Nachdem er angerufen hat.
Der Kundensupport bei Kabel Deutschland ist echt top. Du kommst sofort ran und die sind freundlich. Und die haben auch kundenorientierte Lösungen. Dann hat mich jetzt der Kundendienst, also nicht der technische, sondern der die Sales Droids angerufen. Und die meinten halt, sie bezahlen ja quasi das Doppelte von unserem aktuell teuersten Tarif. Fast. Und da könnte man mal als erste Maßnahme, dass er halt runter drosseln, diesen Preis. Und dann kriegen sie jetzt das 100 MBit Paket zum halben Preis, von dem was ich jetzt gerade noch gezahlt habe, weil ich mich ja nicht gekümmert habe.
Mit 16 MBit?
Wie bei Alice früher. Nee, also jetzt geht es halt auf 100 MBit und die Kabel Deutschland-Jungs meinten, das wäre halt jetzt dann auch DOCSIS 3 Standard und wäre ja auch auf einer anderen Leitung und es wäre alles viel tollerer und dann würde ich halt auch wieder deutlich mehr kriegen. Ist jetzt noch nicht passiert, aber falls andere Leute, die auch irgendwie nicht so dieses 100 MBit Paket bei Kabel Deutschland gebucht haben und vielleicht auch sich wie 16 MBit User fühlen, oder auch nur einen Bruchteil von dem kriegen, was sie eigentlich bezahlen, den empfehle ich doch mal mit dem Kundendienst zu telefonieren, weil da ist durchaus drin, dass ihr dann zumindest deutlich günstigere Preise oder zumindest Erstattungen bekommt. Also die haben sich da nicht so. Man muss halt selber anrufen. War ja bei Alice früher auch so. Die haben ja auch immer das Internet billiger gemacht, aber man musste halt selber sich kümmern und dann mal anrufen und glaube einmal 10 Euro bezahlen pro Umstellung und dann konnte man aber massiv viel Geld sparen. Also es ist nicht von alleine passiert, sondern man musste halt selber sich kümmern. Und da könntet ihr euch vielleicht auch nochmal kümmern. Ja, also wenn dann dieses Upgrade auf 100 MBit auch mit Modem-Tausch verbunden ist...
Was heißt denn das für den Upload?
Nur 6 MBit.
Und wofür kann man die eigentlich real nutzen? Weil Cable Deutschland, die sind auch bekannt dafür, dass sie Bad Torrent und sowas ordentlich...
Na ja, ich glaube bei Cable Deutschland war das so oder ist es auch immer noch so, dass jetzt so... Ich weiß nicht 100%ig, aber eigentlich hast du da so ein gewisses Traffic-Kontingent, bevor sie dich halt drosseln sozusagen auf bestimmten Protokollen. Also du kannst schon BitTorrent benutzen, aber wenn du jetzt halt wirklich da so eine Seatbox betreibst oder wirklich 24-7 die Torrents runterpfeifst, dann machen sie dir tagsüber die Leitungen dünn für BitTorrent. Und das hat vor allen Dingen halt mit tatsächlich wohl Quality-of-Service zu tun, wenn man den Herrn aus den Network Operations glauben darf, weil ja auch Kabelschert Medium ist und so weiter und die dann schon ein bisschen aufpassen müssen, weil sie ja auch Telefon darüber und Fernsehen und was auch immer alles machen. Und da ist dann BitTorrent nicht die höchste Priorität im Zweifel.
Ja, das ist ja irgendwie noch nachvollziehbar, aber es ist nicht so, dass es pauschal ist.
Soweit ich das noch in Erinnerung habe, ist das nicht pauschal, sondern...
Also mein Kumpel ist ja Hardcore-Downloader und bei dem werden, glaube ich, alles, was irgendwie abends bei dem bei 512nb ankommt, dann bleibt es stehen direkt. Kannst du mitschneiden, also...
Echt abends? Also zur Prime-Time sozusagen?
Also YouTube geht bis zu so einer gewissen Stelle und dann geht nix mehr, bleibt einfach stehen.
Also nicht mal Bit-Torrent oder sowas, sondern ganz normale HTTP-Downloads.
Da hast du erst der End-Up dann oder irgendwie so, oder das wirklich nur noch so Kilobyteweise. Aber der ist auch wirklich, also der ist bestimmt Dauer am Limit, also ich denke, ich weiß nicht, ob das bei allen so ist, aber bei ihm kannst du, wenn du einen Download irgendwo machst, 512 MB und dann bleibt's stehen.
Der ist wahrscheinlich schon auf so einer Liste.
Wahrscheinlich, ja.
Wir haben jetzt bei uns im Büro schnelles Netz. Also richtig...
Ja im Büro hab ich auch schnelles Netz.
Echte 100 MBit seit zwei Tagen. Und ich war jetzt heute den ersten Tag wieder so richtig da und ja, das ist schneller. Kann man nicht anders sagen, das ist schon irgendwie relativ flott. Aber dann merkt man auch mal, ich hab gestern so, was ist das vorher? Na okay, ich wüsste nicht, wie das Netz da vorher war. Aber es ist so, diese 50 MBit, die ich zuhause habe, die sind eigentlich schon ganz okay von der Telekom. Also ich hab zwar manchmal das Gefühl, dass das WLAN nicht so richtig macht und sowas, aber ich hab irgendwie eine neue Version von einer App gebaut und die dann so bei Hockey-App hochgespielt. Das ist schon im Vergleich zum Büro, im Vergleich zum Büro vorher, ganz massiv schneller. Also das geht schon so mit ein, zwei Mega...
Ich hab dem Kabel Deutschland-Teche gesagt, also es fühlt sich an wie 16 MBit und das LTE ist schneller als mein 60 MBit DSL. DSL ist es ja nicht. Und dann hat er auch gemeint, ja, ist ein bisschen voll da bei ihnen auf dem Knoten. Jetzt knoten nicht so voll. Seitdem das Kabel Deutschland angefangen hat mit dieser Werbung, ist es scheiße geworden. Ja, ich weiß. Ach ja. Also ich mein, wir haben ja letztes Mal schon geheult wegen diesem ganzen Internet und so. Und auch natürlich aus gutem Grund, weil es ja hier so flaky war. Aber es ist wirklich ein Trauerspiel, dass Faser so teuer ist. Die Telekom gab es ja auch eine Meldung irgendwie. Oder es war zumindest, hat Tobias gemeint, dass die jetzt gar nicht mehr so scharf drauf sind auf Fiber to the Home. Und auch die Bundesregierung sagt jetzt ja, also wir fördern jetzt den Ausbau von Glasfaser oder Breitbandanschlüssen nicht. Das regelt der Markt.
Jaja, der Markt ist ja bekannt dafür, dass man sowas regelt.
Genau und also LTE ist scheinbar jetzt erstmal unsere beste Option auf schnelles Internet.
Ich will endlich IPv6 nach Hause haben.
Bei der Telekom gibt es das jetzt.
Bei der Telekom sei das jetzt der Fall.
Aber nur, wenn einen neuen Anschluss dir holt.
Bei Kabel Deutschland. Das Problem ist halt bei den Neuanschlüssen, also auch bei Kabel Deutschland ist das so. Und ich vermute, dass es andere Provider auch machen. Dann kriegst du halt als neue Kunde eine native V6-Adresse, aber carrier grade, nicht V4. Das heißt, dein V4 ist auf Carrier-Seite oder Provider-Seite genattet. Und nur das V6 ist nativ sozusagen. Und das ist halt... Auch scheiße. Deswegen hab ich jetzt auch ein bisschen Angst vor dem Upgrade auf die 100 MS und neues Modem. Nicht, dass du dann halt auch wieder...
Kein vernünftiges V4 mehr hast.
Kein vernünftiges V4 mehr, aber das ist... Ach, 21. Jahrhundert. Wo bist du?
Also wir hatten jetzt...
Wir hatten jetzt im Gegensatz zum letzten Mal hier keinerlei Internet-Trennung. Also wir mögen den Kontakt zum Streaming-Server verloren haben, aber es macht nicht den Eindruck, als ob das am DSL liegt.
Sag ich mit Mammel...
Wir sind ja auch nie aus dem Chat rausgeflogen und nichts.
Xenum ist schuld.
Keine Ahnung, weiß man ja nicht.
Übrigens, Hans hat dieses Google-Capture auch, und der ist auch bei der Telekom, das scheint. Also wirklich so ein... Hattest du jetzt auch dieses Google-Capture?
Laufend.
Ich hab das jetzt auch ständig seit ein paar Wochen.
Ich hab Hans gesagt, dass du das auch hast, oder hier bei Max, der war erstmal total erleichtert, weil er dachte schon... Ja, aber es kann doch nicht sein, dass er jetzt über Monate aus dem Telekom...
Ja, aber die Telekom macht das nicht.
Ich sag, wenn man Telekom darauf anspringt, ist das nicht unser Problem?
Weil ich das in anderen Netzten noch nicht gesehen hab.
Aber ich hab auch Telekom zu Hause und ich hab's nicht.
Vielleicht sollten wir mal kurz erklären, worüber wir eigentlich reden. Also wenn man bei Google sich irgendwie kontaktiert, übers Web, suche, was auch immer, also bei mir kommt so im Schnitt 3, 4, 5 Mal am Tag, wenn manchmal auch richtig nervig, ganz häufig hintereinander. So eine Capture-Angabe. Ich muss erstmal ein Capture eingeben, bevor er mir glaubt, dass ich irgendwie ein Human bin und hier berechtigt bin, da die Suchtdatenbank abzufragen.
Genau das gleiche hab ich auch.
Und jetzt gibt's ja so einen fiesen Arsch in Berlin, der irgendwie eine Telekom-Leitung nutzt, um irgendwie...
Vielleicht sind es ja auch iOS-User, die sie rausfiltern, weißt du. Mittlerweile erkennen sie irgendwie daran, wie getippt wird oder so.
Das ist ja nicht nur iOS, das ist ja auch Mac. Also bei mir ist es ganz klar so, wenn ich im Büro bin, ist es überhaupt nicht. Und sobald ich zu Hause bin, geht's los.
Und ich hab das nirgendswo anders, außer bei Leuten in Telekom-Netz bisher gehabt. Also es muss schon irgendwie mit irgendwelchen Netzblöcken von der Telekom zu tun haben, würde ich mal sagen. Also irgendwie, dass da irgendwas Komisches passiert, was Google veranlasst, gleich mal das Ganze, den ganzen Blog da als Shady.
Ich wundere mich, dass wenn man einmal gesagt hat, ja, ich bin jetzt hier hinter dieser IP-Adresse und ich bin wirklich ein Human, dass das dann auch nie reicht. Dass es dann irgendwie ein paar Minuten später gleich wieder hinterfragt werden muss. Was denken die, dass ich irgendwie innerhalb weniger Minuten von einem Humanoiden zu einem Androiden gehe? Google, so schnell kriegt ihr mich nicht konvertiert.
Es gibt wahrscheinlich viele so Erweiterungen für...
Ach, du benutzt Androiden, ich benutze Humanoid.
Aber wahrscheinlich gibt es viele so Erweiterungen und Plugins, die dann so reingehen, die so lange aufhören zu suchen, bis dann mal wieder jemand einen Capture eingegeben hat, dann das entsprechende Cookie klauen und dann fröhlich weiter ihre Anfragen stellen oder so was. Also insofern, keine Ahnung, was da bei Google abgeht. Ich würde sagen, die Telekom und Google, die sollten sich mal ein bisschen zusammensetzen, mal einen Kaffee trinken und das Problem gemeinsam lösen, aber wahrscheinlich wird das jetzt dann irgendwann 2018 noch...
Ja, Google könnte einem ja auch mal erklären, warum. Also immer diese Maßnahmen, ohne zu erklären, warum sie die jetzt machen. Man könnte das ja mal hinschreiben oder sowas.
Na, irgendwas gibt ja auch eine Hilfe-Seite, auf der keine Hilfe drauf steht.
Das ist großartig.
Besonders nervig ist es wirklich am iPhone, das einzutippen, weil dann diese Capture... Das ist natürlich auch nicht mal so gebaut, dass sie könnten ja...
Dafür ist dein VPN gut, auf dem iPhone, dass du den Google-Knopf benutzen kannst.
Vielleicht sollte man ja wirklich einfach zu Bing gehen.
Aber raten wir doch mal lieber ein bisschen über Apple. Kommen wir noch zu diesen gefühlten Problemen.
Sinken.
Habt ihr eigentlich alle iPhone 5s?
Treffer unversenkt.
Du auch.
Ich war schon als erster unter uns.
Max war der Erste.
Ich war der Erste.
Hallo?
Aber du warst nicht da.
Ja, ich war nicht da.
Stimmt, der Roddy ist der Einzige, der keins hat. Deswegen haben wir den heute auch ausgeladen.
Genau.
Falls ihr es gemerkt habt, der Roddy ist nicht so ruhig heute, sondern der ist nicht da.
Der darf nicht kommen.
Der sitzt in den USA und bedrängt sich.
Der Zauber ist zu weit weg.
Das Ziel ist zu weit entfernt.
Jetzt zu den gefühlten Problemen. Ich hab das Gefühl, ich weiß nicht, hab ich schon mal erzählt, ich hab jetzt ein neues. Aber ich hab dasselbe Problem, dass ich irgendwie gefühlt, weil das ist ja schwer zu sagen, häufig, und ich weiß halt jetzt nicht, ob es an iOS 6 liegt und an diesen Google Maps, an diesen Apple Maps, was aber eigentlich jetzt damit eigentlich gar nichts zu tun haben kann, weil das ja generell so ist, nämlich das Ding ortet mich schlechter. Also ich hab zum Beispiel so Sachen, ich fahr durch Deutschland, und dann hängt meine Position für Stunden in einem Ort, wo ich einfach auch schon als Stunden nicht mehr war. Und ich hab irgendwie 3G und Internet und alles und ich frag mich warum...
Und GLONASS und...
Ja, und selbst wenn ihr die Scheißsatelliten nicht seht, irgendwie fahr ich da bestimmt durch tonnenweise WLANs und so ein bisschen Internet. Ich meine, im Zug ist es immer so ein bisschen schwierig da eine Aussage zu machen, wo ein Telefon gerade was richtig macht, aber es ist auch nicht nur im Zug so. Kennt ihr das?
Nö.
Kein Problem.
Das Problem mit den Maps-Things, dass man nicht gefunden wird?
Nee, das ist die Positionierung, also dieses Wo bin ich-Ding. Einfach... Manchmal nicht immer, manchmal einfach...
Also ich hatte das schon mal, dass es nicht updatet, aber das war jetzt in ein Mal von 200 Benutzungen oder so.
Dafür geht bei Huckel Finds Friends nicht.
Bei dir geht's nicht.
Bei dir geht's nicht. Ich seh mich.
Ich seh alle anderen auch. Ich seh auch alle anderen, nur dich nicht.
Okay, aber das heißt, du hast dein iPhone 5 wegen dieses Problems tauschen lassen?
Nein, nein, nein, die Kopfhörer-Buchse war kaputt.
Na ja.
Und du hast eine hässliche Höhle drum.
Ja, aber die hässliche Höhle führt dazu, dass dieses Telefon nicht kaputt ist. Das wäre es mittlerweile wahrscheinlich schon.
Schmeißt du das so oft runter?
Hab ich schon mal eine Beule gezeigt hinten drin?
Ist schon häufig.
Wow, wie hast du das denn geschafft?
Runtergefallen.
Ja, das ist halt so Gravity, weißt du? Dinge fallen runter. Und dieses Telefon ist auch schon häufig gegen den Boden gegangen, seitdem es diese Höhle dran hat, aber bisher sieht es halt noch aus wie neu.
Das ist eine Verschwörungstheorie. Diese Hüllen fördern das Unterfallen von Telefonen.
Es sieht aus wie neues Telefon in einer hässlichen Höhle.
Ich finde diese hässliche Höhle ehrlich gesagt ist die beste Höhle, die ich je hatte. Ist von Belkin, habe ich hier schon mal erwähnt, glaube ich. Das ist die, wo du gleich noch eine weiße mit dazu bekommst. Und die funktioniert einfach. Ach du hast mir die geklaut, ne?
Hab ich dir doch gesagt. Ich geb dir nicht wieder her. Ich brauch die. Naja, ich weiß nicht. Die ist ein bisschen glitschig irgendwie, so dieses Gummi. Also ich fand den Apple Bumper ja eigentlich am coolsten. Ich hätte gerne wieder einen Apple Bumper gehabt. Ich hab mir schon mal eine Farbe ausgesucht. Orange nämlich wollte ich mal haben, so Tauchermäßig. Aber die gab's dann irgendwie nicht mehr. Apple mag irgendwie, sie wollen halt, dass man ihr schickes iPhone halt so rumhält. Ich seh das ja auch ein. Es ist schon wirklich schick. Und ohne Höhle sieht es schon wirklich schick aus. Aber wie gesagt, nachdem es mir runtergefallen ist und ich gleich auf der Rückseite eine dicke Beule drin hatte, dachte ich mir, oh nee, ich brauch was.
Ich find an diesen Bumpern immer so doof, die könnten ein bisschen glatter sein. Ich finde, das ist so anstrengend, also nicht anstrengend, es schiebt sich nicht so gut in die Hosentasche rein.
Das ist halt aber genau das Ding. Man muss da die goldene Mitte finden, weil das Teil hier zum Beispiel ist weniger glibberig als das, was ich davor hatte. Und es ist mir schon manchmal ein Hauch zu wenig glibberig, weil ich finde es als einen riesen Vorteil, wenn die Dinger...
Ein Hauch zu wenig glibberig.
Ja, was ich haben will, ich will das Ding einfach irgendwo gegenlehnen, hinstellen, Armaturenbretter, weißt du, und will, dass es dann einfach da bleibt und nicht irgendwie runterrutscht und auf den Boden fällt. Und das geht einfach nur ab so einer gewissen Viskosität und ja, so eine nicht-lineare Viskosität wäre vielleicht ganz gut. Dass das Ding sozusagen, umso schneller es sich bewegt, umso glibberiger muss es werden.
Und wenn es dann kurz vor der Lichtgeschwindigkeit ist, dann würde das gesamte Universum ausbremsen.
So wie U-Blick.
U-Blick? U-Blick, kennt ihr U-Blick nicht? Doch, das hatten wir früher immer auf dem Kongress auch.
Der kleine Bruder von Obelix oder was?
Nee, U-Blick. U-Blick schreibt sich O-O-B-L-I-C-K.
Oder O-Black.
Also Blick mit E oder mit A, dann gibt's mit I oder mit E, das sind so unterschiedliche Sachen. Und du kannst halt einfach zum Beispiel Stärke nehmen. Kauf einfach, geh in den Supermarkt und kauf dir einfach so ein Paket Stärke und dann mischst du das mit Wasser und machst das in so ein Eimer rein. Und du musst dann so das richtige Verhältnis haben, und zwar hier in der Wikipedia heißt es ein Teil Wasser bis anderthalb bis zwei Teile Stärke. Also relativ viel Stärke.
Kann das dann das deine Netzmal wieder tot ist?
Ja, allerdings. Also anscheinend können sie es ja nicht schreiben, aber ich hab auch grad keins.
Du, ich hab hier einfach nur meinen Lastcast laufen und der versucht zu diesem Streaming-Server zu wenden.
Der Streaming-Server abkackt. Ich hab auch.
Ich hab kein Netz.
Auch.
Ah, jetzt ist auch die Internetverbindung getrennt worden. Ah ja, okay. Jetzt sind wir hier.
Na Gott sei Dank.
Ist egal, lass uns einfach weiter reden. Ja, lass uns weiter reden.
Also Internet ist da. Ich wollte jetzt grad hier Hublik.
Genau.
Hublik.
Ich wollt grad Hublik googeln und das ging halt nicht.
Warum sagt der mir denn das irgendwie?
V6, sag mal, kann das sein, dass du connectest, aber...
Kann das sein, dass du kein DNS hast oder so eine Späße?
Wie, dass ich kein DNS hab?
Weil das Netz an sich scheint noch problemlos zu gehen, weil ich grade hier so Seitenaufbau sehe und da laden Bilder. Aber...
Hast du keinen eigenen DNS dabei eingetragen?
Doch, ich hab hier Google-DNS eingetragen. Ist das der Fehler?
Ist du irre? Da kommen bestimmt deine komischen Captures her.
Den hab ich nicht mehr bekommen. Ich hab keine. Ich dachte schon, mit Google-DNS könnte man das ganze Problem vielleicht lösen und wollte jetzt schon extra meine blöde Speedport fritzen und weißte teufel was. Ah, damit ich mir das aussparen kann.
Also ich kann hier zu Xenim auf V4 pingen oder cccde und es geht. Gibt nicht mal Packet Loss.
Jetzt sind wir auch gerade on Air.
Jetzt sind wir gerade on Air.
Kann das sein, dass das Xenim über V6 connectet?
Nein, das ist leider nicht so. Das wird toll.
Wie streamen durch einen Tunnel durch, ja?
Also ich kann ja hier die vom Internet-Anbieter zugewiesenen DNS V4 Server verwenden.
Ich hab eh meinen eigenen eingetragen.
Man weiß nie, was richtig ist. Soll ich jetzt nochmal erzählen, was es mit Ublick auf sich hat?
Ja, also wir haben diese Stärke jetzt mit Wasser im richtigen Verhältnis gemischt.
Achso, dann ist das diese newtonische Dingsbombs.
Nicht newtonische. Non-Newtonian-Fluid. Also nicht lineare Viskusizität ist der Begriff. Und das Besondere an der Mischung Wasser und Stärke ist, also ich kann das auch jedem, der das jetzt zum ersten Mal hört und nicht gleich weiß, ah, Ublick, das müsst ihr echt mal ausprobieren. Also Stärke kurfen und dann in der entsprechenden Mischung irgendwie anmischen und schon das Anmischen ist eine Erfahrung. Weil umso mehr du das halt versuchst zu bewegen, umso fester wird es. Das heißt, du kannst deine Hand da oben sanft reinstecken und das ist so eine ganz glipschige, mehlige, zipprige, sapschige Masse. Und wenn du dann deine Hand schnell aus dem Eimer rausziehst, hast du halt den ganzen Eimer am Arm.
Und sobald das dann wieder los ist, kropft es dann wieder runter.
Genau, weil es wird in dem Moment fest wie Beton. Es ist so, als hättest du gerade in so einem Beton-Eimer gefasst und 10 Stunden gewartet. Und in dem Moment, wo du dann aber verharrst und dann eben keine Kräfte mehr auf diese Fluidität da aufwendest, dann wird es eben auf einmal wieder ganz matschig. Und das ist halt auch ganz lustig, weil auch wenn was runter tropft, es fällt halt, wenn es fällt und keinerlei Beschleunigung erfährt in dem Sinne.
Na doch, die Erdbeschleunigung.
Na, aber wenn es fällt, dann ist es ja bei 0G. Dann ist es halt ganz weich. Wenn es auftrifft, dann setzt du es eben unter Druck und dann wird es wiederum fest.
Und wenn es dann springt, beim Zub auftreffen oder was?
Ja, du kannst auch mit einem Hammer draufhauen, das ist total lustig. Mit einem Hammer draufhauen ist es halt so, als wäre es Beton. Wenn du den Hammer drauflegst, dann sinkt der halt ein und so weiter. Also es ist wirklich spaßig. Und du kannst einfach da Kinder und Nerds und eigentlich generell aufgeschlossene Menschen einfach stundenlang mit beschäftigen, indem du einfach dieses U-Blick anrührst. Wie sind wir jetzt eigentlich drauf gekommen? Ach so, ja genau. Dass du eine Hülle eigentlich ähnliche Fähigkeiten haben solltest. In dem Moment, wo sie sich irgendwie bewegt und irgendwo so Reibungen erzeugt wird, dass sie dann bloß irgendwie anders rumkommt. Naja, der Vergleich greift sie jetzt auch nur zur Hälfte.
Hätte auch eine Beschreibung für die Internet-Leitung sein können. Je schneller man versucht, Daten runterzuladen, desto schwieriger wird es.
Je dringermann es braucht, desto schlechter wird es.
Angeblich gibt es Motorradprotektoren, die so funktionieren. Hab ich mal irgendwo gehört.
Ach so, wo das dann quasi so drinsteckt in den Protektoren?
Genau, und solange es langsam bewegt, passen die sich halt deinem Body an. Und wenn du aber einen Unfall hast, kommt ja der harte Schlag und dann schützt er dich dann halt.
Aber soll das nicht eigentlich eher weich sein? So ein Zeug, der dich Energie aufnimmt?
Na wahrscheinlich ist das so die äußere Schutzhülle.
Ja, irgendwie so. Dass du halt dann später prima auf der Straße lang rutschen kannst.
So bei schussfesten Westen wäre das doch auch geil.
Oh ja, schöner Vorschlag hier, nicht lineare Stream-Biskuität.
Weil die haben wir glaube ich hier schon. Wir müssen einfach langsamer streamen hier.
Soll ich hier nochmal so ein irgendwie Apple-relevantes Thema erwähnen?
Trauen wir uns jetzt nach einer Stunde mit dem ersten Thema?
Ich bin am Montag geflogen mit einem Flugzeug, was ein großer Pain war, weil Montag irgendwie so der beschissenste Tag war, um zu fliegen überhaupt. Nach Düsseldorf. Tegeldüsseldorf. Abends in den Nachrichten wurden nur zwei Flughäfen gezeigt, auf denen es wirklich schlimm ist. Tegel und Düsseldorf und ich war auf beiden. So richtig morgens 2,5 Stunden Verspätung, abends 3 Stunden Verspätung, ihr scheiß Flug. Wegen Streik und Schnee und weiß ja total was.
Kann man immer mit dem ICE hinfahren?
Ja, ich hab's nicht gebucht. Wenn's alles gut gegangen wäre, dann wär's auch okay gewesen. Aber was man beim ICE nicht machen kann, was da nämlich dann ging, ich hab das erstmal mit Passbook, dass wir ernsthaft was machen können. Welchen Flug ist das? Berlin hat Passbook-Support. Die Lufthansa auch?
Angeblich. Ich hab das nicht hinbekommen.
Wie hast du das nicht hinbekommen?
Na, diese Lufthansa ab, die ist so dermaßen wirr und scheiße. Also wenn die Leute nicht sofort gefeuert werden, weiß ich auch nicht wieder, wie sich die Zukunft da entwickeln soll. Aber so was Beknacktes wie diese Lufthansa-App hör ich schon lang nicht mehr gesehen.
Die Lufthansa-App ist das Schlimmste, was man sich vorstellen kann, oder?
Es ist ganz, es ist einfach auf so vielen Ebenen verworren und verkackt, das kann man sich überhaupt nicht vorstellen. Also allein schon dieses User-Interface, mit dem du da begrüßt wirst, mit diesem Piloten-Höhen-Navigation-Scheiß-Dreck.
Das ist das schlimmste Beispiel von Geomorphismus, das man sich vorstellen kann.
Das ist kein Geomorphismus, weil so bucht man normalerweise nicht. Das ist halt das User-Interface eines Piloten, um die Höhe zu machen, aber nicht das User-Interface um Tickets auszuziehen. Also Geomorphismus wäre irgendetwas, was mir das mit der Realität zu tun hat. Das hat nichts mit der Realität zu tun.
Na doch, mit Fliegen irgendwie.
Ja, aber nicht mit der Realität des Buchens.
Ja, also auf jeden Fall.
Ja, man hätte auch irgendwie...
Also es ist wirklich unerträglich.
Es geht gar nicht.
Es ist halt, wenn man diese App startet, dann hat man da so eine, eigentlich so eine Tabellenansicht, es würde problemlos 7 Punkte oder so was aufs Display draufpassen, alles überhaupt gar kein Problem. Dann haben die da so ein bisschen so, das ist wie so ein Höhenmeter gemacht, dass man also Linien sieht, also wie so eine, keine Ahnung was das ist, so horizontalen Messer oder irgendwie so was. Und dadurch passen die ganzen Punkte nicht mehr drauf, man muss also scrollen. Das mit dem Scrollen geht allerdings nicht ganz so gut, weil das sich nämlich der Beschleunigungssensor dafür genutzt wird, um einzustellen, wie das gerade aussieht, das Menü, also wo das gerade hinscrollt. Das heißt, wenn man gerade so in Bewegung ist, so im Taxi zum Flughafen sitzt oder auf dem Weg zum Gate ist, dann verruckelt einem das Ding.
Das darf doch nicht wahr sein.
Ich hab mich immer mit dem Menschen unterhalten, der das programmiert hat.
Ernsthaft?
Ich weiß jetzt leider seinen Namen nicht mehr, weil das ist ganz furchtbar teilnehmend.
Das darf doch nicht wahr sein.
Weil er ist Mobile Max-Hörer und er meinte, ja, ja, wir haben probiert, dem das auszureden.
Ja, ich wollte nämlich gerade sagen, dass es uns bestimmt das Marketing schuld.
Ja, ja, das ist so. Wir haben ihm tausendmal gesagt, das ist ganz unerträglich, aber nein, nein.
Okay, Jungs, dann könnt ihr einfach diese Sendung, den Teil da ausschneiden und dem Marketing zusenden. Wenn ihr sowieso zuhört.
Das ist ja das Allerletzte.
Genau, jetzt sagen wir nochmal genau, wie es ist.
Das ist das Allerletzte.
Wer sich so einen Scheiß ausdenkt, hat seinen Job verfehlt.
Oder sollte sich mal einen neuen Coke-Stealer suchen.
Oder in den Gartenbau gehen oder irgendwas. Aber nicht für Abs zuständig sein, weil das ist einfach mal selbstverliebte Schrottscheiße. Die geht gar nicht. Also das hat mich dermaßen abgeturnt, dass ich keinerlei Bereitschaft hatte, in irgendeiner Form mit diesem Informationsdienst von Lufthansa. Ich muss jetzt mal das Mikrofon ausschalten, weil da quatscht wieder dazwischen. Das geht nämlich jetzt hier. Ja, Sanktionen. Ja, ja, jetzt beschwer dich mal. Du quatschst dazwischen.
Ist doch voll schick.
Ja, ja.
Wenn es nicht so ruckeln würde.
Das ist einfach Dreck, nicht schick. Falsches Wort.
Was halt auch noch wirklich schlimm war, gerade an Tegel. Ich weiß nicht, ob es bei Düsseldorf dann auch, da hatte ich mich so ein bisschen drauf eingestellt. Also ich hab so eine App, die heißt Flightboard, die zeigt einem...
Moment, du warst doch gerade bei dem Passbook. Du bist nur drauf gekommen, weil ja diese Ab-, diese Lufthansa... Ab- kann man das gar nicht nennen. Dieses Ding, ja, dieser Exkrementauswurf einer Marketing-Abteilung, die als erstes an die Wand gestellt wird, wenn die Revolution kommt.
Ach, geht das jetzt danach? Beschleunigungs-Sensor in der App eingebaut, raus!
Das hat mit dem Beschleunigungs-Sensor, das ist einfach von Anfang an scheiße. Es geht ja dann noch genauso weiter, weil du auf allen verschiedenen Ebenen dann irgendwie log in und wenn du dich da nicht einloggen kannst, du musst dir die ganze Zeit immer wieder meine Login-Daten eingeben.
Und die Switches?
Wahnsinnig geworden.
Diese Switches sehen auch immer noch so aus wie bei iOS 4, weil die im Telekom Gold sind. Und die nicht auf die Idee gekommen sind, dass es inzwischen ja hier UI Appearance gibt, wo man das auch umfärben kann nach Berlin.
Ist ja noch schlechter als ID.Jones 11.
Aber es ist mir auch nicht gelungen, da jetzt in irgendeiner Form so ein Passbook rauszubekommen. Bei AirBerlin ist das gelungen.
Bei AirBerlin ist mir das relativ einfach gelungen. Also ich hab ein Check-In hab ich per App gemacht und danach hat er dann irgendwie so verschiedene Varianten angeboten. Ich hab's mir sicherheitshalber sowohl als Passbook als auch nochmal in der App abgespeichert, was auch problemlos ging, außer dass mir die App Bescheid gesagt hat, dass es irgendwelche Luftfahrtbestimmungen verbieten würden, dass man auf einem Telefon mehr als einen Boarding Pass drauf haben darf. Was? Keine Ahnung, ich hab's mir auch nicht so genau durchgelesen. Auf jeden Fall hatte ich dann meine Boarding Pässe in Passbook drin. Und es funktioniert wie beworben. Also du kommst irgendwie zum Flughafen, deine Hosentasche vibriert kurz und du hast dann dieses kleine AirBerlin-Icon auf deinem Log-Screen. Und wenn du das dann aufwählst, dann geht er direkt in den Boarding-Pass auch rein. Und dann hältst du es da über dir, einen Scanner drüber und kannst Flugzeug betreten. Ganz hervorragend.
Das taucht auch automatisch auf?
Das ist automatisch im Log-Screen aufgetaucht, als ich in deinem Flughafen war. Ich hatte ja so ein bisschen Schiss davor, oder was heißt Schiss davor? Ich war ja mal gespannt, wenn man dann mit zweieinhalb Stunden Verspätung, ob dann irgendwann mal der Boarding-Pass so sorgt, ach nee, jetzt muss er ja schon lange losgeflogen sein. Jetzt schmeiße ich den mal wieder weg. Aber das hat er dann auch am Abend, als ich wieder zurückkam, dann hat er mir den alten Boarding-Pass wieder angezeigt. Und ja, aber es hat so weit, also es war wirklich, du nimmst das Telefon aus der Tasche, du brauchst nichts zu machen, du musst keinen PIN-Code eingeben oder sowas, du gehst da rüber, machst das rauf, häkst das kurz über diesen Scanner drüber und gehst ins Flugzeug rein. Das könnte, also es ginge sicherlich noch angenehmer, aber viel angenehmer geht nicht mehr. Was ich auch beeindruckend fand, ist so die komplette Nullreaktion von irgend wem darauf. Also ich hab das letzte Mal, als ich probiert habe, so per Telefon mir, also das war vor anderthalb Jahren, Anfang 2000, so im Frühjahr 2011, hatte ich auch schon mal Check-In im Flugzeug gemacht, im Zug gemacht und hatte dann den Boardingpass nur so als PDF auf dem Handy drauf. Und dann mussten wir aber noch Gepäck aufgeben und dann hat die so, haben sie schon Boardingpass? Ja, auf dem Telefon. Ich druck ihnen das Sicherheitshäuser aber noch aus. Geht immer irgendwas schief. Und jetzt, anderthalb Jahre später, war jetzt auch Business-Flug, also nicht so irgendwie Ferienflieger, sondern schon so irgendwie, ja, Berlin Düsseldorf, da fliegt man ja nicht freiwillig. Da muss man ja schon irgendeinen Jobtermin haben, so montags morgens. Und da hatten mindestens die Hälfte der Leute, hat da nur entweder ihr iPhone oder ihr noch dreieinhalb Leute, Business-Leute, halt ihren Blackberry drüber gehalten und haben darüber den Check-In gemacht. Das fühlt sich schon so ein bisschen wie Zukunft an.
So langsam wagt sich das 21. Jahrhundert aus der Reserve.
Ja. Wird auch Zeit.
Na ja, zwölf Jahre.
Stellt euch vor, die Zukunft, wenn ihr Boarding-Pässe nicht mehr aus Papier.
Drucker funktionieren eh nicht. Wir umgehen einfach das Problem, indem wir einfach das Papier obsolet machen.
Aber diese Flightboard-App, ich glaube, die ist kostenlos. Ich finde die App an sich eher doof, weil die ist halt so ein nachgestelltes Flightboard, wie sie so früher irgendwann war. So ein Flightboard, wie sie früher war. Wir sind schon drei Themen weiter.
Was machst du noch die ganze Zeit, Dennis?
Genau, das sieht halt aus, wie so eine Flughafenanzeige, die mit den Dingsbums irgendwann mal aussah, als sie noch keine Bildschirme hatten. Und es ist doof, weil die können sich keine Flughäfen merken. Man muss immer aus der Liste vorne einen auswählen. Man kann da nicht ein paar Favoriten festlegen. Man kann nicht einmal die Flugnummer eingeben und dann hat er sich die auch gemerkt und dann bleibt das auch dabei. Das kriegt er auch nicht hin. Aber diese App kann anzeigen, wann der Flug gehen sollte und wann er tatsächlich gehen wird. Das ist, wenn man an einem Flughafen sitzt und die zwar überall Bildschirme hängen haben, wann der Flug geht, aber auf dem Bildschirm steht nie drauf, wann er tatsächlich geht, sondern wann er theoretisch gegangen wäre. Ich war da im Sicherheitsbereich drin, schon alles hinter mir und wartete darauf, dass mein Flugzeug oder telefonierte mit Air Berlin, ob ich nicht gleich einen späteren Rückflug kriegen kann, weil das irgendwie alles ganz schön eng geworden wäre, um ein Haar, wenn dann nicht sowieso der Rückflug total verspätet gewesen wäre. Und haben mir offensichtlich so Durchsagen gemacht, so ja, übrigens, das Flugzeug steht jetzt bereit, so mal irgendwie auf einem dieser Bildschirme, dass das auch angezeigt wird, so, übrigens, wir fliegen jetzt, steigen sie mal ein. Dann bin ich dann irgendwie, hab ich das so, last call for flight, blablabla, dann schnell hingerannt zum Gate und da war dann so ein kleiner Vorraum, so ein Tegel halt, wo das so ist, so direkt, wo es reingeht, wo nochmal fünf Plätze waren, wo so drinnen und wo ein Bildschirm hing, auf dem stand dann auch die korrekte Abflugzeug drauf. Ich hab gesagt, können sie nicht irgendwie ein Bildschirm aufhängen, wo das dann auch drauf steht, haben die halt die Dinger, aber es steht doch da. Irgendwie alles so richtig da, hat auch noch nicht die Zukunft. Achso und ja, so Benachrichtigung, dass es zu spät ist oder sowas. Da fragen sie ja, können wir ihnen Push-Notifications zuschicken, damit wir sie informieren können, falls ihr Flug eventuell zu spät sein sollte? Die was bekommen. Also laut Air Berlin ist mein Flug pünktlich. Im Plan soll Informationspolitik ist irgendwie.
Genau, sitzt noch in Tegel und kriegst deine Push-Notification, dass der Flieger in Nüsseldorf gerade gelandet ist.
Herzlich willkommen.
Sag mal, habe ich letztes Mal eigentlich davon berichtet, dass ich hier meinen Mac Pro neu habe installieren müssen?
Nee, du hast davon berichtet, dass du deinen Macbook eher clean installt hast und warst damit nur so semi-zufrieden.
Noch wer Bier?
Ja, du könnt mir noch mal nachlegen.
Ich hab noch.
Keiner atmet wie du, Dennis.
Beste Droge ever, Sauerstoff.
Du kannst gar nicht genug davon kriegen, wa?
Voll der Fasch.
Und du schreist nach Klebkuchen. Du solltest dir Sauerstoff-Klaschen besorgen. zwischendurch mal so einen Shot geben.
So wie bei Blue Velvet.
Wie das so ist. 2012 installieren wir ein Betriebssystem neu. Ich hab nämlich einen Fehler gemacht, einen strategischen. Ich hab in so einem trahnigen Moment dachte ich mir so, ah, die Kiste läuft ja immer noch auf Line. Irgendwie mach ich mal einen Mountain-Line. So, jetzt läuft das auf der anderen Büchse. Nach dem Clean-Install lief es irgendwie auf meinem Laptop halbwegs zufriedenstellend. Siehe da, also so Clean-Install hilft.
Die reinigende Wirkung.
Ja, es war auch wirklich einfach so verharzen, so verkackt. Es ging einfach gar nichts mehr auf dieser Büchse. Und seitdem ist irgendwie okay. Und dann lief das so durch. Soweit alles in Ordnung, installiert. Und nach einer Weile stellte ich da natürlich irgendwie facialpalmierend fest, dass meine ganze Audio-Isarnet-Dante-Ordinate-Geschichte, die ich hier verwende für Recording, einfach nicht online kompatibel ist. Und ich hatte einfach nur noch Knackse und Kratzer und nichts. Ich hatte alles so schön geplant und am nächsten Tag hatte ich irgendwie NSFW irgendwie auf der Liste und ich saß dann hier so am Nachmittag und dachte mir so, oh man, fuck. Und ich hatte natürlich auch nicht, weil ich einfach nicht nachgedacht habe, ich hab zwar jetzt mittlerweile Backups ohne Ende, aber es sind halt alles solche Daten-Backups. Ich hatte halt nicht so einen, ich spiele mal die Platte von eben wieder einen Backup. So, was ich in dem Moment auch gemerkt habe, wie wichtig das zumindest in solchen Situationen ist, dass man dann mal so mit dem Carbon Copy Cloner oder wie heißt dieses andere Tool?
Super Duper.
Super Duper. Ja, was man damit halt relativ easy machen kann, was man theoretisch auch so auf Unix-Ebene gut machen kann, aber diese Tools, die wissen immer so genau, was sich gerade mal wieder von OS zu OS bei den Kommando-Zeilenparametern geändert hat. Von daher kann ich das sehr empfehlen. Hier gleich für die Show Notes, Carbon, Copiclona und Super Duper.
Carbon, Copiclona ist ein tolles Tool.
Hatte ich also auch nicht. Und dann stand ich hier so mit dem Rechner auf Mountain Line und ich überlegte so, wie kriege ich das Ding jetzt offline? Okay, habe ich ja hier eh noch irgendwie im App Store den Installer? Dann lasse ich mir mal den Installer runterladen. 4 GB geht ja hier relativ fix. Aber dauert natürlich auch so ein bisschen. Gestartet, erzählt mir dieser Line Installer, der jetzt unter Mountain Line gestartet wurde, dass das Betriebssystem zu neu sei, um diesen Installer zu starten. Ich dachte mir jetzt mal, bitte, was? Hallo? Ein Installer? Ich meine, dass das Betriebssystem zu alt gewesen wäre. Das hätte ich ja irgendwie eingesehen, aber dass es zu neu ist? Ich meine, das Ding soll im Wesentlichen diesen Rechner booten.
Und vorher die Podcast-Show fertig machen.
Ja, aber ich meine, was bitte kann sich jetzt in einem neuen Betriebssystem so dramatisch verändert haben, dass ein Installer nicht mehr in der Lage ist, irgendwie so ein paar Bites auf der Platz zu schalten?
Nix, aber die Chatten ist ja beim Start. Du kannst nicht mal den Calculator irgendwie auf neueren Dings fahren und so.
Ja, aber warum denn nicht einen Installer?
Ja, warum sollte man?
Weil man ein altes Betriebssystem installieren will. For a reason. Ja, was wollen sie denn bei Apple und bei welchem Betriebssystem? Ich meine, ich darf nur nach vorne oder was?
Vorwärts immer, rückwärts immer. Der Erich hat es auch schon gewusst.
Und das macht begrenzt? Ja, da hatte ich erst mal so ein bisschen Schnappatmung, weil ich mir gedacht habe, wie kriege ich jetzt hier einen Line drauf? Weil gibt es ja jetzt auch nicht so auf CD und so. Oder das hatte ich zumindest jetzt nicht so klar. Dann war halt irgendwie, theoretisch hätte ich jetzt das Image in dem Installer nehmen können und auf irgendwie Medium brennen. Das habe ich dann auch probiert. Scheiterte beim Schreiben von USB-Sticks und wurde irgendwann wirklich irre. Musste aber auch vor allem mal vorankommen. Ich hatte jetzt hier nicht beliebig viel Zeit. Ich musste irgendwie ein Ergebnis erzielen. Man hatte dann Gott sei Dank noch eine alte Snow Leopard CD im Schrank. Das heißt, ich habe dann diese Kiste platt gemacht, habe die Daten nochmal auf die andere Platte geschrieben, die Systemplatte bereit gemacht, habe dann irgendwie Snow Leopard installiert, das dann gebootet. Dann aktualisiert sich das erstmal auf 10.6.8, damit es den App Store hat. Dann den App Store aktiviert, um dann den Line Installer runterzuladen, um dann mit dem Line Installer dieses Snow Leopard wieder offline zu bringen. Was ja dann immerhin schon das Aktuelle ist, weil der Installer ja immer das Aktuelle runterlädt. Und dann musste ich nur noch irgendwie den Scheiß mit Migration Assistant migrieren. Was auch relativ problemlos funktioniert hat. Was nicht funktioniert hat, war, ich konnte dann, womit fing es an? Mit iPhoto. War das iPhoto? Genau, ich wollte dann iPhoto starten. Hab iPhoto runtergeladen aus dem App Store.
Noch mal frisch.
Starte das.
Und es kommt mir hoch mit irgendwie Ja, Crash, irgendwie hier Library, bla. Irgendwas. So, bitte was frisch... Ich hab gerade ein Betriebssystem frisch installiert. Was? What the fuck? Vermute aber, dadurch, dass ich gesagt habe, hier Migrationsassistent, hol doch bitte auch noch die Ups aus diesem Backup wieder mit raus, was sozusagen schon in der Zukunft lag. Dass er dann mit den Libraries irgendwas verkackt hat. Und tatsächlich war es halt dann so iLife-Support-Libraries im Systemordner und noch irgendeinen Schranz, den ich jetzt vergessen habe, also auch Final Cut Pro, also so eine ganze Garde von Apple-Applikationen schrie auf einmal auf. Das andere lief irgendwie. Dann hab ich dann diese Libraries irgendwie manuell ausgetauscht, da kam ich mir auch wirklich kloppt vor. Und dann ging's irgendwann wieder. Aber es ist irgendwie nicht schön.
Und dein ganzer Audiokram, die ganzen Sachen, die kommen einfach nicht so schnell hinterher mit?
Das ist halt das andere Problem. Das ist auch wieder ein Problem dieser ganzen Audioszene schon immer gewesen, dass die einfach arschlangsam sind, was die Anpasserei ihrer Treiber für das Betriebssystem ist. Und ich weiß irgendwie nicht, ob das überhaupt berechtigt ist, jetzt so auf ihnen rumzuhauen, weil wenn man jetzt auch Rody hört und so, wie schlimm das dann teilweise auch zugeht bei Apple, was gerade so die Audiosubsysteme betrifft, was sich dann halt immer wieder ändert.
Aber gerade mit Mountain Lion ist es wohl um einiges besser geworden. Also mit Lion ist da einiges schlimmer geworden. Mountain Lion soll wohl wesentlich bessere Audio-IPs haben.
Na gut, es kann aber zwei Gründe geben. Es kann sich halt bei Apple verschlimmert haben, oder es kann einfach scheiße programmiert gewesen sein vorher und es hat sich dann eben beim neuen Betriebssystem gerecht, weil auf einmal Dinge, wo vor Apple immer gewarnt hat, dass man sich doch bitte nicht tun sollte, in dem Moment dann manifestiert haben. Sowas kann es halt immer sein.
Das kann auch sein, dass sie vorher im Limit waren mit Absicht, um das beste Ergebnis rauszuholen und dann geht es halt kaputt, wenn du ein neues Betriebssystem hast.
Ich denke einfach die Chance, dass diese Driver immer noch nicht Mountain Lion kompatibel sind, bevor Apple schon das nächste OS angekündigt hat.
Kannst du diese Lampe da mal so ein bisschen... Ich kann die auch ausmachen. Super. Als ich hier eben auch Audio Interfaces recherchiert habe, da war nämlich auch mein Augenmerk, weil ich das auch immer noch so im Hinterkopf hatte, dass so diese Firewire Soundkarten immer alle irgendwie, dass da immer Treiberhessel gab bei Leuten, die die hatten. Und das, was ich mir dann am Ende rausgesucht hatte, das war von Native Instruments und das brauchte auch kein extra Treiber-Download, sondern das geht irgendwie mit Chor-Audio irgendwie direkt so. Und das klang dann schon mal erstmal ganz gut so.
Ja, da gibt es so ein paar Firmen, die können das nicht lassen. Die sind immer der Meinung, eigener Treiber muss sein, obwohl ich das bezweifle, zumindest bei Firewire, dass das nötig ist.
Ja, bei USB gibt es halt auch das, dass die ohne Treiber kommen. Also ohne... einfach mit diesem vermute Chor, Audio, irgendwie, keine Ahnung.
Die meinen halt, sie könnten da niedrige Latenzen mit sichern. Ich bin mir auch immer nicht so richtig sicher, ob das alles eher im Bereich des Voodoo- und Arbeiter-Glaubens liegt oder ob da auch wirklich Realität dran ist. Also das Teil macht das sozusagen richtig, ja.
Na, da gibt es halt immer so ein paar Geräte, die ich da auch gefunden habe, aber eben längst nicht alle. Und dann die, die es halt nicht haben, da war es dann wirklich so ja, jetzt auch schon Mountain-Line-Beta- Treiber. Wenn du da ein Produktionssystem halt da drauf dependent hast, dann ist es halt, dann willst du auch keinen Beta-Treiber installieren.
Dieser Rausch von Apple, immer wieder neue Versionen und alte Zöpfe abschneiden, grundsätzlich finde ich das ja gut, aber manchmal weiß ich nicht, ob sie nicht einfach zu schnell voranschreiten.
Also ich habe gerade bei meinem Kunden, der musste nämlich auch immer, also es ist für seinen Motorcontroller, immer einen Treiber mitliefern für die serielle Schnittstelle, weil alle über USB ja seriell sprechen, weil sie können ja, USB ist ja viel zu schwer, man macht es lieber so wie früher, deswegen sind das alles so C-Adapter oder der Adapter ist beim Controller gleich eingebaut, so war es da. Und dann war da halt dieser Treiber für die, für so ein FTD-Chip, die machen also USB-Chips. Und weil der Hersteller von dem Motorkontrol aber wieder seine USB-ID von dem Device nicht richtig eingetragen hat, musste ich nicht nur einen Installer mitliefern, sondern auch noch den vorher patchen, damit dieses Device da drin ist. Und dann hat mir Kumpel Fita erzählt, Lip-USB-Maintener, hier schreibt es doch selbst direkt diesen FTD-Scheiß, dass du da mit dem Ding seriell sprichst und dann brauchst du keinen Treiber mehr und dann ist Ruhe, hab ich gemacht. Und siehe da, ist voll easy.
Nochmal, das muss man nochmal erklären.
Also ich hab, da ist ein Motor-Controller, der hat halt ein USB-Chip drauf, aber wenn du den anschließt, erscheint dann halt eine Serielle auf dem Rechner, wenn du dann diesen Installer hast und dann sprichst du über so eine Serielle mit dem Controller. So wie früher halt, als sie wirklich eine Serielle benutzt haben.
Genau, du bist sozusagen gezwungen, nochmal einen Treiber dafür zu installieren.
Genau, den FTDI-Serial-Ding ans Punkt keckst, weißt schon so. In Köln-Extension musst du auch booten, muss der Kunde booten, wenn er sowas kriegt. Und da stehen aber alle ID's drin, weil FTDI vertreibt ja diesen Stein, aber wenn du den benutzt, kannst du halt deine eigene Device-ID da haben.
Wie heißt die Bude?
Und die haben das aber nicht angemeldet bei FTDI, dass sie folgende Product-ID benutzen, deswegen war der in dem Installer nicht drin oder in dem Treiber und da musste ich den immer noch vorher selber reinpatchen. Also voll der Aufwand. Und dann hat mir halt irgendwann ein Kumpel gesagt, hier sprich doch den FTDI-Chip direkt an, da gibt es irgendwie lib-ftdi und dann brauchst du keinen Installer mehr und keinen Nix und dein Kunde ist happy und die Kunden vom Kunden sind happy und alle happy happy happy. Und so ist es auch, kein Ärger mehr. Weil das Fiese war dann auch noch, dass ich natürlich einen gepatchten FTDI-Treiber hatte, wenn die Leute aber noch andere Geräte haben, die auch diesen FTDI-Treiber benutzen. Dann haben die den natürlich oben drüber installiert und dann waren meine gepatchte Version weg und dann ging es wieder nicht und so weiter. Also es war ein ewiges Drama. Und deswegen mit diesen Treibern, also jetzt kommt die eigentliche Assent von dem Ganzen. Also wenn ihr in einer Firma seid und ihr habt irgendwas, wo so ein extra Installer für extra Treiber ist, das ist totale Scheiße. Macht das irgendwie direkt in euer Programm rein und nix mit Installer und so, das stinkt alles. Also wenn es geht, versucht es ohne hinzukriegen und wenn euer USB noch seriell spricht, dann habt ihr was falsch gemacht. Und wenn ihr jemanden braucht, der sich da auskennt, ihr habt meine Nummer, habt ihr nicht, kriegt ihr auch nicht, aber ihr könnt ja, also sucht euch wen, der euch das macht und es lohnt sich auf jeden Fall. Also die ersten Kunden melden jetzt schon, sie sind happy, dass sie diesen scheiß Installer nicht mehr brauchen. Und schneller kommt es mir auch noch vor, also es ist irgendwie durch die Sirelle durch, habe ich das Gefühl, geht es nochmal durch 20.000 Extra Layer und ja.
So halt nicht.
Und so ist es wahrscheinlich mit den Firewire-Devices oder bei den sonst die Audio-Devices hier mit USB und so, solange die das da nicht selber native irgendwie direkt machen, ist das alles nicht schön.
Ja, und das Netz ist mal wieder tot.
Ja, die Telekom macht jetzt wahrscheinlich so ihren eigenen Approach zum Drosseln oder so, keine Ahnung.
Das ist die Konkurrenz.
Kabel Deutschland. Kabel Deutschland macht einfach so dann Shaping und die Telekom machen einfach Trennung.
So kriegt der Podcaster.
Vielleicht liegt es auch hier einfach an meiner Fritzbox.
Ja, ich hab auch den Verdacht tatsächlich.
Ja, glaub ich eigentlich auch. Ich hab mir ja da Anfang des Jahres schon eine Airport Extreme gegeben.
Aber die hat ja kein DSL Modem drin.
Ja, die kannst du ja nicht benutzen.
Noch nie gehabt.
Klar, schon immer?
Nee. Kein DSL Modem. Nee, hatten sie nie. Die kann PPPoE mit dein Modem sprechen.
Ach so, das klickst du halt davor. Was solls?
Ja, wenn du kein Modem hast.
Es gibt ja auch.
Oh, Ebay 5 Euro?
Ja, aber auch VDSL. Ja, das Problem ist, es gibt nur ein einziges Gerät auf dem Markt, was so funktioniert, dass es tatsächlich mit einer Time-Capsule an VDSL funktioniert und dieses Gerät wird nicht mehr hergestellt und ist auf Ebay mittlerweile zum dreifachen Preis, geht das weg.
Wait, wait, wait, das heißt, du musst so eine Fritzbox nehmen, weil die sowas mit drin hat. Aber du kannst der Fritzbox nicht sagen, hier bitte durchschleifen, der dahinter kümmert sich und das die Fritzbox halt eben nicht.
Das geht. Das geht theoretisch. Aber, nee, ehrlich gesagt, ich hab mittlerweile die Fritzbox und ihre Features ganz lieb gewonnen.
Ja, aber das geht dran nicht.
Das ist überhaupt nicht gesagt, dass das jetzt daran liegt.
Aber es soll noch nicht bewiesen, dass es nicht daran liegt und ich würd's ja mal ausprobieren.
Was soll ich ausprobieren? Aber das setzt die Frage, ob, wenn du das PPPoE von der Airport machen lässt, ob, also und das Modem sozusagen durchbridgede, ob das dann wirklich auch das Problem behält. Wenn die Fritzbox generell ein Modem-Problem hat, dann benutzt sie immer noch das gleiche Modem und dann...
Siehst du denn überhaupt eine Verbindung? Nein, es gibt keine.
Das riecht nach einem Pfeil für Clemens.
Ich hab mich an statische IPv6-Adressen jetzt gewöhnt. Ich will das irgendwie auch bei deinen haben, das geht hier nicht mit einer Timecab.
Aber dieser Markt für so eine Modems ist tatsächlich sehr dünn. Also man kriegt auch so, früher gab es auch so PCI-Karten, wo du das halt noch so in einen Rechner reinstecken konntest und so weiter. Da gibt es jetzt mittlerweile nur noch einen Anbieter, der so Modems in Steckkartenformat z.B. baut.
Ja, aber ich hab hier auch irgendwie...
Ich glaube hier von US Robotics gab es auch immer diese... Das Modem, was ich hatte, gab es auch als Steckkarte, aber das war ja noch bestimmt kein PCI.
Ja, nee, also das ist halt wirklich... Heutzutage gibt es nur diese Plastikkisten, die sind so mit allem gleich drin.
Na, nee, ich hab irgendwie so einen Siemens DSL2, oder wie das Ding heißt, oder DSL2+, oder ADSL2+, oder irgendwie sowas. Und dann hinter kommt gleich hier mein FreeBSD-Router und der macht da alles. Aber das PPP stürzt auch, oder was? Und muss man dann auch mit Kill-9 Hardcore...
Also ich hab das Gefühl, dass es... Ich bin ja jetzt nicht so weit weg von hier und hab mit meinem VDSL... Also nicht so ein Stress wie Tim gerade. Aber so, dass ich hin und wieder mal die Box neu boote, weil es irgendwie gerade mal Stress macht, das hab ich ein paar Mal. Und neulich hatte ich in der Nacht auch mal für... Keine Ahnung, da war mal für eine Stunde das Netzwerk oder sowas.
Weißt du, was für eine Art das ist? Von welchem Hersteller die Differenz ist?
Hans musste gestern auch sagen, dass er seine Telekom-Box powercycelt, weil nichts mehr durchging.
Wobei die Box an sich reagiert noch super und das ist überhaupt gar kein Problem. Ich hab das Gefühl, dass er dann einmal einen Verbindungsabbruch braucht und nochmal einen echten Aufbau oder so was. Das ist irgendwie alles nicht so gut.
Ok, jetzt wieder zurück zum Basisthema. Also, hier Mac Pro, Snow Leopard, Lion, wo warst du stehen geblieben?
Ich hab im Prinzip alles erzählt. Ich warte halt jetzt darauf, dass hier die Bude, das Ordinate, mal liefert und mal die Treiber auf Mountain Lines anpasst. Weil die nächste Katze schärft schon ihre Krallen, wenn du mich fragst. Kann man jetzt schwer davon ausgehen, dass glaube ich Mitte nächsten Jahres schon wieder das nächste US-Release ansteht.
Wann wird da ein Preview kommen, im Januar, Februar irgendwann wieder oder wann war das diesmal?
Aber Tim mag seine Fritz Box, dann hab ich ja mein Werk erfüllt.
Welches Werk?
Ich war immer der Einzige, der die Fritz Box machte.
Ich bin ja auch nicht komplett beratungsresistent.
Ja, ich sag ja, ist ja mein Werk erfüllt.
Aber da kommt auch noch PPO, macht das Ding selbst oder wie?
Muss es ja.
Aber das sind verschiedene Level. Du musst halt erstmal auf physical Level ATM sprechen.
Das ist das Schöne bei diesem Couple Deutschland, dass da einfach AP aus der Kiste rausfällt. Ja, aber du kriegst da auch eine Kiste.
Und warte, lass mich raten, du musst in so einem Web-Interface gehen, um den Port-Forwarding zu machen?
Wahrscheinlich, aber...
Ja klar, weil die Kiste ja das Nut für dich macht, richtig?
Ich verstehe nicht. Ich hab nämlich keinen... Ich hab nicht einen WLAN-Router von denen. Also das ist wirklich nur das Modern, was ich von denen krieg.
Also dieses Kabelmodem.
Ja, wer macht dann aber...
Meine AirPod in dem Fall. Das heißt, ich krieg das auf der AirPod hin. Also da kommt wirklich nur ein schwarzes Cisco-Kiste, wo IP rausfällt. Ethernet. Das ist halt ganz angenehm, so im Handling.
Aber die Cisco-Kiste ist eine kleine Plaste-Box auch.
Ja, ist kein 1990s-Wish.
Früher war das so.
Aber da kommt eine kleine Plastikkiste, da kommt IP raus. Du musst irgendwo deine Benutzerdaten ein, du musst kein Passwort dir merken. Wenn du beim Kundendienst anrufst, dann buchen die sich auf dein Modem ein und machen gleich eine Messung und gucken nach.
Das muss man bei den aktuellen Fritz-Boxen auch explizit abschalten, dass die das können. Also dass da nicht die Telekom draufgucken kann. Das geht mittlerweile auch alles. Also dieses Steck das rein und es geht, das haben die mittlerweile auch irgendwie hingebogen.
Also ich hab ja früher mal Atme gemacht für so eine kleine Bude, die hatten noch eine 1 MBit Synchronleitung oder 2 MBit waren es vielleicht. Mit auch so einer riesengroßen 19 Zoll Cisco 2600 irgendwas. Und da hab ich denen gesagt, ey sag mal, was zahlt ihr hier? Und die so, ja keine Ahnung, es war schon D-Mark oder Euro. Aber so 200 D-Mark, 100 Euro oder mehr, doppelte weiß nicht so genau, jedenfalls voll vier. Was soll denn der Scheiß? Holt euch hier ein normales DSL, irgendwie 6 MBit gab's damals oder 16 schon, weiß ich nicht mehr genau. Und ist billiger, ist schneller, ist besser für euch. Und alles ist super, haben die gemacht. Bin ich ein paar Monate später wieder da. Steht im Schrank immer noch hier so diese riesen Cisco-Kiste. Ich so, ja was ist mit der Kiste da? Ja, die braucht keiner und die hat auch keine abgeholt. Und die ist ja von dem Vertrag davor und die ist jetzt hier so übrig. Ach, also das Altmüll braucht ihr nicht mehr, ne? Ja, ne, willst du haben, kannst du mitnehmen. Ja, ich mach euch die weg. Stand ewig bei mir zu Hause rum, weil ich brauch den Scheiß natürlich auch nicht. Aber irgendwann kam jemand und brauchte die ganz unbedingt, weil die irgendwie so ein komisches Special-Feature hat, was doch irgendwie gebraucht wurde für VoIP denn später, weil man ja CISCO, iOS, konnte man ja nachflaschen und so. Und ich hab die für eine ordentliche Summe verkauft. Also es war richtig gut.
Nicht schlecht. Kommen wir zu anderen Themen.
Na, was rauben wir uns an ITunes 11 ran?
Ich hab nur so Kleinkram, aber es ist so praktisches Zeug. ITunes 11, das müssen wir auch noch drüber reden. Habt ihr da eine Meinung? Ja, hören wir mal los.
Ja, das geht überhaupt gar nicht.
Warum?
Das Interface ist der volle Rotz. 1.000 Features sind irgendwie entfernt. Das sind so Subfeatures, die wahrscheinlich jetzt wieder alle zusammenhören.
Also ich weiß von einem einzigen Feature, was weg ist.
Aber man kann zum Beispiel die ID.3-Text nicht neu schreiben.
Wie? Was?
Na, ich bin ja hier, du weißt ja Hocke, wir haben ja so eine dicke Musiksammlung und ich kümmere mich ein bisschen. Manchmal, wenn man sich aus gewissen Quellen so Musik besorgt, dann sind die ID.3-Text irgendwie so komisch und dann war immer bisher mein Trick, ich schreib die als Version ID3 Version 2.1 irgendwie neu und danach nochmal neu als wieder 2.4 oder 2.3, sogar weil 2.4 ging nicht, wie auch immer, und dann ging's. Und ich glaub, dieses Feature gibt's jetzt irgendwie nicht mehr. Das ist in der letzten Version schon auf dem Kontext-Click verschwunden und jetzt ist es ganz weg.
Dass du die ID.3-Tech-Version sozusagen setzen kannst.
Ja, genau. Dann schreibt er die halt nochmal neu. Und manche Files waren kaputt und da hat Neuschreiben irgendwie geholfen und so eine Feature gibt es halt nicht mehr, weil Apples Entscheidung, glaube ich, ist irgendwie so, dann fragen die, was dann so für Features wichtig ist, und dann sagen die, na so eine Feature sind nicht wichtig, weil die Leute sollen bei uns Musik kaufen und da stimmen halt die Text. Und ja, das Gefühl habe ich halt, dass sie sich nicht mehr kümmern.
Aber weißt du, RIP Mix Burn ist halt einfach lange her. Jetzt heißt es iTunes Match und wenn...
Ja, wir sollten es auch mit deinem eigenen Rechner rippen damals schon. Jaja, ist ja absolut in Ordnung. Aber das hast du ja nur mit iTunes gerippt, dann stimmt ja die IRD3-Text.
Ja, es gibt auch andere Ripper auf dieser Welt. Also sowas ist halt ein bisschen blöd. Und dann dieses ganze GUI, ist alles ganz schick gemacht, aber dann hört es halt auch schon auf.
Also GUI hatte ich ja ein Problem gleich am Anfang. Da habe ich nämlich gerade das iTunes gestartet und habe den zweiten Monitor abgezogen. Und wisst ihr, was dann dieses iTunes zu leisten imstande war? Es hat es geschafft, auf dem kleineren Hauptmonitor die gesamte obere Menüleiste hinter die Menübar zu schieben. Also hinter das Apple-Menü, hinter diese Leiste. Das heißt, es gab keine Chance, das Fenster zu nehmen und es wieder da rauszuziehen. Quitten, Neustarten helfen nicht, Altquit, Neustarten helfen nicht. Es hat permanent mit dem ganzen Hauptmenü oder mit der ganzen oberen Leiste sozusagen hinter dem Apple-Menü gestartet. Ja, ich hab dann mich darauf besinnt, dass ich ja dieses...
Den Mondi noch wieder anschließe, das Kleidermacher und...
Nee, nee, nee, ich hab ja dieses Tool hier, wie heißt es doch gleich? Divi, mit dem ich meine Fenster irgendwie hinschüften kann. Und damit hab ich es dann wieder geschafft. Aber das ist mir echt lange nicht passiert, dass ein Programm das wirklich zulässt, dass es so permanent hinter dieser Menüleiste verschwindet.
Writer hatte da mal so einen Bug, bei dem das genau das Gleiche passiert ist. Und es war wirklich unerträglich, weil du hast das Fenster zugemacht, neues Fenster auf, das neue Fenster war genau in der gleichen Position, echt ätzend. Und die haben dann empfohlen, Window, also in der Menüleiste aufzumachen und da Zoom auszuwehren. Es ist quasi so, als ob man auf die kleine grüne Bubble klicken würde und dann zooms auf volle Größe, aber dann stimmt es auch wieder. Das funktioniert bestimmt auch bei iTunes. Hoffe ich mal, falls das passiert.
Und was ich halt auch echt zum Heulen finde, ist der Store.
Da war ich noch nicht mal, da bin ich eh nie.
Also der Mac App Store ist scheiße und der iTunes Store, der ist jetzt auch wieder richtig schlimm. Ich verstehe auch nicht, warum die nicht einfach eine eigene Webseite daraus machen. Du loggst dich da ein auf der Webseite, dann bist du da drin und hast Taps im Browser. Du kannst mehrere Apps mal nebeneinander aufmachen und musst nicht immer in dieser bescheuerten irgendwie ich klicke eine Sache an, dann muss ich erstmal wieder zurück, um wieder die nächste mir auszuwählen. Du kannst halt nicht einfach sagen, hier die drei Filme mal im Tab öffnen und dann zwitschst du da so schön durch. Das ist so eine ekelhaft langsame, verzögerte, mühsame Navigation durch diesen ganzen Store. Und sie machen ja da am Ende Webviews. Oder genau, hier dieses Seitwärts scrollen. Da klickst du auf irgendein Item mal drauf und dann willst du irgendwo in der Beschreibung seitwärts scrollen und wenn die Maus nicht an der richtigen Stelle ist, dann gehst du zurück. Dann ist sozusagen diese Seitwärts scroll, gehst du plötzlich, das gehe zurück.
Ach sowas, das ist aber das erste, was sich ausschaltet nach einer neuen Installation.
Ja, aber das ist halt auch, diesen iTunes, das ist so kaputt irgendwie. Das ist einfach nicht geil.
Und dann bis man durchgeblickt hat, wie es jetzt hier ist mit dem Songs-Abspielen, ob jetzt das gesamte Album in die Liste kommt oder nur der Song, den du gerade hast und ob der Song, den du jetzt anklickst, als nächstes gleich in die Songliste kommt oder hinten dran und so. Also die haben sich da ja irgendwie was einfallen lassen, aber ich blicke da noch nicht so klar durch. Und es mag sein, dass man sich irgendwann dran gewöhnt, aber intuitiv ist das alles irgendwie nicht.
Vor allen Dingen, also ich finde halt auch echt, dass es jetzt wirklich an der Zeit, diesen App-Store da rauszuziehen aus diesem iTunes, der gehört da einfach irgendwie meiner Meinung nach nicht mehr rein. Und ob da Filme, also okay, Musik und Filme können ich noch mitleben, aber diese App-Store muss da raus. Das muss irgendwas eigenes sein. Das muss irgendwie ein Interface sein, wo es auch Spaß macht, da wirklich durchzubrausen. Für mich ist das jedes Mal ätzend. Auf dem Phone wie, also jetzt eigentlich auf iTunes ist es noch ätzender als auf den mobilen Geräten, den Store nach irgendwelchen Programmen oder so zu durchsuchen. Da suchst du nach Dexter und dann kriegst du halt auch, du kannst nicht sagen, ich will jetzt nur Apps suchen, oder? Kann man das mittlerweile? Ach doch, warte mal. Moment, ich gucke gleich nochmal, ob das geht mittlerweile. Aber wenn du Search Store oben eintippst...
Also echt der solide First World Problems, die ihr da sozusagen habt. Ich kann nicht genug, nicht richtig kaufen.
Nee, ich kann, also ich weiß nicht, ich finde dieses...
Ich kann auch nicht kaufen, weil das jetzt schon wieder weg ist.
Ich verstehe überhaupt gar nicht, was hier gerade los ist.
Kann sein, dass du über IPv6 streamst?
Nein, kann ja nicht sein.
Recht auswählen, dass...
Weil Nicecast kann das nicht. Hab denen geschrieben, ob sie das nicht mal einbauen wollen. Und so...
Ok, eigene Streaming-Lösungen.
Ja, es führt keinen Weg dran vorbei. Ich glaub 2013 ist das Jahr des Streamings.
Wir bilden Stöcker, ich mach Mambel, da sind in 10 Minuten 100 Leute.
Doch, guck, das geht hier ganz hervorragend mit dem Auswähl, dass man nur Apps haben möchte.
Wo hast du das ausgewählt?
Na hier rechts in der Leiste hab ich ausgewählt, da seh ich ja, ja, nur Apps haben möchte.
Also mein Beef zum iTunes 11, zunächst einmal kann ja sein, dass jetzt irgendwelche kleinen Features weggegangen sind, aber User-Interface-mäßig haben sie einen Schritt nach vorne gemacht.
Also wenn man zehn Gruppen und zwanzig Songs hat, ist doch alles viel langsamer geworden, findest du nicht?
Alles so ein bisschen hakliger und sluggier.
Also gerade die Geschwindigkeit ist bei mir besser geworden, deutlich besser.
Doch, ich find das auch sexier.
Ich find das irgendwie so.
Und die ganzen Alben auf einer Seite, da blickt doch kein Schwein durch, wer sortiert dann so seine Musik?
Nee, du kannst ja hier auch wieder den Column-Browser-View und so.
Also du hast ja den alten View noch.
Den man erstmal mühsam wieder einschalten muss, aber den gibt's noch immerhin, ja. Aber ich weiß nicht, irgendwie nicht...
Und der kommt wie?
Du musst auf Songs klicken und dann kannst du dann alle möglichen Features wieder einschalten. Ja, ich weiß nicht, also jetzt gerade ist es auch nicht langsam, aber ich hatte jetzt schon ein paar Mal irgendwie so den Eindruck, dass es irgendwie alles so... Also, ich weiß nicht, die haben doch irgendwann mal iTunes auf diesen Webview umgestellt oder WebKit oder was auch immer, dass das halt alles nicht mehr... Das ist diesen...
Ich hab ein bisschen gescrollt und gleich steht das ganze Ding hier.
Und irgendwie, ich find halt, irgendwie merkt man das immer noch, dass das nicht so...
Ich weiß nicht. Also, ich find auch, man merkt ihm deutlich an, dass es immer noch dreckiges Carbon ist. Also, das ist sehr eklig.
Das ist einfach zu viel in einem Programm. Das kann mir kein anderer erzählen, dass das irgendwie...
Und das sind Sachen, die sind echt schlimm. Also, es sind so dieses Download-Fenster, dieses Neue. Wenn man ja irgendwie... Das Einzige, was ich mit iTunes wirklich mache, ist, meine Apps zu aktualisieren. Und dann sind ja jetzt die Downloads, die man sich gerade runterlädt, sind ja jetzt nicht mehr in so einer Seitenleiste da drinnen, was vielleicht auch Sinn macht, sondern im eigenen Fenster. Was man eben aufmachen kann. Und dieses Fenster verhält sich komplett bekloppt. Also, das kann man zum Beispiel nicht per Apfel-W zu machen, sondern dann wird das Hauptfenster geschlossen und das Download-Fenster davor bleibt geöffnet und so was. Das ist nicht wirklich rund.
Das ist kein dreckiges Carbon.
Und ich fand diese Leiste links, die fand ich eigentlich da voll cool. Wo würde denn mein iPhone jetzt kommen, wenn ich das hier mache? Auch da oben drin, oder was?
Das ist kein Carbon.
Das ist 64-Bit.
Meinst du, dass das Coco ist? Glaub ich nicht.
Na, es gibt keinen 64-Bit.
Ich weiß, dafür haben sie es gebaut. Ich hab keine Ahnung. Aber das ist doch kein... Das merkt man doch eben. Das merkt man eben noch an, dass es Carbon ist. Das ist doch kein Rebrite.
Und was soll diese Cloud überall? Ich hab gar keine Cloud.
Doch, du hast ein iTunes-Account.
Das reicht schon.
Bestimmt denn ist.
Aber ist ausgeschaltet hier alles.
Du hast keine Cloud. Ich weiß. Aber es ist egal. Cloud ist da. Die kriegt man auch nicht weg.
Naja, also ich hatte ja ehrlich gesagt...
Der andere Player. Ich hab nämlich gerade, weil ich gleich noch sagen wollte, welchen Player ich denn jetzt gerne mal immer noch nebenbei benutze, aber das machen wir gleich nachdem Tim noch sein Beef losgewonnt.
Gleich nach der Werbung.
Ich hab nicht so viel Erfahrungen gesammelt jetzt mit iTunes 11. Ich war nur überrascht, dass trotz der neuen Oberfläche im Wesentlichen darunter eigentlich immer noch dieselbe Maschine ist. Und es gibt auch immer noch dieselben ekligen Modalen, Dialoge und so, die hochkommen. Das ist wahrscheinlich das, was du meinst, ne?
Jaja, das ist... Also das hätten sie anders gemacht, wenn sie es auf Coco umgestellt hätten.
Ich finde, es ist etwas aufgeräumter. Sie haben eine klarere Trennung zwischen diesem Store und dem Rest. Wenn du nicht mit diesem Sidebar arbeitest, du kannst im Wesentlichen noch genauso arbeiten wie vorher. Also ehrlich gesagt, mir ist dieses Update auch egal.
Weil...
Eigentlich ändert sich da gar nichts.
Wobei ich ja dieses Play-Next-Feature finde ich ja ganz gut. Das ist ja eine lustige Sache, die ich auch mal verstehe. Aber ehrlich, wenn man Musik werden will, nimmt man Spotify, oder?
Ja, mal so, mal so. Ich hab schon noch Lokalmusik, die höre ich eher mit iTunes. Nee, eigentlich höre ich das mit dem Programm Ekut. Heißt das.
Was bist du denn auch Spotify-User?
Ja, ich bin auch ein Spotify-User. Aber nicht viel, also immer mal wieder. Weil ich mal irgendwie spontan denke, was war das nochmal? Oder irgendjemand mir eine Playlist shared, wo er meint, das muss ich schon mal gehört haben.
Also ich müsste mir auch nochmal pitchen, weil ich hab da glaube ich noch nicht mal einen Account.
Das Ding ist, ich glaube du wirst da auch erstmal kirre, weil da kommt halt alle 10, 15 Songs kommt halt auch so ein kleiner Werbespot.
Außer man bezahlt halt?
Außer man bezahlt halt.
Also meine Freundin, die hat, die ist, also ich persönlich brauch das nicht, ich hör viel zu wenig Musik, als dass sich das für mich lohnen könnte, aber meine Freundin, die hat sich so den 10-Euro-Account gekauft mit Mobile und allen Pipapo und die ist damit im Großen und Ganzen sehr glücklich. Also es ist so dieses, kannst du es halt, ich glaub auf dem Rechner hört sie so gut wie nie. Das geht halt damit sehr gut. Sie hat die iPhone-App, wo du dann auch Musik runterladen kannst. Weil ich ein bisschen Scheiße finde, ich glaub, um die iPad-App überhaupt zu benutzen zu dürfen, muss man schon einen Paid-Account haben. Also kriegst du die nicht mehr auf ohne Paid-Account. Wir haben diese Logitech Squeezebox, die Spotify-Unterstützung hat. Was echt cool ist, weil wenn du die auf dem Desktop legst, legst du dir eine Playlist an. Die ist sofort auf dem iPhone da, die ist auf der Squeezebox da, die ist überall da. Also das ist so wirklich wunderschöne Synchronisierung. Und sie macht das halt massenhaft, um so sich von irgendeinem Musiker wirklich alles, was der so gemacht hat, anzuhören. Das kannst du ansonsten legal für bezahlbares Geld ja gar nicht hinkriegen. Und da zahlst du deine 10 Euro und dann kannst du dir alles anhören, was der jemals gemacht hat.
Haben die auch alles?
Na die haben sehr viel, aber also ich war schon oft erstaunt, dass sie bestimmte Sachen haben, aber sie haben auch immer noch natürlich viel nicht. Also Beatles ist ein ganz schwieriges Thema zum Beispiel.
Aha, keine Beatles, na toll.
Da braucht man ja, da braucht man dann als ausschließlicher Beatles-Hörer.
Da hör ich doch die ganze Zeit rein, ob es wieder was Neues gibt.
Also ich hab gehört, irgendjemand hat gemeint, war das mal im Chat das, oder im Twitter, dass Paul McCartney bei der Nirvana Reunite singen soll.
Das hab ich auch gelesen, ich weiß nicht. Also ich halte das ja nach wie vor für irgendwie, für ein Scherz von irgendwem. Überhaupt, es gibt eine Nirvana Reunite?
Na ja, was auch immer.
Wie soll denn das gehen?
Da warten wir erstmal ab. Aber auf jeden Fall, ich hör Musik mit iTunes, mit Spotify und mit Ekut. Und Ekut ist halt so ein super Keyboard-Navigation-Slim-Musikplayer, der auch wirklich ein Musikplayer ist. Der ist, den find ich auch noch ganz schnuffig.
Immer Französisch. Da muss ich jetzt erstmal ein Capture eingeben.
Für unsere amerikanischen Freunde jetzt nichts. Genau. Es gibt ja auch Windamp immer noch für OSX. Die machen ja noch weiter.
Ich hab eben gerade das eingegeben.
Ja, das ist genau das Ding.
Was ist denn bei dir noch schlimmer? Ich schicke mich nämlich nicht an.
Ich meine, das Interessante ist, ich konekte jetzt gerade über IPv6.
Moment, der Link kommt gleich.
Das hat ja einfach irgendwie meinen IPv6-Range irgendwie deprecated.
Nee, also wie gesagt, ich habe jetzt das gleiche Problem. Und ich hab stinkenes IPv4.
Ja, eben. Aber ich komme überhaupt nicht für ihn nicht aus einem Telekom-Range.
Verstehst du?
Das kann nicht mit Telekom-Range als Telekom-Range was zu tun haben. Weil er sieht nicht, dass ich Telekom-Range bin. Ich hab eine IPv6-Adresse.
Sicher?
Ja, das ist mein Netz. Das ist immer dasselbe. Feste Adressen. Per Poop. Ah, nachdem ich das jetzt eingegeben habe, krieg ich das gleich nochmal.
Ah, beim dritten Mal geht's. Siehste?
Das ist einfach mal...
Hast du es vielleicht einfach falsch eingegeben?
Die wollen mich einfach zu bingen bringen. Ecute Mac, Ecute Mobile, pixieups.com.
Ach, das gab's neulich auch kostenlos oder so, ne? Für einen Tag.
Das ist auch free download.
Ach, die haben auch ne App. War das so, dass die noch ne iPhone-App haben, ne ganz gute?
Ja, die haben auch ne mobile App. Die hab ich allerdings noch nicht probiert. Ist die auch frei?
Nee, die kostet Geld.
Irgendwo muss das Geld ja herkommen, ne?
Wahrscheinlich weil sie sich nicht gut genug verkauft hat und so jetzt sagen, na, machen wir's jetzt. Ich glaub, das...
Aber das ist also diese... Ich mag diesen Ecute Mac ganz gerne. Man muss sich einmal kurz so ein bisschen in die Steuerung reingefummelt haben, aber die ist halt keyboard... Man kann da Keyboard Only sehr schnell auch zum Ziel kommen und nehme ich immer mal gerne so auf Arbeit um schnell irgendwie...
Wenn es mal ganz schnell mit dem Musikwechseln gehen muss.
Ja, ja, diese iTunes ist halt einfach echt zu klattert. Ich meine, da sind Bücher drin. Da sind Filme drin, da sind irgendwie da ist irgendwie alles drin, Apps und ach, ich...
iPhone, Backup, also...
Aber findet ihr nicht, also findet ihr nicht auch, dass der Store irgendwie was eigenes sein könnte? Irgendwie, ich finde echt das toll, wenn es eine Webseite wäre, wo man sich einmal einloggt und dann klickt man dann irgendwann, will ich haben und dann, dann passiert das, dass es automatisch auf dein Phone oder was auch immer kommt und nicht irgendwie dieses iTunes-Grafel dazwischen ist mit Taps, mit, weiß schon, so irgendwie so ein bisschen fluffig, eine richtig schöne schnuffige Store-Webapp.
Tja, ja, das wäre, das wäre gut. Also das hat man ja bei dem Betriebssystem mit A, bei dem Telefonbetriebssystem, da ist das ja so. Das funktioniert auch gut. Also du kannst auch, vor allen Dingen, man braucht ja den Dreck, also dieses Runterladen im App-Store, ich brauch das ja nicht mehr. Ich hab ja meine Apple-ID eingegeben und der lädt das ja sowieso. Ich synchronisier das ja nicht bloß, damit er das runterlädt. Und das ist halt bei Android so, da gehst du im Browser, loggst dich ein und dann kannst du auf all deine Android-Geräte, sagst du auf welchen das jetzt installiert werden soll und so. Das geht schon ganz hübsch. Hat dann allerdings auf der anderen Seite einen Nachteil, wobei das sollte eigentlich ein lösbares Problem sein, dass es natürlich schon die ersten Trojaner gibt, die dir deine Browser-Session übernehmen, die irgendwie unterm Arsch was installieren.
Ja, aber es kann auch so gehen, du kriegst dein Phone, kriegst dann halt ne Push-Notification, mach noch mal kurz den kleinen App-Store-Zauber-Authentifizierung mit Apple und leitet dann halt auf.
Wobei, dass man da kein Passwort eingeben muss, finde ich eigentlich ganz angenehm. Wenn man so ein iTunes auf dem Mac kauft, dann brauchst du nicht mehr auf dem Phone keine Passwort mehr einzugeben.
Was mich immer noch wundert, ist, dass ich immer noch Image-Capture brauche, was nicht im iTunes drin ist, um irgendwie an die Bilder von meinem iPhone ranzukommen. Also so das, was fast noch Sinn machen würde, das dann ins iTunes reinzuschieben, das gibt es irgendwie extra.
Und letztens...
Machst du das nicht mit iPhoto?
Letztens hatte ich ja was wildes versucht, ja. Da dachte ich mir, Moment, meine Kalender sind ja gar nicht gesüngt. Und das W-Line-Syncing ist nicht an. Und die Kontakte sind auch nicht gesüngt und die Safari Bookmarks nicht. Na ja gut, 21. Jahrhundert, das mit dem Syncing, jetzt über Kabel und so, das haben sie ja ein bisschen geübt. Ich klick jetzt mal diese Checkbox, synkt doch mal meine Kalender und meine Kontext und meine Safari Bookmarks. Und, was ist euer Tipp? Hat's geklappt? Oder war es eine totale Datenkatastrophe, die mehrere Stunden Aufräumarbeit nach sich zog? Ihre Einsätze bitte.
Was denn noch? Also ich würde sagen, es hat perfekt funktioniert und du warst glücklich.
Ja, nee, das war wieder mal der totale Fail. Alle Kalender doppelt drin.
Du singst bisher aber deine Kalender nicht?
Nein, ich hab auf... Doch, ich hatte... Ich hatte halt einen Google-Kalender. Der war bei beiden irgendwann schon mal eingetragen und dadurch hab ich auch schon meine Termine so über Google gesungen. Aber ich dachte mir irgendwie, ich hab auch so ein paar lokale Events, die halt nicht immer auf dem anderen Device sind. Und jetzt mach ich das mal an.
Du wechselst auch gerade Sünden mit Mergen, oder?
Naja, das macht der dann, wenn du das das erste Mal tust, dann gibt's halt auch den Merch. Und diesen Merch hat er einfach auch wieder grandios verkackt.
Merch ist schlimm.
Und meine Safari Bookmarks, dann hat er, also wirklich, das kann man ja keinem erzählen. Also ich hab hier frisch angefangen, beim Bookmarks, als ich hier Mountain Line installiert hab. Ich weiß nicht mehr aus welchem Grund, aber irgendwie hat sich meine Bookmarks irgendwie mal alle weggefeuert, weil war eh so ein Müllhaufen. Und seitdem hab ich wieder mal hin und wieder so ein paar Bookmarks, zum Beispiel mein ganzes Gitarren-Equipment und so. Alles frisch drin. Dann mach ich diesen Bookmark-Sync und Merge mit meinem iPhone, wo so gut wie keine Bookmarks drauf sind. Und was macht der? Er schmeißt halt alle meine neuen Bookmarks, nicht alle, genau, das ist eigentlich das Krasse. Er hat ein paar Ordner weggeschmissen oder ein paar Bookmarks, die ich so seitdem auf meinem Mac gesammelt hab. Ein paar hat er drin gelassen und ein paar hat er irgendwie aus, ich weiß nicht woher er diese Bookmarks geholt hat. Ja, ich hab schon Jahre nicht mehr gesehen. Also es war wirklich so ein nein, Ark, Restore, Safari, Bookmarks, nein, danke. Also es hat ja auf dem Mac zerstört. Also es war und Kontakte, ich hab's alles revertet.
Das ist wirklich so ein großer Schmerz und ich hab auch irgendwie ehrlich gesagt keine Ahnung, wie lange das noch dauern soll, bis das mal wirklich schmerzfrei wird.
Und das war auch dieser Grund, warum ich getweetet hab, dass irgendwie Sünden bei mir so das einzige, wo es eigentlich so problemfrei ist, auf dem IMAP Server ist, wo wirklich auch so, ich lese eine Mail hier, dann ist sie da auch gelesen, ich bewege eine Mail da irgendwohin, dann ist sie auch da in dem Ordner und das ist so...
Das findest du bemerkenswert gut. Wobei, ah, da hab ich übrigens auch noch schon lange anhaltende Fragen. Was sind die? Seid ihr Mail-kompetent? E-Map?
Also, ich hab zumindest meinen eigenen Mail-Server im Betrieb.
Probier doch mal die Frage zu stellen.
Okay, das ist nicht ganz einfach. Dieser Präfix, dieser E-Map Path Präfix. Also ich hab ja mehrere Accounts, aber ich hab irgendwie das Problem, dass ich jetzt... Also da ist noch so ein CTC-Server drin, da ist irgendwie ByteCamp, tralala, da ist Gmail drin und so weiter. Und ich hab irgendwie so das Gefühl, jeder E-Map Server hat so eine ganz andere Auffassung darüber, wie das mit diesem Präfix und diesen Pfaden und diesen Ordnern irgendwie zu sein hat.
Das kann man auch innerhalb des gleichen E-Map Servers auch unterschiedlichste Art konfigurieren, wenn ich mich recht entsinne.
Genau, außerdem hab ich das Gefühl, dass so ein paar E-Map Server auf eine Art und Weise konfiguriert sind, wie es eben mit dem Rest, insbesondere mit der Mail-Applikation auf dem Mac OS X einfach nicht zusammen spielen will. Und auch dem iOS. Was irgendwie ja noch der kleinste Ansatz ist. Also ich versuch mich mal dieser Problematik ein bisschen zu nähern, was ich da eigentlich für Probleme habe. Zum Beispiel Probleme, dass wenn ich auf dem iPhone Nachrichten lösche, sie sozusagen in den Trash schiebe, dass er mir dann sagt, das ginge nicht. Obwohl es dann weg ist.
Dann wird es sofort gelöscht, kann das sein?
Vielleicht.
So was.
Dann lege ich, jetzt muss ich mir mal ein bisschen nachdenken, dann möchte ich Dinge tun und dann kommt dann irgendwie die Mail-Applikation herum und meint so, um jetzt hier den Junk-Ordner richtig anlegen zu können, müsste ich aber diesen Emap-Path-Prefix jetzt anders setzen, als das jetzt hier gerade ist, soll ich das für dich automatisch tun? So nach dem Motto, soll ich das Richtige tun, von dem ich denke, dass es das Richtige ist und ich bin dein Computer und du verstehst davon sowieso nichts? Bitte drück OK.
Aber wir fragen dich trotzdem, weil wir sind ja nicht schuld gewesen, wenn es nachher schiebt.
Genau, dann drücke ich OK und dann wird es so absurd, dass dann auf einmal Ordner in meinem Inbox-Ordner erscheinen und die anderen Ordner sind dann auf einmal wieder alle weg, die vorher so separat sind. Du nixst schon so ein bisschen, also du kennst diese generelle Problematik. So, was ich mich jetzt überhaupt erstmal gefragt habe ist, was bedeutet dieser E-Map Passpräfix genau?
Ich glaube, das war einfach nur ein bisschen mehr Konfigurationsmöglichkeiten zu haben.
Wozu ist das gut und vor allem, was ist die allgemeine Erkenntnis, was der Wert ist, auf den sie gesetzt sein soll? Soll es Inbox sein oder soll er leer sein? Also das ist die zweite Frage. Und die dritte Frage ist, wie heißen eigentlich diese ganzen well-known Ordner für Spam und gelöschte Mails und so weiter? Weil das ist auch...
Also Mail auf Mac kann man das auswählen. Da kann man Ordner auswählen und kann sagen, du bist jetzt der Spam-Ordner.
Ich weiß, dass ich das auswählen kann, aber ich werde wahnsinnig, weil ich dann auf verschiedenen Rechnern immer irgendwas auswähle mit dem Ergebnis, dass ich drei Rechner habe, die alle auf derselben Inbox andere Annahmen darüber haben, welcher Ordner jetzt was ist, und einfach alles doppelt und dreifach an verschiedenen Stellen landet. Aber gehen wir mal an den Anfang. Was ist dieser E-Map-Pass-Prefix genau?
Also man kann... Ich kann diese... Also er sagt es hier schon so ein bisschen, geht es in die Richtung so eine Art Chainshoot für deinen IMAP-Server, aber ich glaube diese Art Fragen, die kann ja der Clemens wahrscheinlich sehr gut beantworten. Also du weißt es nicht. Ich kann es dir nicht verbrieft sagen. Ich hab die Erfahrung so gemacht, ich habe ja den eigenen Mailserver eingerichtet und ich habe DoveCat als IMAP-Server, weil DoveCat als einziger IMAP-Server gilt, der IMAP auch sozusagen standardkonform überhaupt spricht. So jetzt ist auch bekannt, dass Apple Mail von IMAP nur so die Hälfte implementiert, beziehungsweise so ein paar eigene Annahmen darüber trifft, wie IMAP sich zu verhalten hat. Und wenn man jetzt... Ich habe halt am Anfang so den Ansatz genommen, okay, ich nehme jetzt einen Mac OS X Server und konfigurier da Mail und ich glaube, die benutzen, ich weiß nicht, ob sie auch DoveCat benutzen für IMAP, bin ich mir gerade nicht sicher. Ich glaube aber. Und übernehme jetzt mal deren Konfiguration, damit es mit meinem Apple Mail gut funktioniert. Hab ich aber nicht hinbekommen. Also ich hab da bestimmt drei, vier Nächte lang dran gesessen, das DoveCat so zu konfigurieren, dass Apple Mail damit glücklich ist und all diese Probleme verschwinden, die du gerade besprochen hattest. Und dann am Ende habe ich mich dann eben dazu durchgerungen, das hat man ja auch schon ein paar Mal in der Sendung erwähnt, dass ich halt Apple Mail, zumindest auf Mac nicht mehr benutzen, sondern Postbox, was ja sozusagen so ein bisschen Thunderbird oder Mozilla Mail implementiert, aber mit einem etwas tolleren Interface. Noch toller. Und die halt einmal ordentlich sprechen. Und damit sind jetzt alle meine Mail-Probleme zumindest auf Mac verschwunden gewesen. So, weil da kannst du auch alles einstellen, das macht der auch so, und der legt auch keine komischen.notes und also weißt ja, dieses Apple Mail, das hat ja in jedem OS, hat das irgendwelche anderen tollen neuen Features gehabt und jetzt To Do's und jetzt Posts, die wieder verschwinden und jedes Mail legt da irgendwelchen anderen Schrott ab. So, und glücklicherweise macht das das. iOS Mail legt halt nicht diese Folder an, sondern das bleibt so, also das macht nicht so diesen Automatic Magic Voodoo. Und deswegen benutze ich auf dem iPhone dann halt natürlich Apple Mail und das funktioniert ziemlich problemfrei tatsächlich, also da habe ich jetzt mit meinem derzeitigen Mail Setup auf dem iOS keine Probleme, dass da irgendwas nicht geht oder dass irgendwie plötzlich Ordner doppelt auftreten und sonst was. Also eigentlich war bei mir immer das Problem, Apple Mail auf dem Desktop, weil das halt irgendwie, ja, mit IMAP so wie es eigentlich gedacht ist.
Also du meinst wirklich, dass das Apple Mail Schwächen hat, was IMAP betrifft? Ich habe halt da am wenigsten Probleme.
Also mit Apple Mail habe ich auch gute Erfahrungen gemacht, also gerade mit diesem IMAP-Prefix. Das erinnert mich nämlich daran, dass es, ich wüsste gar nicht mehr, dass es die Einstellung überhaupt noch gibt, das haben wir, früher habe ich das mal eingerichtet, das heißt den Cyrus eingerichtet. Und bei dem Cyrus konnte man, also da hatte jeder User seinen eigenen Präfix, User Punkt und dann Usernamen. Und es gab aber noch Ordner aufgrund dessen, die wir alle zusammen sehen konnten. Also man konnte einen globalen Ordner anlegen, den konnten jeder sehen und jeder Mails reinschieben. Und das ist eigentlich auch ganz gut, weil dann kann da auch jeder, also so abzuarbeiten, das Zeug wird dann in den Ordner reingepackt und so was, das geht darüber relativ gut. Und was da an diesem IMAP-Pass lag, das war dann sozusagen im Home-Bereich. Deine Inbox war halt, normalerweise erwartete er die unter Inbox sozusagen und in dem Fall ist er dann auf username.inbox gegangen und dafür war dann halt diese Präfix gut.
Ja, aber ich hab ja IMAP Server diesen eingerichtet mit dem IMAP Passpräfix Inbox in Großbuchstaben.
Das halt ich für ein Fehler.
Ja, oder das ist halt so ein internes Keyword für was dann intern auf deinen Usernamen aufgelöst wird auf der Platte. Da müsste man halt jetzt ins Fallsystem gucken, wie er denn da überhaupt deine Mail wegsortiert.
Aber das würde erklären, warum er dir dann unter deiner Inbox die ganzen Ordner anzeigt.
Ja, aber bei Gmail und me.com, also iCloud und so weiter, die haben alle einen leeren IMAP Passpräfix.
Ich glaube, mit leer ist man da im 2x2 nicht so falsch.
Ich glaube, ich muss mal mit meinem Mailprovider reden.
Ich glaube, du musst mal nochmal mit Clemens reden.
So, aber wie heißen die Ordner? Wie heißen die Ordner, wo gelöschte Mail reinkommt? Deleted Messages?
Das ist wieder wie am Mark.
Für Apple ist das so. Das ist nicht so festgelegt. Also die kommen, ich weiß gar nicht, ob die überhaupt mit irgendwelchen Defaults daherkommen oder ob du in der Konfiguration sagen musst, wo du das gerne hättest. Aber Deleted Messages ist auf jeden Fall nicht.
Doch, das könnte bei Entourage oder Outlook...
Entourage, Outlook Server vielleicht.
Ich glaube, das ist sogar bei Apple genauso.
Ja, bei Apple ist das so, aber jetzt bei normalen E-Maps...
Ja, weil diese Ordner entstehen. Also es ist dann einfach, dass sie dann da sind und...
Ich weiß.
In dem einen kleinen sehe ich sie halt nicht, weil es ein Special-Ordner ist und in dem anderen sehe ich sie halt, weil es für ihn ein Ordner ist, wie jeder andere auch. Und das ist einfach schlecht.
Ja, das ist das Ding. Also du kannst halt MAD benutzen oder Postbox oder Thunderbolt und dann hast du halt E-Map, aber nicht so den Apple User Interface-Bonus. Oder du willst den Apple User Interface-Bonus und hast halt ein grottiges E-Map. Also wie gesagt, ich wollte halt ein cooles E-Map-Interface haben und halt irgendwie die ganzen Features auch ordentlich benutzen können. Und dann hab ich halt gesagt, ja dann Apple Mail, dann bist du es jetzt gerade halt mal nicht. Und ich komm mit dem Postbox, ich bin damit auch nicht hundertprozentig glücklich, aber wie gesagt, zumindest diesen E-Map-Kram kriegt es halt hin. So was zum Beispiel bei Apple Mail schon immer nicht richtig gegangen oder wo man halt seinen Server auch schon wieder weg. Was bei Apple Mail schon immer so ein Problem war, war auf E-Map-Folder sich zu subscriben. Also zum Beispiel, wenn du so ein Global-Folder hattest, zum Beispiel ein cooles Setup bei...
Du hast einfach immer alle Orner gesehen.
Ja, ne du konntest, also es gab immer dieses Fenster, wo eigentlich diese Ordner auftauchen sollten, aber bei den meisten Mails, aber wenn sie nicht irgendwie speziell konfiguriert waren, ging das halt nicht. In anderen Clients war das immer kein Problem. Es war immer Apple Mail, wo immer so ein, weiß nicht, ein Special Voodoo Zauber nötig war.
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass man Subscriber überhaupt in Apple Mail hatte. Ich dachte, sie unterstützen dieses Feature wahrscheinlich nicht.
Ne, das gab's irgendwann in Präferenz, das versteckt. Und das coole Feature ist nämlich, wenn du so einen globalen Folder hast, dann kannst du einen globalen Ham- und Spam-Folder haben. Und dann können halt Leute sozusagen manuell Spam-Mails, die durch den Filter durchgerutscht sind, in den Spam-Folder legen und so Mails, die jetzt nicht so unbedingt private Informationen oder was das ist. Also du kannst auch sogar jedem User einen Ham-Folder in seiner E-Map-Box legen und dann können sie halt Mails, die fälschlicherweise im Spam gelandet sind, sozusagen da reinziehen und damit geht einmal der Tag der Spam-Filter-Learner drüber und lernt sozusagen Ham und Spam noch besser zu unterscheiden, also auch für deine Firmen oder im Kommunikationskontext. Das ist halt ein cooles Feature und das ging halt auch mit diesen Folder-Subscribes. Du kannst halt den Usern anbieten und wenn sie das Feature haben wollen, klicken sie in ihr Mail klein und subscriben sich auf diese Folder. Aber mit Apple Mail war das schon immer ein Krampf. Ich hab jetzt die letzte Version in Mountain Lion nicht ausprobiert, aber ich würde mich doch stark wundern, wenn sie es plötzlich irgendwie geschafft hätten mal.
Ich nutze, glaube ich, so unglaublich wenig Mail-Features. Was ich wirklich mal gerne wissen würde, ich hab ja ein Gmail-Account, wie mache ich, ohne über das Mail-Interface, ohne über Gmail gehen zu müssen, dem Gmail klar, das ist jetzt Spam, das will ich nie wieder sehen. Das ist so was, was ich nicht verstehe. Reicht das, wenn ich das von Hand in den Gmail-Spam-Ordner reinschiebe? Hat da jetzt irgendjemand mal was rausgekriegt? Wäre dann mal ganz spannend.
Okay, wir vertagen das Thema.
Aber ich hab noch was.
Ich hab auch eine Mail.
Ja, ich hab auch Mail. Ich hab jetzt einen zweiten Gmail-Google-Account und da fängt es an furchtbar zu werden. Also ich hatte ewig lange eine Gmail-Adresse und war damit auch ganz glücklich. Aber irgendwie kommt man ja mal auf die Idee, dass es eventuell nicht gut wäre, sich auf alle Ewigkeiten so doll an Google zu binden und dass man wenigstens die Option hat, jederzeit den Mail-Server zu wechseln. Also hab ich dann irgendwann mir mal die Mail-Adresse unter meinem eigenen Domain maxher343max.de eingerichtet. Ein zweiter Hintergrund war, dass ich ja vorhabe, nächstes Jahr zu heiraten und dass ich dann meinen Nachname ändern wird und dass ich dann sozusagen jetzt schon mal unauffällig den Nachnamen aus der, also so damit ich dann die E-Mail-Adresse nicht wechseln muss.
Dann windest du dich raus.
Ich winde mich raus, genau. Und darum hab ich mir mit Google Apps damals noch rechtzeitig, mittlerweile kostet das ja jetzt auch Geld auch für kleinere Kunden, hab ich mir so ein Domain da eingerichtet, was ja auch furchtbar schmerzhaft ist. Also wenn man auf diese, so das überhaupt zu finden in dem Interface, also ich google jedes Mal nach Google Apps und dann komm ich da auf die Seite, wo ich das Produkt kaufen soll und das dann irgendwo ein ganz kleiner Login-Link, nach einer Weile hat man schon...
Das mit diesem Web haben die Google-Jungs nämlich auch gar nicht so richtig drauf, ne?
Ne, überhaupt nicht. Und dann hab ich das da eingerichtet und hab da eigentlich nichts weiter gemacht als eine Weiterleitung von meiner 343max.de-Adresse an meine Gmail-Adresse, weil ich wollte jetzt nicht den ganzen Wusel da mit alle Kalender rüberziehen und weiß derzeit was. Genau, fast Max-Zufall. Ja, das mit der Mail-Weiterleitung hat ok-isch funktioniert. Aber es gab auch Sachen, die haben da überhaupt nicht dran funktioniert. Das eine war die Absender-Adresse. Nämlich, weil auf dem iPhone nutze ich das ja über Exchange, also da habe ich ja das Exchange-Protokoll. Und das Exchange-Protokoll kann offensichtlich, also ich vermute, dass es das Exchange-Protokoll ist, vielleicht ist es auch irgendein anderer. Hansel in diesen ganzen Instanzen kann nur eine Absender-Adresse. Und zwar die vom Server vorgegebene. Und das ist natürlich meine richtige Adresse. Jetzt wollte ich natürlich abgehende Mails unter maxer343max.de haben. Geht auch. Gibt es auch eine Einstellung in den Gmail-Einstellungen? Kann man auch eine Send-Adress-S mit seiner default-Adresse. Das passiert dann aber dazu, dass das iPhone glaubt, ich hätte diese Hauptadresse, also max.winner.gmail und das andere. Und wenn ich zum Beispiel auf eine Mail, die an mich gerichtet ist, antworte, mich dann selber wieder in den CC setzt und so eine Spähe. Also das macht keinen Spaß. Das andere ist, dass man natürlich dann irgendwann zum Beispiel Kalender, Termineinladung an die maxr343max.de Adresse kriegt. So. Wenn ich die dann probiere, bei, mit dem anderen Mail-Account zu sagen, ja, ich möchte gerne an dieser Veranstaltung teilnehmen, zu sagen, nein, sie sind nicht eingeladen, bitte wenden sie sich an den Administrator, bla bla bla bla. Also hab ich beschlossen, dass ich, hab ich einfach gesagt, okay, ich richte mir einen zweiten Mail-Account ein. Ich hab jetzt auf dem iPhone sozusagen zwei private Mail-Accounts. Und von da abfängt es an, sehr, sehr merkwürdig zu werden. Ab da erst? Ich hab probiert, ach so, was ich, genau, eigentlich von der Einrichtung her war es relativ unproblematisch. Hab halt auf dem Mac einen neuen Mail-Account eingerichtet, auf dem iPad, auf dem iPhone. Muss man jetzt ja mittlerweile pro Gerät einmal machen, sind halt mehr Geräte. Na gut, ist es halt so. Ich wollte es jetzt aber auch gerne so haben, dass ich ein Profilbild habe. Bei Gmail hat man ja oben diese Leiste, wo man zwischen den Accounts hin und her schaltet. Und wenn kein Profilbild da ist, ist das für mich immer so ein Zeichen. Ah, du bist auf einem falschen Account. Wechsle schnell den Account, weil ich habe so einen Firmenmail-Account zum Beispiel, wo ich wirklich nun, also den habe ich in Mail drinne und darüber werde ich niemals irgendwas im Netz machen. Und wenn das, dann ist das das Zeichen, dass irgendwas falsch läuft. Also so wollte ich eigentlich nur ein eigenes Profilbild einrichten. Jetzt hat aber ja Google irgendwann mal dieses Google Plus eingerichtet. Und offensichtlich haben sie in dem Zug beschlossen, wer ein Profilbild will, braucht auch einen Google Plus Account. Also, wann immer ich probiert habe, dieses Profilbild zu ändern, bin ich irgendwie auf so einer Google Plus Seite gelandet. Und auf dieser Google Plus Seite stand dann, ihr Administrator hat Google Plus nicht freigeschaltet. Bitte wenden Sie sich an Ihren Administrator. So, dann habe ich meinen inneren Administrator angeschmissen, bin in die Google Apps-Administrations-Überfläche gegangen, habe da auch ein bisschen rumgesucht. Und da stand dann, Google Plus ist ein Premium, blablabla, Drecksdienst kostet so und so viel im Monat. Dann habe ich gedacht, nee. Dann habe ich aber nochmal per Twitter rumgefragt und dann gab es dann irgendwie noch so, nee, das geht auch kostenlos, das geht auch irgendwie kostenlos. Dann habe ich da ewig lange rumgesucht. Da gab es auch irgendwo einen Link, dass das kostenlos ist. Ich habe keine Ahnung, was das mit den Premiumzeug auf sich hat. Dann habe ich da das Google Plus freigeschaltet. Dann habe ich mir für diese max-f343-max.de-Adresse einen zweiten Google Plus Account eingerichtet. Das bei Google, die ja so Hey, Real Name Policy. Und wir wollen das jeder Person. Aber wenn du einen privaten und einen Firmenaccount hast, dann brauchst du schon mal zwei Google Plus Accounts. Hab mir da einen Google Plus Account eingerichtet, hab ein Bild hochgeladen, hab diesen Google Plus Account zu vergessen. Was für ein Fehler. Jetzt kriege ich natürlich ständig von Google irgendwelche Mails. Hey Max, wir haben da folgende Freunde für dich gefunden. Möchtest du dich nicht mal wieder auf Google Plus anmelden? So, diese ganzen Notifications, die ich bei meinem alten Google Plus Account schon abgeschaltet hatte, die waren jetzt plötzlich wieder an. Und Google scheint sehr, sehr verzweifelt zu sein, was die Nutzer ihres Dienstes angeht. Man kriegt sehr, sehr viele von diesen Möchtest du nicht Freund mit so und so werden Mails.
Ich weiß schon mal, wo ich meinen eigenen Mails habe.
Vielleicht ist es schon besser.
Das ist...
Vor allen Dingen auch diese... Weil ich hab das ja, hatte ich ja auch schon mal erzählt, ich hab das ja auch so gemacht, dass ich halt mehrere Mail-Accounts auf einen Server gezogen hab, quasi mit Aliasen und so weiter. Und in meiner Inbox gibt es halt vier Subfolder pro E-Mail-Adresse ein. Und wenn ich eine Mail sende, dann werden die auch im Sendmail-Folder zu der jeweiligen E-Mail-Adresse einsortiert und so weiter. Und das geht auch alles wunderbar, aber sowas kann man halt auch nicht woanders so bei Google oder so konfigurieren. Das ist schön, aber es war auch sehr viel Arbeit, muss ich sagen. So ein Mailserver, der richtet sich nicht von alleine ein, ne?
Nee, da kannst du mal einen Screencast machen.
Also ich weiß nicht, ich will das auch eigentlich nicht mehr. Also ich hab ja auf meinem... Ich hab mich bewusst dagegen entschieden.
Man muss ja eigentlich auch nicht jeder seinen eigenen haben, aber es könnten sich ja schon immer so ein paar Leute zusammen tun. Und jeder, der ein bisschen Admin ist, sollte auch für Friends und Family, dass die auch wegkommen von diesem Scheiß, ganzen anderen Services.
Nee, noch besser. Firmen sollten sowas als bezahlte Dienstleistungen anbieten.
Es gibt ja so Hosted Exchange zum Beispiel. Das kostet so irgendwie 5-6.
Wie meinst du bezahlte Dienstleistungen?
Das gibt es doch auch. Bei jedem Web-Poster kriegst du eine E-Mail zu deinen eigenen Domänen mit Web-Mail.
Aber die sind doch eben scheiße.
Die sind nicht so scheiße wie jetzt noch das bei Google, wo du das Produkt bist.
Aber Google ist eigentlich auch gut.
Ich hätte auch mal nichts gegen einen Mail-Service-Dienstleister. Einer, der Mail kann. Wo du irgendwie dir das Standard-Paket klickst und du hast automatisch irgendwie Plus-Support in deiner E-Mail-Adresse, wie bei Gmail, mit irgendwie automatischer Sortierung in Folder.
Die Firma, die das für mich macht, die heißt Krux GmbH.
Aber es gibt tatsächlich Dienstleister, die sowas anbieten.
Es gibt doch hier Fast-Mail-FM, hat vorhin einer im Chat gesagt oder uberspace.de oder was weiß ich.
Hucke, lass mal dein Setup kopieren und jeder, der Account haben will, zahlt uns einen Euro im Monat.
Ich hab bei denen eine Adresse, die nichts kostet, bei outlook.com. Das ist jetzt ehemals Hotmail. Sagen sie es jetzt unbedingt in Outlook. Probieren jetzt langsam, die User rüberzuziehen. Sieht vom Webinterface relativ okay aus. kann wohl auch Exchange und dieses ganze Zeug, also Push und Kalender und Sinken und weiß der Teufel was. ich weiß nicht, man kann wohl auch eigene Domains draufziehen. Das geht wohl auch. Vielleicht ist das ja was. Ich hab's nicht so genau getestet, aber so richtig schlecht sah es nicht aus. Und Outlook. Microsoft ist ja gerade so ein bisschen in einer Verliererposition. Die können sich im Augenblick nicht so weit aus dem Fenster läden. Mit wie weit sie ihre Kunden verarschen.
Ich glaub, die können immer noch. Ich glaub, die haben das noch nicht gelernt, was sie eigentlich tun müssen.
Macht auf jeden Fall nicht so einen extrem schlechten Eindruck.
Kommen wir vielleicht zu Dienstleistungen, die alle mögen? Also ich zum Beispiel. Ich mag ja Dropbox sehr. Ich weiß, es gibt da auch diverse Alternativen und die sind auch vielleicht billiger oder größer oder mehr Space oder drauf geschissen. Aber Dropbox funktioniert mittlerweile einfach extrem zuverlässig. Ich meine, die hatten auch so ihre Probleme mit...
Bitrot.
Mit Bitrot?
Hatten sie das nicht auch mal?
Nee, die hatten mal eher so ein paar Security-Passwort-Probleme.
Mit Bitrot, das war glaube ich eher so ein Bug in X3, der es dann geschafft hat, in Verbindung mit einem Linux-Könnel, der jemanden ganz furchtbar aufgeregt hat.
Linux ist schuld. Ich wollte nur noch mal kurz Dropbox erwähnen, weil die jetzt so ein neues Feature haben. Dropbox links heißt das. Jetzt kannst du quasi jedes File aus deiner Dropbox eben mal public machen. Dann kannst du halt einfach ein Link generieren und dem jemanden schicken und dann kann der dann eben auf die Datei zugreifen. Das war vorher nicht ganz so einfach möglich, wie es jetzt möglich ist. Und das ist eigentlich cool.
Ich wollte ja neulich was mit Ipsys und Zet machen und das ging dann nicht. Da war ich sehr genervt. Und zwar ich wollte das machen, dass... Kurze Leutaten? Ja, genau. Mein Prozess, wenn ich einen Podcast gemacht habe, ist der folgende. Ich nehme das auf mit Reaper auf dem MacBook Pro zu Hause.
Das finde ich ja so hart.
Es ist eine Software, die hat mich irgendwie einen Bruchteil dessen gekostet, was der Rest so kostet. Hat alle Features, die ich so brauche. Ist vom Interface, ja finde ich live jetzt ehrlich gesagt, ist Geschmackssache, aber ich würde sagen, nimmt sich nicht so wahnsinnig viel. Und man kann vernünftig je mehr Spuraufnahmen und kann das alles und ich bin glücklich. Und ich kann dann, und ich rendere die Datei und rendere direkt auf die Dropbox als Flaggfile. Und dann spielt Dropbox das hoch. Und wie könnt ihr euch vorstellen, das dauert so eine Weile. Und dann hat man halt, irgendwann hätte ich gerne, also am liebsten wäre es mir natürlich, dass auf Phonik dann irgendwann mitkriegt, Moment mal, die Datei ist da, jetzt fange ich mal an, direkt die entsprechenden Versionen draus zu generieren und das dann wieder zurück auf meinen Server zu spielen direkt. Das macht das ja auch dann per SFTP, das funktioniert ja alles ganz hervorragend. Habe ich die auch mal angehauen, meint sie, ja, wäre ein spannendes Feature, hätten sie auch gerne. Bis dahin hielt ich es ja erstmal für ganz okay, wenn ich eine Push-Notification kriege, wenn die Datei da ist. Und dann dachte ich so, naja, if this is the NSZ hat ja hier Push-over-Support, also diese App und es hat Dropbox-Support, das geht auch. Und man kann auch ordentlich überwachen. Aber man kann dummerweise nur sein Public-Folder überwachen. Man kann nicht einfach jeden beliebigen Ordner überwachen und sagen, wenn sich da was ändert, dann löse mal eine if this is the NSZ-Aktion aus. Man kann halt immer nur ein Public-Folder überwachen.
Obwohl man sich da schon einloggt innerhalb von if this is the NSZ.
Du kannst ja auch Dateien reinschreiben per if this is the NSZ. Es gibt ja auch so Instagram-Bilder, das mache ich zum Beispiel als Bildschirmschoner. Das ist Instagram-Bilder, die ich gemacht habe, die ich like und von Freunden automatisch in einer Dropbox landen. Mein Bildschirmschoner bedient sich dann aus der Dropbox, was so zum Foto-Anzeigen geht. Das ist ganz hübsch. Also das funktioniert alles, aber if this is the NSZ ist leider nicht flexibel genug. Das geht schon in eine sehr, sehr richtige Richtung, aber die haben es dann irgendwie auf so eine doch etwas dumme Art ein bisschen zu dumm gemacht.
Die sollen da endlich mal Flatter einbauen.
Automatisches Flattern, ja das wär cool.
Ja, dass man da überhaupt mal Flatter nutzen kann, dass man da flattern kann, dass man Flatter-Lookups machen kann.
Es gibt hunderte Dienste, die die mal dringend einbeten sollten.
Ja, aber vor allem Flatter.
Auch Flatter, sag ich mal.
Nein, vor allem.
Wollen wir uns mal nicht streiten?
Wollen wir mal lieber Bitcoins reden, ne?
Ne, bevor wir zu den Nerd-Kramen kommen, vielleicht noch ein bisschen Kleinkram.
Aber wo wir bei Dropbox gerade waren, kann ich vielleicht noch mal sagen, Sparkle Share ist fertig. Das ist ja dieses...
Git-based Dropbox.
Git-based Dropbox. Was daran schön ist, was bei Dropbox ja leider auch nicht wirklich geht. Ich hätte ja gerne sowas, dass ich ein Ordner auf meinem Server habe und der synchronisiert wird automatisch mit einem Ordner, den ich in der Dropbox habe. So irgendwie könnte man so ein komplettes Wordpress da reinpacken, editiert das lokal und es wird automatisch hochgesyncht oder sowas. Und das würde zum Beispiel mit SparkleShare ganz hervorragend gehen. Vermutlich mal. Hab's aber auch noch nicht probiert. SparkleShare, du hast einen GitHub-Account irgendwo, entweder...
Ja, du kannst entweder hostest du dein eigenes GitHub-Repository auf deinem Server.
Oder halt GitHub, Bitbucket und wie sie nicht alle heißen.
Und dann hast du so einen Client, so ähnlich wie Dropbox sozusagen. Kannst halt auch sagen, hier, dass alles, was da reinfällt, auf diesen Server bitte. Und alle Clients, die sozusagen auf den gleichen Server zeigen, die werden dann auch so synchronisiert.
Und ist dann natürlich auch gleich versioniert.
Und versioniert.
Ist eher für Textdateien gedacht als jetzt für wirklich große Binärdateien? Weil halt alles mit Versionierung und Diff und so. Aber ich glaube, für sowas ist es ganz gut.
Ja, kann auch für so ein Entwicklungsworkflow vielleicht ganz hilfreich sein mal. Ach, die haben ja auch schon ein paar Flatterklicks gekriegt, die Jungs.
Ich war mal wieder in so einem Apple Store.
Schon wieder?
Naja, ich hatte ja ein neues iPhone 5 bekommen. Da habe ich dann auch, warum ich da mal reingehe, weil ich da irgendwie ordentlichen Support kriege. Ich habe dann noch mal irgendwie so einen Experten befragt, ob er das eigentlich genauso sieht. Ich weiß nicht, ob wir überhaupt schon mal darüber gesprochen haben. Ihr habt ja dieses Problem nicht, deswegen ist das hier nie so ein Thema. Aber so dieses iPad, das gilt ja so ein bisschen so als Wunderwaffe für Kinder. Was es da nicht tolle Sachen gibt, da kann man im Internet browsing, da kann man irgendwie Spiele drauf spielen, pipa po. So und jetzt denkt man sich natürlich, was passiert wohl, wenn ich jetzt meinem Kind mein iPad gebe?
Scheibe kaputt?
Na jetzt mal abgesehen von diesen Hardware-Problemen, die kann man ja durch Geld relativ easy lösen. Aber es gibt ja auch noch so andere Probleme. Darum geht es mir nicht so sehr, sondern die Kollateralschäden. Da ist dann Mail drauf zum Beispiel. Und es ist für so ein Kind sehr einfach, mal eben dein komplettes Mail-Archiv der letzten 10 Jahre zu löschen, mit ein paar Finger. Dann denkst du dir doch, vielleicht sollte man das weglassen. Wie machst du das? Vor allem grundsätzlich, du kannst überhaupt nicht auf so einem iOS-Gerät sagen, das benutzt jetzt mal jemand anders.
Das geht ja beim Nexus, ne?
Ja, das haben sie da jetzt eingebaut.
Deswegen finden wir Konkurrenz auch voll toll.
Bei Windows 8 haben sie da wirklich, wie ich finde, also ich hab's nicht in Aktion gesehen, aber es hat einen schönen Namen, es heißt Kids Corner und es ist nämlich, dass du direkt auf dem Log-Screen von dem Windows-Phone hast du eine eigene Geste und damit kommst du in diesen reduzierten Modus und brauchst auch keinen Pin eingeben. Und kannst da nur auf die Spiele zugreifen zum Beispiel. Und du brauchst dafür eine eigene Geste zu haben, die so ein bisschen versteckter ist, aber was so ein Kind nach ungefähr drei Sekunden drauf hat, finde ich total geil. Du brauchst das dem Kind nur in die Hand zu drücken, hier, nimm und das Kind weiß Bescheid.
Ja gut, aber es gibt ja jetzt dieses Feature, dass du so ein gesicherter Modus oder irgendwie so ein Kack da einschalten kannst. Aber es ist nicht so, dass du dann sagen kannst, lass die Mail weg. Also es ist nicht so, dass das Mail-Icon verschwinden darf, sondern du kannst auch diese App nicht löschen, das ist nicht möglich, weil die muss ja da sein, weil wie soll es sein, dass dein Kind deine ganze Mail löscht? Und stattdessen, das Einzige, was du sperren, du kannst auch nicht den Zugang zum Mail sperren, sondern du kannst nur sperren, dass neue Accounts angelegt werden. Ja, schau dir das an, das ist das Einzige, was du da machen kannst. Das heißt, du musst alle Accounts löschen auf so einem iPad, das sonst gar keinen Zugriff hat, und dann kannst du halt maximal die Sperrung du darfst keine anderen anlegen machen.
Aber es gibt doch, hast du diesen Modus mal, also ich weiß nicht, ob das für deine Bedürfnisse ausreicht, es gibt ja diesen Log-Modus, wo man sagt, diese App kann nicht mehr verlassen werden.
Auf dem iPad.
Ja, ich will ja, dass sie die Apps verlassen.
Du möchtest, dass sie zwischen verschiedenen Spielen hin und her wechseln können.
Ja, ich möchte halt einfach mich einloggen auf dem scheiß Teil und einen zweiten Account machen und sagen, lalala. Aber was ich halt noch viel krasser finde, an der Stelle haben wir jetzt auch mal wieder mit dem Evil Empire zu tun, ich könnte natürlich jetzt sagen, ok, du kriegst jetzt dein eigenes scheiß iPad. Es ist nicht möglich, ein iPad in so einen Modus zu bringen, dass man vielleicht mal nur ein Sub-Set von Sachen benutzt, weil es würde ja ausreichen. Nein, ich könnte ja auch noch ein anderes iPad nur für die Kinder kaufen. Irgendwann ist man wahrscheinlich an diesem Punkt und denkt sich scheiß drauf. Weil die wollen sowieso die ganze Zeit damit spielen.
Du hast jetzt eh schon zwei, drei...
Also das ist eh schon... Als Uhr hängen. Insofern kannst du auch für deine Kinder ein iPad kaufen.
Das iPad, ich weiß nicht, warum man euch da immer so aufregt, das iPad ist hervorragend als Uhr.
Wir regen uns gar nicht auf hier. Eben ist es nur besonders hervor.
Dieses iPad, was da oben hängt als Uhr, benutze ich den ganzen Tag. Das ist die beste Uhr, die ich je hatte. Versuch mal eine gute Uhr zu kaufen. Versuch mal eine Uhr zu kaufen, die dir die Zeit ordentlich anzeigt auf diesem Planeten. Das ist nicht einfach. Glaubt man nicht, dass es das Produkt Uhr überhaupt noch gäbe. Da seid ihr geschockt.
Ich hab geguckt.
Digital-Uhr? Kriegst du nicht. Es gibt einfach keine Digital-Uhr. Die Revolution der 80er Jahre.
Nichts.
80er Jahre, du hast das Stichwort schon gesagt.
Naja, aber es war keine schlechte Idee. Was hast du denn?
Hast du Analog-Uhr auf deinem Computer?
Du hast auch eine Digital-Uhr.
Bleib mal in den 80ern.
Unter Garantie lässt du dir die Zeit mehrmals am Tag digital anzeigen. Allein schon von deinem scheiß iPhone.
Ja klar, aber dann brauch ich auch keine.
Okay, sag mal so, ich knie also schon nieder und sag, okay, Apple, ihr habt mich so weit, ich kauf jetzt ein anderes Gerät, weil ich darf ja nicht so ein Login machen. Hab ich jetzt nicht gemacht, aber ich sag mal nur, ich würde es tun. Und dann, wie richte ich dieses Gerät ein? Ich kann ja ja nur genau den gleichen Scheiß wieder irgendwie installieren, so und dann halt auch irgendwie, ja, da geht dann halt auch keine Mail. Es sei denn, ich benutze halt einen anderen Account.
Ja, also iCloud fällt aus, sonst ist ja alles wieder drauf.
Ja, das heißt, ich muss dann dem Kind dann vielleicht noch einen eigenen Account machen.
Eine eigene EC-Karte oder Kreditkarte am besten machen.
Und natürlich alle Programme nochmal kaufen. Weil, warum sollte denn das, was ich kaufe, warum sollte es mir denn gestattet sein, Spiele, die ich von meinem teuren Geld gekauft habe, mit meinen Kindern zu teilen?
Und wenn du den gleichen Account benutzt, können sie wieder deine Mails löschen, richtig?
Na ja, gut, die Mails müssen ja nicht eingerüstet werden. Mail-Account ist ja schon nochmal ein bisschen was anderes, aber das geht ja dann auch gleich weiter mit AppStore und Pipapo.
Na aber wieso eigentlich könntest du das machen? Du könntest dich mit deinem AppStore-Account einloggen, dann könnten sie alle Apps installieren, die du auch hast, aber du lässt halt den ganzen anderen Zeugs weg. Das geht ja praktischerweise. Das ist sehr nervig, wenn man ein neues Telefon einrichtet. Ja, auch für Game Center möchte ich meine Apple ID verwenden und auch für kaufen möchte ich und auch für iCloud und so, aber das kannst du ja alles noch getrennt machen. Ja, das geht alles. Und du kannst ja, ich mach das ja auch regelmäßig.
Was hat denn der Experte gesagt?
Der Genius?
Naja, den Genius, ich hab jetzt nicht diese volle Debatte dort entfacht, sondern mir ging es halt sozusagen nur um dieses Reduzieren, dass ich nicht in der Lage bin, so ein iPad soweit zu reduzieren, dass man einfach mal mail... Ich würde ja so gerne so ein Gerät dann vielleicht auch selber benutzen. Natürlich kann ich das so weit runter stritten, dass es dann nur noch von Kindern benutzt werden kann, aber dann ist das Gerät für mich halt selber so useless, weil ich dann alles wieder anschalten, neu konfigurieren müsste, nur um mal eine Mail abzufragen und danach müsste ich die Accounts wieder alle löschen.
Das ist totaler Blödsinn.
Ja, das wäre einfach.
Es ist wirklich totaler Blödsinn und der empfiehlt dann auch nichts anderes ein. Die zweite Sache, die ich den Genius gefragt habe, ist, ob es irgendeine Möglichkeit gibt, diese scheiß Spracherkennung auf diesem iPhone auszuschalten. Und das geht auch nicht.
Kann man Siri nicht abschalten?
Siri kann man abschalten, aber wenn du Siri abschaltest, kommt die Spracherkennung. Und die Spracherkennung kann man nicht abschalten. Weil wenn du nämlich dein scheiß Telefon in deiner Tasche hast und es ist hunderttausendmal gelockt, gelockt wie in Fort Knox, drückst du einfach auf diesen scheiß Button eine Weile und dann macht's BEEP BEEP! Nicht Open my Browser, sondern ruf irgendeinen scheiß Typen, dessen Telefonnummer du zwar noch in deiner Adressbuchliste hast an. Was machst du denn da?
Er hat Voice Control gestartet und das hat jetzt gerade mit deinem Raten in den Song abgestartet.
Ja, aber ich mein, das musst du natürlich mal klar machen. Dieses Telefon ruft.
Auch im Lock-Modus?
Ja, weil du es nicht ausschalten kannst. Drück da einfach mal lange auf diese Tasse und dann hast du deine scheiß Spracherkennung.
Also, wenn du nicht Siri hast? Oder kriegst du einen Lock-Spring.
Ja, oder Siri ist ja genau das gleiche, aber Siri hört dir dann auch zu und tut irgendwas auf Basis dessen, was du da irgendwie machst.
Du löscht all meine Mail.
Das ist jeder Befehl für sein. Das ist das Lustige. Ich sag, ich geh nämlich nach Hause. Also du brauchst ja gar keine Kinder mehr.
Ich find das frech. Ach, dann muss ich Java benutzen auf meinem Computer. Jetzt, nachdem Apple das in allen Browsern dieses Plugin rausgenommen hat, was sie mal selber gehackt haben, und dann wirst du ja gezwungen von diesem scheiß Oracle laden, dir Java runterzuladen. Dann kommt dann dieses Plugin, das geht auch relativ schmerzfrei.
Ach, du brauchst das als Plugin noch dazu?
Naja, im Webbrowser brauchst du das Plugin.
Ja, nee, also du wolltest nicht Java generell, also dass dann die Java...
Die Java ist ja da, aber dieses Java Webbrowser Plugin, das haben sie ja jüngst gelöscht. Wegen Bodennebel und gefährlich, und wir wollen nicht verantwortlich dafür sein und so, schrei die anderen an. Und jetzt kriegst du halt quasi dieses Replacement Plugin von Oracle. Dann merkt man mal wieder, was Apple da alles für Integrationsleistungen geleistet hat damals, als es das noch gab, die jetzt nicht mehr da sind.
Sieht jetzt komplett nach Swing aus, oder wie sieht das denn aus?
Ach naja, das Aussehen, ich meine Java sah ja schon immer scheiße aus.
Ja, aber nicht ganz so scheiße.
Daran hat sich jetzt eigentlich nichts weiter geändert. Ne, nur die Integration mit dem Betriebssystem ist halt jetzt scheiße. Vorher war sie so gerade noch so zu vertragen.
Wie ist sie jetzt?
Naja, also ich hab immer diesen Fall Umsatzsteuererklärung. Was machen wir dann?
Elster anrufen.
Elster online.
Ach, ich dachte dann Steuerberater holen.
Ne Umsatzsteuer-Voranmeldung. Achso, da hol ich jetzt keinen Steuerberater aus dem Bett. Also für die paar Zahlen, das krieg ich schon noch selber hin. So, aber du musst ja dann über diese Webseite gehen. Man korrigiere mich, wenn ich irgendwas missverstanden habe, aber so mache ich das und dann geht man da hin und dann musst du da vorher schon in so einem völlig absurden Prozess dir da so ein Zertifikat besorgen, damit das alles hoch verschlüsselt ist und so weiter. Weil ein normales Passwort tut es natürlich nicht. Nein, das muss dann hier mit Krypto und Tralala und Aluhut und Volles Pumper. Meinetwegen.
Kato meint, wir könnten mal einen anderen Master-Server haben. Ja. Damit der Stream besser funktioniert.
Aber es fällt doch hier das Netz auch aus.
Das sind zwei Probleme.
Soll da mal der Meta... Nein, das Netz fällt hier nicht aus.
Da hat er auch der Meta immer geschrieben.
Ja, ne, schreib mich mal direkt an.
Alter! Mit den Zugangsdaten, dann trage ich die ein.
Wo war ich? Irgendwas mit... Keine Ahnung, war es wichtig?
Das heißt, das erste, was du machen musst, ist, du musst dein Zertifikat hochladen, wenn du dich da einloggst.
Bei Elster?
Ja, bei Elster. Da kommt so ein Filebrowser hoch. Das heißt, dieses Java-Plugin öffnet dann so ein Filebrowser. Und es kann natürlich nicht sein, dass es sich dabei um den Standard Filebrowser handelt. Natürlich nicht, das ist ein schöner Swingbrowser. Nein, da kommt irgendwie so ein Auswurf, so ein Magenauswurf von Filebrowser hoch, in dem einfach gar nichts funktioniert, was man in den letzten 20 Jahren liebgewonnen hat. Weder kannst du da auf Buchstaben tippen auf deiner Tastatur oder springt an den richtigen Stelle in der aktuellen Liste, noch dass du da irgendwas reindrängen kannst, um irgendwie mal schnell irgendein File auszuwählen. Das geht einfach nicht. Nein, du musst wirklich da durchscrollen, den Ordner doppelklicken, den du öffnen willst und dann wirklich Ordner für Ordner da durchmarschieren. Aber es ist auch nicht so, dass du dir alle Ordner angezeigt bekommst, die du auf deiner Festplatte hast.
Nur mit Elster im Namen.
Nur ohne, halte ich fest, ohne Umlaut. Wenn du da einen Ordner hast, der ein Äh enthält, ja, dann gibt es diesen Ordner einfach nicht in diesem Filebrowser. Wird einfach nicht angezeigt. Weil Ähs, wissen wir ja alle, sind das international vereinbarte Signal für Datensperrung.
Hinten Files sind immer mit Äh vorne.
Also ich muss erstmal meinen Ordner umbenennen, damit ich überhaupt in der Lage war, diese Datei überhaupt physikalisch auszuwählen.
Jetzt könnt ihr alle raten, wie der Ordner hieß.
Körperschaftssteuer.
Aber da ist auch kein Äh drin.
Geschäftliches oder sowas. Nicht, dass er gut benannt war, aber... So nennt man auch keinen Ordner. Ich meine, er war einfach nicht da. Noch nicht mal lachende Männchen oder sowas. Irgendwas Paragrafzeichen im String oder so. Damit hätte ich ja noch irgendwie leben können. Emojis wäre kein... Nicht anzeigen, das geht einfach gar nicht.
Tu wäre gegangen.
Also es ist wirklich alles...
es geht gar nicht.
So, dann hab ich noch eine letzte Geschichte aus der Abteilung weniger Schmerzen, weil ich hab das mal auf Uploadnet gepostet und festgestellt, dass viele Leute das gleiche Problem haben. Seit Mountain Lion, wenn man so Google-Kalender in seinem Kalender, ja, jetzt Grönländer-Thema, wenn man so Google-Kalender abonniert hat. Das geht ja so mit iCal, ganz brauchbar mit Lion. Und unter Mountain Lion kriegt man jetzt am laufenden Meter so 404 Fehler. Modale Dialoge gehen auf. Error, Falsch, Kalender.
Hatt ich erst, nachdem du darüber geschrieben hast.
Hatt ich das heute.
Hatt ich heute auch. Hab ich rausgeschmissen, nochmal reingeschmissen, dann ging's wieder.
Ich hab gar nichts gemacht. Ich hab okay gerückt und gewartet.
Okay, hier kommt die Lösung. Habt ihr sie auch doppelt? Habt ihr auch alle Kalender doppelt?
Das hatte ich erst nach diesem Altjungs-Sync. Da war auch der Google-Kalender doppelt drin plötzlich.
Das ist super geil. Also ich hatte nicht nur alle doppelt, sondern ich hatte dann so im Zwei-Tages-Abstand auch alle meine Google-Kalender nochmal als lokale Kalender.
Schön.
Also das iCal hat sozusagen alle gesunkenen Kalender nochmal als lokale Kalender angelegt. Das war richtig geil. So, die Lösung ist ganz einfach. Man nimmt in iCal diesen Google-Kalender komplett raus und macht das nur noch über dieses, wie heißt das Ding? Diese Preference-Pane, die man nicht benennen kann, weil sie so bekloppt benannt ist. Mail, Contacts and Calendars heißt es hier. Und da trägst du deinen Google-Account ein und klickst dann Kalender an. Und wenn du diese ganzen 404-Fehler bekommst, dann ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit groß, dass das da schon der Fall ist. Und dass iCal das sozusagen nochmal parallel nochmal über seine eigene Art und Weise da ranzugehen macht und da entsteht dieser ganze Quatsch. Also raus aus iCal, rein in die System-Preferenz und dann funktioniert das.
Und wenn man sonst... Nee, also sind wir jetzt mit dieser kleinen gemischten Sektion fertig, können wir jetzt mal wieder ein bisschen über Bitcoins reden?
Ja, wir können mal wieder über Bitcoins reden. Ich kriege jetzt gerade noch was die Spracherkennung und das automatische Wählen betrifft. Man könnte noch eine Codesperre für Sprachwahl einrichten. Dann könnte man das verhindern. Das werde ich mal ausprobieren.
Gut, aber erst lauschst du uns und dann lauschst du uns annächtig, was es Neues zum Thema Bitcoins zu berichten gibt. Und zwar an alle da draußen jetzt also schon auf ihren Bergen von Bitcoins sitzen. Jetzt nach dem letzten Block Split, den hat man ja schon in der Sendung besprochen, oder?
Der kam dann aber erst noch. Und der kam und ging vorüber. Ich hatte ja gesagt, dass man jetzt ein bisschen gucken sollte. Die Preise sind ein ganz bisschen angestiegen, also der Wechselkurs von Euro zu Bitcoin, aber nicht wesentlich, also nicht mal 10% glaube ich so richtig. Und der Block Split an sich war ja noch nie da gewesen. Das war der erste gegen Software mäßig, also auch reibungslos über die Bühne. Also das ist im Jahr 2000 wahrscheinlich mehr passiert.
Genau und jetzt sitzen halt alle durch diesen immerhin ein bisschen Kurssprung auf zu viel Bitcoins und wissen nicht, was sie damit tun sollen. Und da gibt es jetzt die Lösung. Kurssprung? Naja, so ein mini bisschen. Es setzt auf 10 Euro in etwa. Aber wenn ihr jetzt also nach Möglichkeiten sucht, entweder eure Bitcoins noch zu vermehren oder alle zu verlieren, es gibt quasi Bitcoin-Roulette, könnte man es nennen. Und zwar ziemlich cool gelöst, das heißt Satoshi Dice. Und das funktioniert so, ihr könnt jetzt mal alle parallel, auch die ihr nachträglich hört, auf satoshidice.com gehen. Ich paste auch die URL mal kurz in den Chat. Ich animiere euch jetzt natürlich nicht zum Glücksspiel. Mit einer Schaufel Salz wird ihr jetzt diesen Beitrag genießen. Das Schöne ist halt folgender. Ihr seht unten bei Bets so eine Liste von Bets. Und dann gibt es auch da die Gewinnchancen. Das ist wie beim Roulette. Es gibt also auch so eine Gewinnchance für so bei 50% und die Ausschüttungen, die es dann da eben gibt. Die Bank, schreiben sie auch vorne rein, hat einen Vorteil von 2 oder 3%, so ähnlich auch wie beim Roulette, wo es ja eigentlich perfekt fair wäre, wenn nicht die Null oder irgendwie noch was beim Roulette mit dabei wäre.
Ein 37. geht an die Bank oder irgendwie so.
Genau. Und bei Satoshi Dice ist es halt 2 oder 3%. Und das Schöne ist halt, man sucht sich jetzt also die Gewinnchance raus, die man gerne hätte oder den Multiplayer, den man gerne hätte und daneben steht eine Bitcoin-Adresse. Und man überweist an diese Bitcoin-Adresse also mindestens den Mindesteinsatz. Und dann wird sozusagen gewürfelt, also hier less than 32.000, also weniger als 32.000. Wenn die Zahl kleiner als 32.000 ist, dann kriegt man 48,8% Gewinnchance und einen Price-Multiplier von 2,004. Also man kriegt Doppelte raus. So, also man überweist da den Mindesteinsatz hin und man kriegt sofort eine Transaktion zurück in seiner Bitcoin-Wallet. Und entweder ist diese Transaktion halt 0,00001 Bitcoin oder was auch immer, also der super kleine Zahl. Oder man kriegt...
Der sogenannte Satoshi, das ist nämlich die kleinste eine, die in Bitcoin geht und die haben sie irgendwann mal Satoshi genannt.
Genau, also entweder man kriegt nur ein Satoshi zurück, also einen feuchten Händedruck quasi, also weniger als der Mindesteinsatz auf jeden Fall. Oder man kriegt sozusagen seinen Einsatz verdoppelt zurück. Und das halt relativ instant. Also man kann auch live dazugucken auf der Seite, indem man eben bei Reeson zum Beispiel guckt oder da wo es auch immer gerade aufblinkt. Das heißt es wird auch immer, also ich glaube sie haben die Zahlen schon entweder vorgezogen oder sie würfeln halt live, wenn du die Überweisung machst.
Ich glaube in der Überweisung, die sozusagen mathematisch mit Krypto herrscht, weil er das da ist, ist das Ergebnis schon drin. Ich dachte immer, dass es beim nächsten Blog ist, der gefunden wird, aber dann könnten sie es ja nicht sofort machen, deswegen muss es irgendwie anders gehen. Aber ich hab es mir nicht genau angeguckt.
Aber ich hab jetzt einen Kollegen von mir, der hat das halt mal ausprobiert, weil er da interessiert war. Und der hat halt diese weniger als 32.000 Gewinnchance genommen, also wo es 48,8 Prozent gibt. Und er hat halt irgendwie bei unter einem Bitcoin angefangen, hat dann immer verdoppelt und hat aber einen Sprung relativ mehr gemacht. Also er war dann schon irgendwann bei 16 Bitcoins, dann bei 32, hat wieder verloren, hat noch mal verdoppelt auf 64, wo er schon sagt, ok, wenn das jetzt schief geht, dann...
Das sind 640 Euro.
Ein Zocker, weil er meint halt, ok, ich hab jetzt noch ein paar Bitcoins hier und ich kann noch 2, 3 Mal verdoppeln. Irgendwann, wenn es dann halt doch klappt, dann hab ich's wieder drin. Und da hat er schon geschwitzt und hat dann noch mal mit 64 gespielt und dann hat er tatsächlich einmal gewonnen und hat dann am Ende des Tages hat er dann irgendwie so 15 Bitcoin-Gewinn tatsächlich auch gemacht, weil diesem Satoshi da ist. Aber es ist halt echt extrem interessant, halt einfach umgesetzt, dass du eine Überweisung machst mit dem Mindesteinsatz an die Adresse zu der Wette, die du halt machen willst. Also wie ein Roulette, ich setz jetzt auf rot oder was auch immer. Ich bette jetzt eben, dass es kleiner als 32.000 ist die Zahl, kriegst sofort eine Transaktion zurück und entweder ist eben nur ein Satoshi drin oder eben dein Gewinn. Das heißt, du hast wirklich instant quasi Bitcoin-Glücksspiel und kannst hier auf der Website auch noch live zugucken. Und Dennis meinte vorhin schon, die ganzen Bitcoin-Jungs, die hassen die Seite jetzt so ein bisschen oder finden es auf jeden Fall nicht so cool, weil da werden halt arsch viele Transaktionen natürlich generiert.
Seitdem sind diese Bitcoin-Files so riesengroß geworden. Und deswegen bauen die jetzt auch um, dass alles irgendwie viel kleiner wird und so weiter. Ich hab mal, ich erzähl mal kurz. Ich hab mal geguckt, also die sind wirklich doch gar nicht so klein. Das sind immer noch 4,5 Gigabyte aktuell. Und das ist schon das Neue, was demnächst rauskommt. Ich glaube noch mit der Alt-Methode ist es noch ein bisschen mehr. Was sie aber verbessert haben, ist, dass es eigentlich nur noch sekenziell hinten dran gehangen wird. Und der muss nicht die ganze Zeit in den 4 Gigabyte hin und her laden, so die ganze Zeit randommäßig, sondern es wird nur noch angangen. Also er kann irgendwie viel besser und schneller damit umgehen. Und deine Platte muss nicht mehr ganz so viel rödeln. Die Daten sind zwar da, aber die EO-Load von deinem Rechner, die sollte demnächst, wenn die Version 0.8 kommt, deutlich sinken.
So, jetzt kann man auf dieser Webseite, um das kurz abzuschließen, mit dem Satoshi Dice, kann man eben auch gucken, was so die Rare-Wins sind. Also Leute, die jetzt so richtig, da hat glaube ich einer mit Less Than 4 gewonnen. Zum Beispiel, man hat dann halt einen entsprechend hohen Multiplayer bekommen. Man kann eben zugucken, das ist schon ganz witzig. Aber wie gesagt, jetzt noch mal die Warnung. Also, Glücksspiel, wie gesagt, die Bank hat immer einen Vorteil, oder wie auch immer. Und ihr habt bei jedem Mal ziehen halt immer die gleiche Chance. Und es kann eben auch sein, dass ihr 15 oder 20 Mal eine Niete zieht und dann seid ihr halt schon pleite. Und dann habt ihr keine Chance mehr, mit einem Verdoppeln das rauszuholen. Also, das soll jetzt keine Ermutigung sein, aber ich fand es trotzdem mal so in diesem Bitcoin-Universum jetzt mal eine schöne oder eine interessante Idee sozusagen. Und es gibt natürlich auch Bitcoin...
Hast du das auch gemacht?
Ich hab's noch nicht gemacht. Ich hab nur beim Kollegen zugeschaut.
Ich hab einmal, als ich jung war, wahrscheinlich 19, als ich mein Kumpel 18 wurde, war ich in einer Spielbank am Kuhdamm. Da war genau das Gleiche. Da war schon irgendwie drei-, viermal rot gefallen und alle haben auf schwarz gesetzt. Der Tisch wurde immer voller und voller, also Roulette. Und irgendwann waren meine 400 DM weg. Und ich hab den Gruppier gefragt, wie weit das schon ging. Und der meinte, er hat schon bis 16 gesehen oder so. Also 16 mal die gleiche Farbe. Und Glücksspiel ist halt Glücksspiel.
Es ist halt jedes Mal die gleiche Chance.
Genau, die Chancen ändern sich nicht. Da kann so aufs Rot kommen, wie du willst. Das ist total egal. Die Bank nimmt ein 37. im Durchschnitt. Also bei Roulette und da halt irgendwie 2-3%.
Das ist halt so.
Ich bin, glaub ich, kein Zocker, weil ich kann mir das vorher durchrechnen, wie meine Chancen sind. Und der sagt mir immer, du verlierst.
Ja, wie gesagt, das ist halt so diese übliche Täuschung oder da, wo man sich halt schnell, glaube ich, verrennt. Weil man denkt so, ah, jetzt war es schon dreimal rot, jetzt ist ja die Chance viel höher, dass beim nächsten Mal jetzt also schwarz kommt.
Das ist, wenn man Mathe nicht verstanden hat.
Und das ist halt der entscheidende Knackpunkt. Aber es macht den Leuten trotzdem offensichtlich Spaß. Also das ist sehr populär, wenn man da so zuguckt, was da so live an Transaktionen durchgeht, ist da schon ordentlich Betrieb. Und es gibt halt auch sowas jetzt schon mittlerweile wie Bitcoin Lottery, wo halt so Losziehung und so weiter.
Ja, aber die gab's schon immer. Das sind diese ganzen Scammer und so. Da muss man ein bisschen aufpassen. Da sind nicht alle echt. Aber Satoshi, das war dein Kumpel ja auch, die 64 dann ausgezahlt bekommen hat. Also es hätte sich auch schon rumgesprochen, wenn es ein großer Scam ist.
Also das funktioniert auf jeden Fall. Also man kann das mal ausprobieren, aber bitte nicht süchtig werden oder alle sein Bitcoin-Vermögen da wegverspielen. Genau, spendet es lieber an die Mobile-Max-Crew, damit die auf Satoshi Dice ein Vermögen aufbauen können.
10 Euro, was ist das hier wert? 10,68 Euro gerade.
68 oder? Das haben wir heute erstiegen. Morgen waren es noch 10,30 Euro, glaube ich.
Ja, Last Trade, 10,68,25 Euro. Und wenn ich mich hier nicht vergucke, Mount Gox Euro, das ist schon relevant.
Mount Gox ist so der Größte.
Und ja, okay, das heißt, da ist ja hier mein Bitwald sogar ein bisschen Geld wert.
Interessant.
Kannst du uns Weihnachtsgeschenke kaufen?
Was war der Peak seinerzeit mal?
25?
Ja, so in dem Dreh. 30 Dollar oder so. Es war im Sommer, also Sommer 2011 war das so.
Das Sommer auf Bitcoin.
Als Fox halt auch so einen Bericht gemacht hat er so.
Genau, da war der Mega-Hype so und da ging es richtig ab.
Was ist denn Below Min? Hier spielt gerade jemand die ganze Zeit immer extrem kleine Summen.
Achso, auch da bei Satoshi Bin. Satoshi Dice.
Es steht immer als Result steht Below Min da.
Na, hast du wahrscheinlich gewonnen oder was?
Nein, Below Min. Wie kriegst du halt zurück, wenn er den Mindesteinsatz zu wenig, also wenn er unter dem Mindesteinsatz zu durft.
Achso, da war einfach jemand zu durft, die richtige Anzahl.
Und ist aber schon auch richtig abgesichert, weil es geht wirklich, die Transaction selbst ist, wo drin steht, ob die Zahlen stimmen oder nicht. Also sie können auch nicht wirklich so lotteriemäßig bescheißen, sondern die Transactions machen das. Und wenn das nicht stimmen würde, dann würde das ganze Bitcoin ja nicht sicher sein.
Also du kannst das auch überprüfen quasi, ob das dann auch wirklich ausgezahlt worden ist.
Das sowieso, aber auch sie können mit dieser Summe, also nach der halt geprüft wird, ob ausgezahlt wird oder nicht, die ist sozusagen auch schon Teil von dem Bitcoin. Sie nutzen einfach das, was Bitcoin sowieso macht, nämlich kryptografisch sichere Sachen. Und da kannst du dann direkt selber prüfen, ob das Ergebnis so war oder nicht.
Also es ist ein komplett transparentes Verfahren.
Eigentlich schon, ja.
Sie halten sich trotzdem teil ein.
Ja, irgendwie so.
Aber es ist ja beim Roulette auch so. Da sieht man ja auch so, ob man gewonnen hat oder verloren.
Ja, aber es gibt halt ganz viel, wo du es halt nicht mehr siehst. Also, ja, keine Ahnung. Wo gibt es noch Lotterie, wo man nicht mehr gucken kann? Die ganze Online-Lotterie.
Wahlen? Ich weiß nie.
Zum Beispiel.
So, was haben wir noch bei Bitcoin? Dann gibt es irgendwie Bitcoin News. Und zwar gibt es ja diese Bitcoin Exchanges, wie Mt. Gox. Das sind so die größten. Also, ich glaube, 90 Prozent aller Transfers, oder 90 waren es nicht, aber ich glaube, die Hälfte aller Bitcoin-Transfers läuft über Mt. Gox. Die schieben, kannst du ja mal bei Bitcoin charts, da hat es ja gerade offen, steht die Zahl da, wie viel die täglich immer rüberschieben. Ich glaube, das hat noch alles schon mal. Was steht hier? Schnell mal gucken. Knappe Millionen in 30 Tagen, aber ich weiß jetzt nicht, ob sie Dollar oder Bitcoin sind.
Saudi-Day-Volume in Bitcoin sind 97.000.
Ja, wenn es aber Bitcoins sind, dann sind es natürlich...
Es sind 10 Millionen US-Dollar in 30 Tagen.
936.000 Euro.
Ist schon nicht so wenig.
Dann sind es aber keine 10 Millionen US-Dollar.
Also, eine Million.
Um einen Faktor kann es halt falsch, nämlich der Preis des Bitcoins ist halt 10. Das ist nur 1 Dollar. Deswegen kann es ja nur maximal 10 Mal größer oder kleiner sein. Wie auch immer ihr jetzt das auszeichnet.
Bei Bitcoin-Charts steht bei MT-Gox, bei 30 Tagen steht Volumen 10 Millionen US-Dollar.
Na gut, alles klar.
Also bei UST, ich gucke jetzt gerade bei Euro.
Und 867.000 Bitcoins.
Euro ist natürlich immer nicht so doll. Jedenfalls, das ist halt so ein Exchange. Das sind halt einfach irgendwelche Typen, die das halt machen und die haben halt kein Backing. Das heißt, wenn die eines Tages weg sind, dann kannst du halt versuchen, die noch zu verklagen oder wie auch immer, aber man hat nicht so wirklich Rechte und die sind auch nicht abgesichert und nix und so weiter und so fort. So und jetzt gibt's, jetzt hab ich die Seite.
Aber man hinterlegt ja da auch keine Bitcoins, oder? Die agieren ja nicht als Bank, sondern...
Doch, doch, doch.
Also ich hab da noch Restgelder liegen, weil du immer nicht die ganze perfekten Summen so machst und ich hab da irgendwie noch 3-4 Bitcoins liegen und auch so irgendwie 3-4 Dollar oder so, weil ich die nicht gerade abheben konnte. Und das liegt halt bei denen schon rum. Also ich hab da einmal hin überwiesen, als ich Bitcoins haben wollte, so einen Testkauf mal, und dann hab ich auch mal Bitcoins hingeschoben, weil ich wieder Euros haben wollte, und davon liegen halt jetzt auch noch ein paar rum. Das heißt von meinen beiden Währungen liegen da noch so Krümelbeträge rum.
Wie haben dich diese Euros erreicht?
Erreichen tun die mich, indem ich sage, ich will das auf mein Postbankkonto haben und die kommen von einer polnischen Bank und die zieht aber schweinereimäßig noch mal ein Prozent ab.
Ein Prozent?
Ja, warum auch immer. Kenne ich auch keine Bank, die das so macht, aber ich würde ja verstehen, wenn die bei Mount Gox mir ein Prozent sagen, das kostet jetzt, und bei denen kostet das glaube ich auch minimal ein paar Prozente. Aber warum die Bank dann selbst auch noch mal was abzieht, wenn ich bei Mount Gox sage, ich will 100 Euro haben, kommen nur 99 bei mir an. Finde ich ein bisschen blöd, aber vielleicht ändert sich das ja auch noch in der Zukunft. Die können ja ihren Anbieter da wechseln. Jedenfalls jetzt wird es interessant.
Das heißt, Mount Gox, das finde ich gerade interessant, Mount Gox selber nimmt überhaupt nicht am SWIFT-System teil, sondern hat sozusagen andere Banken, mit denen sie zusammen arbeiten.
Mount Gox ist halt keine Bank. Die brauchen halt irgendwie wen, der das halt am Ende für die macht.
Na ja, sie könnten auch Money Agents sein.
Ja, da weiß ich nicht genau, wie da die Bestimmung, wie das alles so läuft.
Also sowas wie Western Union und so weiter, das ist auch nicht unbedingt.
Weiß ich nicht. Jedenfalls gibt es einen anderen Bitcoin Exchange, da heißt Bitcoin Central. Und ich weiß jetzt nicht aus welchem Land der kommt, aber eventuell ist es Frankreich, weil die haben es jetzt geschafft, in Frankreich als Bank sozusagen angenommen zu werden. Die haben dort irgendwie lauter Prüfungen über sich gehen, wie sagt man das?
Über sich ergehen lassen.
Über sich ergehen lassen, die man halt erfüllen muss und so weiter. Und haben jetzt den Status einer Bank anerkannt bekommen. Das heißt, dass wenn du dort dein Geld hinterlegst, dann ist es einigermaßen abgesichert, so wie halt die europäischen Bankengesetze das vorschreiben. Also du musst halt als Bank ja, keine Ahnung, wenn deine Kunden eine Million bei dir ablegen, musst du doch irgendwie lächerlich wenige Prozent zur Seite legen. Ich glaube, das waren wirklich nur 5% oder sowas. Ich weiß auch nicht, wie die damit das irgendwie so decken wollen. Aber bei den riesen Banken scheint das halt was auszumachen. Wirklichen die alle ihr Geld abheben gleichzeitig. Aber wahrscheinlich um so kleine Stürmchen auszuhalten. Und das müssen die jetzt halt auch so machen. Aber es gilt halt nur für die Euros, die du bei denen zu liegen hast und nicht für die Bitcoins natürlich, weil das Bitcoin ja nicht so richtig als Geld zählt, sondern nur als wahrscheinlich für die einfach als Produkt wie Schmuck oder irgendeiner anderen Scheiß. Und was es dann halt eines Tages gehen könnte, ist, dass du von der Bude, also Bitcoin, wie heißt die jetzt? Bitcoin Central, eine Kreditkarte bekommst, die du dann mit Bitcoins auffüllen könntest. Zum Beispiel. Weil es ja gar nicht so verkehrt wäre. Das sind die News von der Bitcoin-Exchange-Seite.
Hast du mitbekommen, dass man bei wordpress.org oder com jetzt auch mit Bitcoins zahlen kann?
Kannst du ja so einen Block mit Bitcoin kaufen.
Ja, also es gibt immer mehr Läden, wo die halt irgendwie, also weiß nicht, vor einem Jahr war es halt noch, oder weißt du ja hier...
Ja, aber das basiert sozusagen auf unmittelbarer Euro-Umrechnung oder...
Ja, die rechnen das halt so Tageskurs um. Umso mehr Läden das machen, umso stabiler wird auch der Kurs, glaube ich.
Oder?
Also ich meine, da eiert ja noch hin und her, weil...
Aber auch als Auszahlungsfront wäre es ja ganz interessant. Also es gab so ein bisschen die Diskussion da auf Twitter und auf Mailinglisten, ob man zum Beispiel das Problem, was Flatter hat, dass sie quasi um mir jetzt Geld oder wem auch immer Geld auszuzahlen, müssen die ja dann durch PayPal gehen derzeit oder durch Moneybookers, was letztlich das Gleiche ist. Wobei die sich dann halt zwei Prozent rippen.
Das machen die bei Mt. Gox ja auch. Das ist nur noch dieses zusätzliche Prozent, was von der Bank abgezogen wird.
Das heißt, die landen auch bei zwei Prozent?
Ja, ich glaube schon. Also beim Auszahlen bei Mt. Gox, immer wenn man auszahlt, muss man Prozente zahlen. Ich glaube, es waren zwei, ich bin mir nicht so sicher. Und ansonsten, wenn man Transaktionen macht, von Euro nach Bitcoin oder Bitcoin nach Euro, da muss man sich ja noch nicht auszahlen. Man könnte ja die ganze Zeit daytraden bei denen und immer von einer Währung zu anderen wachsen. Da muss man irgendwie 0,6 Prozent bezahlen. Ja, aber da hast du ja noch nichts ausgezahlt. Das bleibt ja immer noch bei denen. Ab 1000 Euro geht es auf 0,5 runter sogar.
Also wenn wir jetzt einen Bitcoin-Betrag in Euro umrechnen lassen wollen würde zum aktuellen Tageskurs, dann würde von dem errechneten Wert wie viel Prozent nochmal weggehen?
Erstmal 0,6.
Aber? Nee, ich meine, wer es jetzt in Euro auch haben will auf meinem Konto?
Da müsste ich jetzt nachgucken, aber ich glaube, es waren zwei Prozent.
Drei Prozent, okay. Das heißt, es ist letztlich genau das gleiche wie PayPal.
Außer irgendwann über Bitcoin Central kriegst du dann vielleicht noch günstigere Konditionen, weil die halt selber die Bank sind. Und dann nicht nochmal einen Drittanbieter dafür missbrauchen müssen.
Ja, und wie zuverlässig die sind, auf ganz lange Sicht kann man natürlich auch bei Mt. Gox nichts sagen. Also Paper ist ja auch erstmal funktioniert ja alles, solange halt nicht von irgendwo politischer Druck oder was auch immer kommt. Und erst dann machen sie dir ja irgendwie Stress. Und da weiß man bei Mt. Gox auch noch nicht, was passiert. Da kann auch jemand kommen und von heute auf morgen den Laden dicht machen und dann ist die Kohle weg wahrscheinlich. Also da ist es wahrscheinlich mit dieser Bank, wenn das so stimmt, dass die da wirklich voll die Auflagen haben, zumindest schon mal ein Stück besser. Und auch Leute, die halt sonst immer nicht wussten, naja, wo kann ich denn meine Bitcoins in Euro tauschen und andersrum, wenn da das Bankhörsel noch bei denen hintersteht. Ich meine nicht, dass jetzt alle doll den großen Banken vertrauen. Ja, irgendwie haben die ja doch gelitten in den letzten Jahren. Aber aus Bitcoin-Sicht ist es schon erstmal noch ein Gewinn. Also da passiert was. So, dann nächste Bitcoin News. Ich habe ja mal erzählt, dass ich hier so ein FPGA-Board habe. Und die Firma, die das macht, ist so eine deutsche Bude, die auch schon vorher FPGA-Boards gemacht hat. Die hat halt so eine eigene Bitcoin-Software, die ist in Java geschrieben. Und das ist halt nicht so wirklich cool. Vor allem auf Fribi ist die nicht, weil da ist das Java halt nicht so cool. Und dann bin ich gerade dabei und eigentlich jetzt schon ein bisschen abgeschlossen, dass ich Support für diese Z-Tex-Boards für CG-Miner geschrieben habe. Das ist so das Standard-Bitcoin-Mining-Tool. Und das kann jetzt auch mit diesen Z-Tex-Boards umgehen. Ich konnte das vorher auch schon, aber jetzt kann es halt noch ein Stück besser damit umgehen. Ich habe da eine Menge gemacht. Und wenn Leute jetzt so ein Z-Tex-Board haben, dann sollen sie sich dieses neueste CG-Miner mal angucken, Version 2.10.0. Das kann jetzt irgendwie die Firmen, den Bitstream schneller reinschieben, kann auch jetzt selber die Firmware reinschieben. Man muss nicht mehr irgendwie die Java-Software dafür benutzen. Und das alles auch, wenn man die Dummy-Firmware benutzt und so weiter. Also es ist jetzt ein bisschen speziell für Z-Tex-Leute, aber die wissen es dann schon. Und die CG-Miner-Software hat auf jeden Fall mehr Features und ist besser und schneller als diese Java-Software und verbraucht auch weniger CPU-Power. Also wer zum Beispiel einen Raspberry Pi benutzt für Bitcoin-Mining, was viele machen, weil man will ja möglichst auch Strom sparen, dann ist diese CG-Miner echt cool, weil es braucht irgendwie gar keine CPU-Resourcen, weil es schon sehr schonend programmiert wurde. Und die können sich das mal angucken. Und ansonsten, wer da Fragen hat, und ich kann auch immer Betatester gebrauchen, bin ich auf irg im BTCMP-Channel, so wie mein Pool heißt. Und wenn die da irgendwelche exotischen Z-Tex-Boards haben, weil ich hab nur das Y-Board, dann kann ich mit denen das mal testen. Oder auch Leute sind interessant, die halt Rechner mit Big Engine haben, weil ich hab nur Little Engine, und dann könnte man da auch mal Sachen testen. Also gibt es irgendwelche Router, die unter MIPS laufen, und die Leute, die da Linux drauf haben, und dann könnte man CG Mine mal da drauf testen. Also wisst ihr Bescheid.
Dein Netz löchert immer noch, ne?
Ich hab keine Ahnung.
Kann man dieses UMTS-Stick-Ding?
Wolltest du uns nicht irgendwie einen fetten Tunnel machen?
Ja, ich hab ja hier kein LTE in der Prenzlerberghöhle hier.
Ein Ghetto.
Das muss mal irgendwie... Also mir ist das irgendwie unklar, ob das jetzt hier ein DNS-Problem ist, aber das würde ja nicht erklären, warum Streams abreißen.
Das ist wirklich... Ich kann es mir nicht erklären. Also auch so Webseiten hängen auch so beim Laden. Der Ping läuft ja die ganze Zeit durch.
Ja, das hört sich ein bisschen nach Routing-Problemen an, oder?
Na, oder... Mal den Clemens drauf loslassen.
Ja, ist schwierig zu sagen gerade. Ich kann es auch gerade nicht ändern. Das ist alles elend. Aber da sind wir bei den guten Vorsätzen. Nächstes Jahr wird alles besser. Und das ist definitiv eine der Dinge, die ich mir mal genauer anschauen werde. Auch die Sache mit dem Streaming als solchen. Ich habe ja sowieso noch so einiges vor. Und im Sinn. Hier so für Internetradio des 21. Jahrhunderts. Hot Love Plug-in nähert sich auch rasant der Beta, den Beta-Zustand. Das wird auch noch ganz cool.
Plug-in für was?
Für WordPress.
Weil es nichts anderes gibt, was verwendet wird. Also ich hab mal rumgefragt, so auf Twitter, welche Podcasts, womit die denn überhaupt ihre Podcasts veröffentlichen, wenn sie nicht WordPress nehmen. Also es war wenig. Also es gab kein einziges anderes System, was irgendwie einen zweiten Platz eingenommen hätte. Also nach dem Motto, wenn man nicht WordPress nimmt, nimmt man das? Nein. Sondern es war alles so, ja, ich hab so meine eigenen Skripte und da gibt's da irgendwie so ein obskures Plugin für Drupal und nichts wurde zweimal genannt und es war einfach alles irgendwie merkwürdig. Oder halt Hoster. Aber auch die Hoster sind irgendwie sehr unverbreitet, hab ich so den Eindruck.
Wie so Hoster, die das komplett für einen macht. Ach, gibt's das? Die Hosten dann nicht nur die einzelnen Datei, sondern die bieten einem auch eine Lösung an, mit dem man das so macht.
Genau, die haben da irgendwie so ein UI und da kannst du dann die Dateien hochladen und dann erzeugen sie einen Feed für dich und so.
Da gibt's halt in den USA, gibt's hier Libsyn, schon längere Zeit, die aber auch nur MP3 unterstützen und.
Achso, da kann man nicht einfach beliebige Dateien hoch?
Nein, das sind dann halt so Podcast-Hoster oder sagen, vielleicht ist das nicht der richtige Bezeichner, das sind weniger Podcast-Hoster, sondern mehr so Podcast-Publishing-Systeme, webbasierte Publishing-Systeme, die dir einfach eine bestimmte Art von Podcast ermöglichen, wo du aber jetzt nicht kreativ werden kannst oder irgendwie alles abdecken kannst, was du willst. Interessanterweise, auch Phonic hat jetzt gerade vorgestern Libsyn-Support eingebaut. Also wenn man sowieso schon da postet, dann kann man dann sozusagen auch direkt da die Dateien hin übertragen. Aber für mich ist das nichts. Und mit Wordpress bist du halt am nächsten dran, dass du sagen kannst, hier, ich will jetzt hier einfach mal modernen Podcasting machen. Also allein schon, dass du mal alle Formate unterstützt. Mit auf Phonic ist halt diese ganze Konverziererei jetzt einfach. Und deswegen, ich stelle halt gerade alles um und ich produziere ab jetzt halt alles in vier Formaten. Mindestens. Kommt halt alles in MP3, in Vorbis, Opus und MP4 raus. Was den Vorteil hat, dass du eben den Webplayer so beschicken kannst, dass du wirklich jetzt alle Fälle abdecken kannst. Also es ist mir jetzt egal, von welcher religiösen Zuschneidung dein Browser ist, du kriegst halt irgendwas, ist halt alles da.
Kostet ja nichts mehr.
Genau, kostet ja nichts mehr, kostet nur noch Platte. Und wenn man halt noch weitergehen will, was ich auch noch vorhabe, ist dann eben so, dass man eben alles auch noch in groß und in kleinen Varianten hat. Dass man sagt, hier dicke Datei, hier dünne Datei. Na gut, mit Streaming hat das jetzt erst mal gar nichts zu tun.
Wir können das ja nochmal hinlegen halt und dann...
Achso, du meinst, dass auf Phonik das gleich so zerdingst? Ja, den Feature Request habe ich da auch schon mal gestellt, aber der hat noch nicht ganz so...
So quasi einmal durch den Segment durchlässt.
Ja, das wäre in der Tat cool, weil man dann eben einfach besser zu iOS-Devices streamen könnte, aber das ist halt auch derzeit die ganze Anwendung.
Ja, wobei das mit MPEG-4 auch wirklich gut geht.
Ja, es ist eben good enough und von daher sehe ich das noch nicht so ganz genau. Aber mal schauen, wie es da so weitergeht. Ich habe da eine Menge Ideen.
IPv6 gibt es noch so einen kleinen Anmerkungpunkt, den ich vorhin noch vergessen habe. Da gab es heute auf Nekker News wieder mal so eine Meldung, wo so ein paar deutsche Hacker schon seit langer Zeit, also nicht nur die, so eine Attacke herausgefunden haben, wie man derzeit alle BSDs, alle MacOSen, alle Windows freezen oder zum Neustarten bringen kann, indem man so IPv6-Router-Advertisements ins Netz reinpustet und dann auch iOS-Geräte, also alle Arten, Geräte, die nicht Linux sind, bleiben dann stehen und hängen. Da gibt es auch so eine URL zu, wo man sich da mal hinreichend zu belesen kann und auch ein bisschen selber ausprobieren kann. Die haben es auch schon allen Apple gesagt und so weiter. Hier gibt es diese von The Hacker Choice, heißen die? THC, das war noch die. Genau. Da gibt es so ein Toolkit und auch eine Anleitung und ReadMe, was das alles damit auf sich hat. Vielleicht wärst du auch gerade so attackiert. Und damit der Handle with Care, ähnlich wie mit dem Glücksspiel, das ist jetzt hier nicht so zum eure Kollegen-Stenkern, sondern ihr könnt damit zumindest überprüfen, ob jetzt bestimmte Betriebssysteme vielleicht dagegen schon gewappnet sind oder nicht. Aber das ist zum Beispiel jetzt gerade so in der Security-Szene ist das wohl gerade auch so ein Thema, jetzt wo IPv6 halt viel mehr deployed wird. Gucken sich das auch viel mehr Leute jetzt genauer an und da gibt es halt schon noch so einige Lücken in den Stacks, in den Implementationen, die halt da so einige Probleme noch offenbaren. Und ja, es ist jetzt schon ein bisschen traurig, dann zu hören, dass eigentlich gerade nur Linux, der da nicht scheinbar verwundbar ist, sondern alle BSDs, Windows und so weiter. Ja, also da könnt ihr euch mal dazu belesen.
Talking about Security. Könnt ihr ja vielleicht hier nochmal... Vielleicht geht nicht auf den Kongress?
Ich, ich, ich...
Das ist in Hamburg.
Seitdem ich beim TTT bin, war ich jetzt bei jedem Kongress.
In Berlin.
In Berlin halt. So und jetzt so nach 11, 12 Jahren dachte ich mir so, ach jetzt mal so... Also jetzt werden die mal in einer anderen Stadt sind, ist doch eigentlich mal die Gelegenheit, einfach mal zu Hause zu bleiben und mal nichts zu tun. Und sich das entspannt im Stream anzugucken. Wo man nicht lokal da sowieso da ist für den Aufbau und so weiter und so fort. Irgendwie hab ich grad mal... So mal einmal Pause in 12 Jahren, ist ja wohl mal drin.
Ist ja feigheit vor dem Feind.
Wieso Feind?
Ich hieß es doch abgehauen. Ja ich kann mir das nicht leisten.
Wie Bitcoin-Millionär Dennis Ahrens?
Nee, nichts mit mir mehr. Nee, ich müsste da irgendwie unterkommen, irgendwie ordentlich. Und wenn man dann auf den Kongress irgendwie Schichten schiebt, dann will ich nicht irgendwie mit zehn Leuten in einem Zimmer schlafen. Das geht nicht. So, dann muss man auch anfahren. Und das kostet alles Geld.
Ja, das ist auf jeden Fall Teil der... Sagen wir mal, also ich hab auch irgendwie grad keinen Bock, mich so darum zu kümmern, dass ich da dann für eine Woche in ein Hotelzimmer oder irgendwo hin und her fahren, zurückfahren.
Weil ich war letztes Jahr so ein bisschen... Also, wenn er in Berlin gewesen wäre, wäre ich dieses Jahr bestimmt hingegangen, aber auch so Organisationsfubar. Und ich war letztes Jahr so ein bisschen unzufrieden. Also ich fand ihn so nicht so ganz töfte. Und hab dann gedacht, ach, jetzt drei Tage in Hamburg oder schön zu Hause auf der Couch liegen. Dann klang die Couch irgendwie verlockender.
Okay. Ich werde hinfahren, ja. Ich bin fest gebucht. Also ich hab jetzt keine Tätigkeiten dort, organisatorischer Art. Außer, dass ich einen kleinen Workshop mach. Zur Podcasting halt. Und ansonsten schau ich mir das mit großem Interesse an. Wobei ich so das Programm jetzt so ein bisschen, was auf mich zurollte. Ich weiß nicht, vielleicht habe ich es mir nicht gut genug durchgelesen, aber das ist auch so ein Trend der letzten Jahre, der mich so ein bisschen stört vielleicht sogar schon. Das gefühlt sich sehr in Richtung Hacker Security Only entwickelt. Habt ihr auch diesen Eindruck?
Art and Beauty findet ja auf jeden Fall schon mal seit einigen Jahren nicht mehr statt. Also das mal irgendwie, kann mich noch an ein Kongress erinnern, wo Jussi mit der, wie heißt sie doch gleich, von We Make Money Not Art und so weiter so ein Talk. Habt man jetzt mal länger glaube ich nicht mehr gesehen.
Jaja, die Ebene zieht sich zurück. Das ist schade eigentlich. Aber ich bin trotzdem erstmal gespannt, was das Gebäude so an Dynamik entfesseln kann. Und ich meine, so wie jetzt vielleicht manche Leute in Berlin so ein bisschen den Schwanz anziehen, vorverkauf ist jetzt eh vorbei, ne? eine Menge Leute geben. Vorverkauf ist vorbei, aber ich meine, ich mach mal ehrlich gesagt, werde ich sorgen, dass da einen vor Ort Verkauf geben wird. Also ich meine, da ist Platz. Also wenn die Veranstaltung ein Platzproblem hat, dann hat sie kein Problem mehr.
Ja, ich glaube ab einer gewissen Menge Gäste sind die Auflagen komplett andere. Und das wäre wohl schon noch ein Problem, weil dann wird es richtig teuer. Also auch wieder so Sicherheitsauflagen halt, wegen Panik, Terrorismus, Feuer, Wattung.
Ach ja, was da alles so passieren kann, so viel Internetbandbreite.
Und ab einer gewissen Größe hast du das halt.
Aber das heißt jetzt nicht, dass ab einer bestimmten Größe dein Eintrittsstopp ist? Kann ich mir nicht vorstellen.
Glaub ich auch nicht. Werden schon irgendwie Regeln.
Na gut, also wer auf jeden Fall auf dem Kongress ist und bezogste Podcasting hat, ich mach am dritten, zweiten Tag glaube ich, weiß jetzt gerade gar nicht, kleinen Workshop so um diese ganze Potluff-Geschichte. Und da kann kommen, wer will. So.
Alle 29.000 Gäste.
Wollen wir denn nochmal über Apple reden? Oder ist das irgendwie...
Voll aus der Mole gekommen eigentlich.
Sag mal, hier das iOS ist mir aufgefallen, da gab es ja dieses 601, ne? Und vorher haben alle rumgeheult, was haben sie geheult? Zu viel Strom verbrauchen, das hätte ja schon so ein bisschen geholfen, das Update, aber noch nicht so richtig und blau überhaupt. Aber inzwischen schreit irgendwie gar keiner mehr nach irgendeinem Update, oder? Also ich meine, läuft alles oder gibt es keine Probleme mehr?
Oder...
Ich dachte schon, dass sie irgendwann noch so ein richtiges 6.1 hinterherschieben.
Maps und iCloud.
Na 6.1, das ist ja ein Appdater.
Ach so, ist.
Und das Maps besser? Ja, das ist ja doch.
Updates kommen, daran hab ich gar keinen Zweifel.
Ja, aber es dauert so lange, finde ich, diesmal.
Da ist, ich meine, kann man ja auch alles im Netz nachlesen, das ist ja nun kein Geheimnis, da ist nicht viel Neues. Also ein API-Call, das erschreckt, also quasi gar nichts da. Es sind drei neue Calls oder irgendwie sowas. Keine Ahnung, was sie dann sonst noch so getrieben haben. Vielleicht ja das Apple-TV-Update. Darüber haben wir jetzt gar nicht geredet, oder? Dass da irgend so ein Typ auf seinem Apple-TV plötzlich Apps gesehen hat im Store.
Ich hab das nur so am Rande mitbekommen. Was hat er denn da genau gesehen?
Mist, jetzt haben wir alle genauso viel. Wieso muss ich das Thema auch ansprechen? Wir hatten so ein Bildschirmfoto davon gemacht. Mal sehen, ob ich das jetzt hier app-verweise auf Apple-TV... Oder ist es... Es sieht so aus, als ob er hier ein Foto von dem Interface des Apple-TVs gemacht hätte. Auf dem Gerät. Und da ist dann oben so ein Banner quasi. Und da steht unten drunter Apps & Games. Zum Thema Snow Sports.
Also auf seiner Apple-TV.
Auf seinem Apple. Genau. Jetzt kann es natürlich sein, dass die dieses Banner versehentlich statt aufs iPhone oder aufs iPad auf dem Apple-TV ausgespielt haben. Keine Ahnung. Auf jeden Fall. Ist ja irgendwie klar, dass da langsam mal was kommen muss. Und jetzt nachdem hier Tim Cook ja im Interview ja nun mehr, also deutlich darauf hingewiesen hat, dass da irgendwas passieren wird. Ich auch so ein Ohrsaft bitte. Langsam wird's Zeit, ne?
Ich frage mich halt, okay, ich meine, er hat jetzt da diesen Hint gebracht mit irgendwie, wenn ich den Fernseher einschalte, dann sieht das aus wie vor 20 Jahren.
Und das muss ich erinnern?
Hat er das gesagt?
Ich glaube, er hat irgendwie gesagt, dass der Apple TV für sie auch vom größten Interesse sei und ich meine, das ist so ein Upgrade von Hobby und dann hat er halt gesagt, so dieses Jahr, das sieht ja immer noch so aus wie vor 20 Jahren, dieses Fernsehen.
War er auch recht?
Definitiv.
Mir ist immer noch nicht so ganz klar, was so ihre eigentliche Strategie ist und es gibt ja jetzt auch Gerüchte, dass hier irgendwelche Fernseher-Prototypen durchbauen. Ich weiß nicht so recht, was ich davon halten soll. Irgendwie...
Ja, das haben wir ja auch schon ein paar Mal durchgekaut. Sie brauchen halt live Übertragung, halt trotzdem irgendwie Sport, News, was auch immer.
Aber amerikanischen Sport haben sie mittlerweile erstaunlich viel.
Ja, aber ich sag ja nur so als Zusammenfassung. Sie brauchen halt irgendwie super viel Content. Also da reicht es halt nicht, irgendwie zwei coole Serien zu haben, sondern sie brauchen eigentlich alle coolen Serien, die gerade heiß sind. Weil sonst ist das auch schon wieder zu uncool.
Das muss auch besser funktionieren. Ich hab neulich... Also meine Freundin wollte was gucken, zusammen mit einer Freundin. Und ich saß nur so daneben und hab einen Rechner gestartet. Und wir haben dann probiert, auf dem Apple TV sich was auszuleihen. Und es war furchtbar. Irgendein Trailer angeguckt, der kam dann ohne Sound. Da hat da irgendjemand vergessen, die Tonspur einzuspielen, offensichtlich. Und dann hat's ewig gebuffert. Obwohl, ich meine, wir haben VDSL da und alles schön schnell und so. Und es hat gebraucht, bis es geladen ist.
Das ist so ein humanoides Beistellgerät.
So, dann kriegt man nicht raus, ob die Sachen auf Englisch oder auf Deutsch sind. Oder ob das verfügbar ist. Und dann hatten sie sich irgendwas ausgesucht. Dann bin ich zu Pirate Bay gegangen, hab gesagt, in einer Viertelstunde hab das. Und dann haben sie sich halt so angeguckt. Das ging im Endeffekt.
Jedesmal.
Das ist wirklich das Schlimme, dass es immer noch besser funktioniert.
Ich mach es halt mittlerweile so, wenn es das überhaupt im iTunes Store gibt, dann klick ich auf LINE, gleich Pause, lösche es danach. Dann hab ich einmal meine 2 Euro oder 3 Euro dafür bezahlt. Und lad's dann halt über Pirate Bay und hab dann halt Subtitles und Tonspuren und Qualität, die ich haben will.
Und zwar die...
Es ist ja nicht so, dass ich nicht dafür bezahle. Ich bin ja schon irgendwie eigentlich so... Ich hätte das ja gerne so, dass es direkt in iTunes funktioniert usw.
Dann kannst du es dir so ein bisschen vorstellen, wenn du es so machst.
Aber wenn ich dann halt mal so einen Scheißbrief oder was auch immer kriege, dann sag ich halt, hier hab ich bezahlt, ich hab's nur woanders geguckt.
Ich glaub, das interessiert sie eben so einen Scheißdrück. Es ist ja gut fürs Karma.
Und das Karma ist wichtig.
Und die Subtitles, da gibt es echt im Internet, wenn du irgendeinen Film runterlädst, gehst du auf so eine andere Seite und dann kriegst du Subtitles wirklich in allen Sprachen, die es für diesen Film bestimmt niemals gegeben hätte. Und da gibt es halt Freaks, die das alles eintippen und da können die einfach auch nicht mithalten.
Ja, bei iTunes gibt es halt keine Subtitles und das ist auch so ein, also ich weiß nicht, von welchem Planeten sie kommen, auf die Idee kommt, dass Subtitles irgendwie unnötig werden.
Ja, ich mein, was kann so schwierig daran sein, einfach jeden Film in Englisch mit englischen Subtitles anzuliehen?
Kann ich dir sagen, ich glaube, weil die ja für einen deutschen Film nicht einfach dann nur eine deutsche Tonspur machen, sondern der ist glaube ich auch teilweise wirklich anders geschnitten. Ich will keinen deutschen Film. Und weil er anders geschnitten ist, können sie die englische Tonspur nicht so drin lassen.
Naja, aber sie könnten doch, sie haben doch den Film sowieso in der englischen Original-Fassung schon rumliegen bei Apple, sie müssen dir doch bloß die Datei ausspielen.
Du sagst ja, der deutsche ist eventuell anders geschnitten.
Ja, aber dann hast du halt den englischen Original-Variante ein bisschen anders geschnitten.
Dann sind die Rechte wieder anders.
Ja, drauf geschissen woran das liegt.
Sollen sie klären.
Wenn es den Film in englischer Fasse gibt, dann gib mir doch immer Subtitles.
Also ich meine, es funktioniert bei jeder DVD und bei jeder Blu-ray, dass der in hunderten Sprachvarianten auf einem Medium drauf ist, mit verschiedenen Totspuren.
Da hast du Subtitles auf YouTube mittlerweile.
Dass man das auch nicht mal als Preset angeben kann. Also ich meine, mich interessiert überhaupt nichts.
Genau, zeig mir nur Filme an, die auf englisch verfügbar sind. Fertig.
Und da ist halt auch wieder die Subtitles haben. Aber dieses Store-Interface ist halt auch an sich schon so nervtötend, also dann klickst du halt so, okay, nur Filme in Originalsprache. Okay, dann hast du dieses Genres, okay, kann ich das jetzt einfach expanden? Nein, ich muss in die Kategorie komplett rein und scroll ich da alles wieder durch, dann gehe ich zurück, wo war ich denn jetzt gerade, dann wieder scroll, scrollen muss, ich krieg da jedes Mal aufs Plug.
Das bleibe ich, jede Videothek hat da ein besseres User-Interface. Und die ist schon nicht gut.
Meine Videothek, die hat auch ein anderes Interface und zwar ist es blond und voll nett.
Und heißt Robert. Ja, das ist halt, also, ich hab's auch schon, man wiederholt sich auch nur. Sie könnten das so toll machen, sie könnten so Geld einnehmen, also ich meine, das liegt ja auch nicht nur an Apple, aber...
Ich glaube, diese ganzen Leute, die diese Filme zusammenschneiden müssen, das muss auch ein furchtbar, wahrscheinlich nie bezahlter Job sein von Leuten, die dabei in der Nase popeln und es überprüft auch keiner, ob es funktioniert und so was. Wer hat sich darüber mal so aufgeregt? Leo vom FSC K-Log, glaube ich, war das. Falls nicht, dann war es vermutlich jemand anders, der meinte so, dass bei Serien ist das ja besonders schlimm. Da kaufst dir irgendwie so einen Season Pass, um irgendwas gucken zu dürfen, dann kriegst du die ersten drei Folgen und danach werden irgendwie noch mal zwei Folgen in SD hochgeladen, so ja, ja, ja, hier mit deinem HD-Season Pass kannst du jetzt noch mal so zwei SD folgen und danach wird es irgendwie komplett vergessen. Und dann hast du vorher irgendwie im Vorfeld schon viel Geld dafür ausgegeben, um diese Serie immer aktuell gucken zu dürfen. Und dann wirst du wirklich so auf nicht mal halber Strecke gnadenlos hängengelassen und du kriegst es einfach nicht mehr.
Ja, vor allen Dingen so aktuell ist es ja dann auch nicht, dass Thorin das halt auch immer schneller. Ja, ne, also Apple TV, die brauchen wir gar nicht, damit erst ankommen, wenn sie halt so auf Content-Seite da nicht nochmal einen richtig großen Schritt vorwärts machen. Vorher gucke ich da gar nichts an, was Apple TV heißt.
Aber warum ist das so schmerzhaft? Wird damit so wenig Geld gemacht, dass sich das nicht lohnt?
Das kann ich mir gar nicht vorstellen.
Ich meine, es sollte doch mal da pro Film irgendwie ein Hunderter in die Hand nehmen, um den vernünftig aufzuarbeiten. Das hat man ja echt schon viel gemacht.
Aber ich hab's ja auch schon mal erzählt. Ich wollte mal Alien gucken.
Naja, ich meine, was kann das kosten?
Ich glaub, der würde sich ganz schön aufregen.
Der, der teilnehmen muss oder hochspielen muss?
Wollte ich Alien gucken? Die Definition eines ganzen Filmgenres quasi. Und das gibt's halt nicht. Oder Harry Potter. Ich wollte mal Harry Potter gucken, gab's nicht in Englisch oder nicht den Teil. Dann gab's nur die ersten zwei Teile, nur den ersten und den vierten. So eine Sachen gibt's da halt, wo du denkst, echt...
Die das mit den Rechten klären, würde mich am interessieren.
Kann ich Pirate Bay so was machen wie iTunes Match so? Also du lädst dir das torrent runter und... Pirate Match und dann bezahlst du halt irgendwie 3,99 an den jeweiligen Rechteinhabern, aber du kriegst das halt einfach aus dem Torren und wo es herkommt ist eigentlich egal, weil du kannst es ja eins zu eins zuordnen, so und dann ist alles gut, so. Können wir es nicht einfach so machen, so Pirate Match, so?
Das frag ich mich ja sowieso so ein bisschen, warum die mich anfangen. Ich hab ja das Gefühl, dass so bei The Daily Show, die ich ganz gerne gucke, da wird ja mittlerweile auch schon der Vorspann gesponsert von irgendwen, ob die das machen, um auch diese Sachen so ein bisschen zu monetarisieren. Eigentlich müsste es doch, wenn es einen offiziellen Stream gäbe, wo sozusagen der rechte Inhaber noch ein bisschen was dran verdient und dann ist die Qualität relativ hoch und dann kannst du es dir per BitTorrent runterladen, dann kommen da vielleicht mal drei Werbespots rein. Würde ich ja nicht nein sagen. Warum noch niemand probiert, diesen Weg da einfach ein bisschen Kohle rauszuholen?
Ja, die sind einfach noch immer da in der Vergangenheit und auch dieser große Musikindustrie-Umbruch, der ist ja auch immer noch im vollen Gang. Wenn du dir jetzt eine neue Band gründen wollen würdest, hast du immer noch die gleichen Probleme, wie du vor ein paar Jahren schon gehabt hast, dass das irgendwie in dieser ganzen Ecke noch echt zu wenig passiert. Also da ist das 21. Jahrhundert noch voll in Deckung sozusagen. Und ich weiß auch echt nicht mehr, also so langsam habe ich ja den Glauben daran verloren, dass das in naher Zukunft sich mal auflöst in ein Happy Hippo Rainbow Wonderland.
Ich glaube, das wird jetzt als nächstes bei 3D-Druck. Ich habe heute so einen Artikel darüber überflogen. Und zwar gibt es da so ein Soundboard. Ich weiß jetzt nicht, wie das heißt. Das sieht sehr schick aus, kostet ein Schweine Geld. So ein weißes Ding mit sehr bunten Knöpfen oben drauf. Super schickes Teil. Und die animieren wohl User dazu, eigene Knöpfe dafür 3D auszudrucken. Also dass die auch so ein bisschen Hilfestellung dir leisten, wie du die Knöpfe selber ausdrucken kannst. Und wenn du irgendwas Alternatives brauchst, dass du das selber machen kannst, das wird noch ein ganz großes Ding werden, wenn dann irgendwelche Hersteller von irgendwelchen Markenprodukten probieren, dir zu verbieten, dass du doch dafür jetzt Ersatzteile selber ausdruckst oder sowas. Weil das ja ihren ganzen bösen Weg schadet. Das wird alles nur noch schlimmer werden.
Aber Cory Doctorow hat in seinem Talk beim letzten Kongress gesagt, das wird jetzt alles nur noch einfacher. Er hat gemeint, das Kopieren wird immer einfacher.
Nee, er hat gesagt, dass es wie im Computerspiel ist, dass die Musikindustrie, diese kleine, lächerliche Industrie, die keinen interessiert, dass die jetzt sozusagen nur der erste Gegner war. Und das man an dem jetzt lernen muss.
Ja, genau, aber er hat ja auch gesagt, dass irgendwie dann in der Zukunft die Enkelkinder kommen. Und dann sag ich, Großpapa, erzähl doch nochmal, wie unglaublich schwierig es war, damals Dateien zu kopieren, wo es halt noch nicht einen Chip gab, der jeden Song, der jemals produziert wurde, oder jeden Film, der jemals gedreht wurde, halt draufpasst, so Fingernagel und so. Aber Jungs, Apple hier, Tim und alle, wie soll das draußen heißen, wir würden bezahlen, echt, ehrlich.
Bestimmt. Diesmal in echt.
Ihr macht einen coolen Service, ihr macht Subtitels, ihr macht Quality, ihr macht das up to date, ihr schiebt den Scheiß raus, sobald ihr ihn habt, wir bezahlen dafür. Wenn ihr den Batman oder irgendeinen Scheiß filmt, ins Kino und gleichzeitig oder ein paar Tage später, ein paar Tage später ist okay, ihr macht den online, Full HD, 18 GB RIP, bezahlt dafür ein paar Euro, das ist super, ich mach das.
Wir lernen nicht. So, und wir?
Lernen auch nicht.
Wir lernen auch nicht mehr.
Wir lernen auch nicht mehr, wa? Sind wir jetzt am Ende der Sendung angekommen? Du würdest sagen ja?
Also fast.
Fast.
Aber, so.
Genau. Dann müssen wir hier lang.
Ist auch schon spät.
Und wir haben die vier Stunden nicht geschafft, die Lukas F uns vorher gesagt hat für diese Sendung. Na, der hat irgendwie ausgerechnet, wir haben doch, wann haben wir angefangen? So gegen 20?
Ach so, der hat diese Durchschnitts...
Genau, und der meinte, dass ein Mobile Max 1000 wird dann irgendwie 21 Stunden lang? Also die Grafik sieht schon beeindruckend aus, muss man mal sagen.
Der ist schön geplottet irgendwie.
Und ist auch so eine Wellenbewegung drinne, geht mal wieder ein bisschen nach unten.
Also einmal der totale Durchschnitt, einmal so ein Monatsdurchschnitt und dann einmal alle einzeln, ne? Musst du posten, sonst wissen wieder alle nicht, worum es geht.
Hab ich schon gerätwärtet. Na, schon ein paar Stützchen her. In der Mobile-Max-Dimeline. Aber können wir gerne dann in die Show-Notes aufnehmen, den Tweet hier. Beziehungsweise den Tweet, beziehungsweise die Grafik, ne?
Müssen wir noch irgendwie Wort verlieren über Made in USA? Ja, weiß man ja nicht wovon, wobei ich schon so eine Vermutung habe.
Na, was ist denn deine, also du spielst darauf an, dass Steve Cook, Steve Cook hab ich gesagt, Steve Cook ist gut, ne?
Tim Jobs und Steve Cook, das wäre so ein schöner Anlass.
Auf die Frage, wie es immer so wäre, mal in USA zu produzieren, dann gesagt hat, ja, mach mal. Demnächst. Und es wird auch so ein bisschen spekuliert, dass das damit zu tun hat, dass Foxconn in die USA geht und dort ein Werk starten will. Also es kommt jetzt sowieso zeitgleich, dass ich mir irgendwie nicht vorstellen kann, dass es sich miteinander zu tun hat.
Das kam schon ein bisschen mit dem Foxconn nach USA, kam ja schon ein bisschen vorher, ein paar Wochen.
Ja, aber eins und eins, oder? Also ich meine...
Also was ich glaube ist, dass ja auch...
Ich kann mir jetzt nicht vorstellen, dass sie in den USA ein Werk aufmachen, wo sie, wo irgendjemand neu anfängt, irgendwie diese ganze Logistik, die sie jetzt Foxconn in den letzten Jahren irgendwie in den Arsch geblasen haben, komplett neu für so ein Ding zu machen.
Glaub ich auch noch. Glaub ich auch nicht. Was ich glaube ist, da hat ja irgendein Typ mal gefragt, wie jetzt hier 2012 und wieder keine neuen Mac Pros. Die sind ja schon so lange überfällig. Und da hat Tim Cook geantwortet, ja, kommt aber erst nächstes Jahr und dann richtig irgendwie ganz großes Ding und wird alles wieder schön. Und ich glaube, dieses Made in USA, das sind die Mac Pros, die so nächstes Jahr in Amerika von irgendwelchen Amis zusammen schrauben lassen.
Ja, aber er hat gesagt...
Weil da gibt's eh nur ein paar Tausend von und mehr nicht und die kannst du auch von Hand zusammenbauen. Na ja, ist doch aber so, oder? Da lohnt sich einfach fast gar nicht, dass irgendwo so kleine Firmen gibt's da in China gar nicht.
Erstens hat er gesagt, das kann natürlich vieles bedeuten. Er meinte, es wäre eine Existing-Mac-Line. Gut, da kann man jetzt sagen, Mac Pros gab's schon. Und jetzt sind das halt nur rein zufällig die neuen. Man könnte auch sagen, dass sie erstmal, um das zu testen, etwas nehmen, was... Ich meine, es würde einfach erstmal sehr viel mehr Sinn machen, dass sie in die USA gehen und dort etwas produzieren, was sie genauso auch schon woanders produziert haben.
Das würde doch gar keinen Sinn machen, oder?
Doch, das würde total Sinn machen, einfach aus einem logistischen Argument heraus. Dass sie sozusagen die etablierten Strukturen, also die etablierten organisatorischen Strukturen und auch das Gerät selbst, dass sozusagen klar ist, dass sie mal nichts Neues lernen.
Aber dann muss man es ja doppelt bauen. Also das hat man schon mal gebaut, so eine Produktionsstraße in dem einen Kontinent, dann macht man es nochmal.
Ja gut, aber vieles davon lässt sich ja dann auch in einer zukünftigen, du musst ja überhaupt erstmal das Personal aufbauen, du musst überhaupt erstmal den Standort aufbauen, du musst überhaupt erstmal den Scheiß zum Laufen kriegen, mit Amerikanern, die das vorher noch nie getan haben. Wenn du dann sozusagen...
Jetzt soll er seine Herrle blöse dann nix können.
Nein, aber ich meine... Ich sag nicht, dass sie das nicht können, aber ich sag nur, dass sie das bisher noch nicht getan haben.
Das ist eine Technologie, die noch nie in Amerika oder in Europa wahrscheinlich auch nie stattgefunden hat. Das wurde bisher immer in Asien gemacht und das ist... Genau.
Das ist doch bestimmt auch so ein Kram, kann man ja nicht vorstellen.
Nein, in dem Maßstab, so ein paar Millionen Computer rauspumpen.
Ja, ich glaube eben nicht, dass es ein großes Gerät ist. Zuverlässig. Ich glaube, dass es halt was ist, was nicht so oft ist und deswegen glaube ich, dass es der Mac Pro ist. Davon wäre es einfach keine...
Stimme, denn es zu, das klingt sehr plausibel.
Prove me wrong. Ich würde eher davon ausgehen, dass sie etwas advancedes, was sie jetzt schon machen, in der Form...
Zum Beispiel iMac oder ein iPhone oder was? Ich würde sagen ein R.
Oder auch ein iMac. Meinetwegen. Also es ist mir wirklich an der Stelle ziemlich egal.
Ich glaube aber da von den Dingern wären so viele verkauft. Ich glaube, das wäre halt viel zu teuer in Amerika.
Aber ich glaube einfach nicht, dass sie jetzt in Amerika mit etwas starten, was dann auch noch komplett neu ist. Wenn sie dann in Probleme rennen, dann haben sie keinerlei Erfahrung, auf der sie aufbauen kann.
Ja, aber bei Mac Pro ist das egal. Da gibt es nicht so viele. Das schleifende Gehäuse von Hans und Lothar.
Ich würde sagen, sie machen eher was, was mehr wird. Also wo sie die Kapazitäten in China nicht runterfahren, sondern wo sie sagen, wir verkaufen davon so viel mehr, dass sich das lohnt, neue Kapazitäten in Amerika aufzubauen.
Aber dazu ist halt China viel zu billig. Dann würdest du dich in Amerika dumm und dem nicht zahlen.
So viel billiger ist das nicht?
Warum machen die das denn dann? Weil die Leute flexibel sind. Du kannst die halt noch leichter wieder auf die Straße setzen, um es jetzt mal böse zu sagen, als in Amerika.
Das ist auch eine Preisfrage.
Du hast auch die Leute, die du schnell genug ranbekommst, die dann auch da sind. Das sind eingefahrene Strukturen und die funktionieren. Das ist wohl das Hauptproblem. Das hat Tim Cook in diesem Interview gesagt, das habe ich auch schon davor mehrfach gehört, dass ein iPhone in der Produktion irgendwie 30 Euro mehr kosten würde, wenn du es in Amerika baust. Also schon deutlich mehr, aber jetzt nicht komplett unbezahlbar. Ich kann mir vorstellen, dass es auch einige Vorteile davon haben. Sie müssen die Scheiße nicht mehr so extrem weit transportieren. Sie haben ja dieses Problem, dass ständig irgendwie jedes neue Produkt in Asien irgendwie liegt. Das könnten sie vielleicht, haben sie die Hoffnung, in Amerika auch ein bisschen besser in den Griff zu kriegen. Und ich kann mir vorstellen, dass sie einfach von Währungsschwankungen ein bisschen unabhängig sein wollen, weil das so der, wie heißt das, chinesische Geld eigentlich, dass das so relativ wenig wert ist.
Ich weiß das auch jedes Mal wieder nicht.
Aber dass das irgendwann plötzlich in die Höhe springt und dann die Löhne in China extrem steigen und die Produkte scheiße teuer werden, das wollen sie glaube ich auch nicht haben. Und dann so ein bisschen Produktion halt in Amerika zu haben, dass man sagen kann, ok, damit kann man so ein bisschen die Währungsspannung abfangen.
Also ehrlich gesagt glaube ich deine Argumente alle komplett so nicht, weil ich auch nicht glaube, dass sie es machen, um Geld zu sparen.
Nee, nicht um Geld zu sparen, aber um sicherer zu sein.
Ich glaube sie machen es einfach nur aus Marketinggründen.
Nee, das glaube ich nicht. Das glaube ich auch nicht. Das haben die nicht nötig.
Ich glaube schon.
Doch. Made in USA sieht halt toll aus.
Wahrscheinlich kriegst du auch nicht eine Subvention dafür. Das könnte ich mir eher vorstellen.
Das ist echt nicht Ips way of dealing with things. Dass sie jetzt mal so eine Manufacturing-Line aufbauen, nur damit es irgendwie gut aussieht.
Weil ihnen das innerhalb kürzester Zeit wieder auf die Füße fallen würde.
Vielleicht machen sie keinen Riesenverlust, aber sie machen da keinen Gewinn.
Vielleicht kriegen sie ja irgendwann mal einen Steuervorteil.
China wird teurer und USA geht es nicht sonderlich gut. Also billige Kräfte kriegst du da auch. Und auf der anderen Seite brauchst du eben auch gut ausgebildete Kräfte.
Und du musst den Scheiß nicht mehr so weit transportieren.
Das ist ja geil.
Bei bestimmten Sachen weiß ich gar nicht mehr, ob die da wirklich so gut ausgebildete Kräfte brauchen. Also um so ein iPhone zusammenzubauen. Also ich glaube wirklich, dass die da schon ganz schön stupide Fließbandarbeit machen. Irgendwie 100.000 iPhones am Tag zusammen schrauben. Und das kommt noch dazu. Deswegen, Mark my words oder wie man das so sagt, ich sag euch, die lassen da Mac Pros von Hand basteln. Und das war's erstmal. Und dann kann ja mehr kommen. Dann kann man ja mal gucken, wie das so geht und so. Aber das ist halt so klein genug, dass man das handeln kann, wenn auch mal was nicht so richtig klappt. Weil selbst wenn die eine Reihe nehmen, diese in China noch parallel fahren, selbst wenn es dann in USA nicht klappen sollte, weil sie vor Probleme stoßen, dann müssten sie ja dann in China dann doch wieder die Kapazitäten besorgen. Also so oder so wäre das ja dann doch wieder ein riesengroßes Problem. Und wenn sie dann nur ein paar Mac Pros zusammenschrauben, das kriegen die auf jeden Fall hin. Also wenn da was schiefläuft, dann...
Da setzt sich Timsono selber hin und strafft drauf.
Von den teuersten Kisten, also Mac Pros würden wahrscheinlich keine 50.000 mehr verkaufen, oder?
Das sagen sie nicht.
Ja ungefähr, weil haben die das doch schon immer gesagt, wie viele Desktops und so.
Nee, die sagen nicht wie viele Mac Pros.
Sondern nur Desktops an sich. Ja, aber es war doch auch schon immer weniger werdend und weniger werdend und wenn Leute welche kaufen, dann waren es wahrscheinlich auch ne Menge iMacs. Also Mac Pros so scheiße teuer, den kaufen echt nicht mehr viele. Ja, aber trotzdem, wer braucht den denn? Ja, und wie viele Pros gibt's so? Und die dreizehn anderen, genau. Und was wird sein? Das Motherboard wird aus China kommen oder aus Taiwan oder sonst wo, alles wird von sonst wo her kommen und vielleicht das Gehäuse an sich oder das Zusammenschrauben davon machen sie dann in den USA.
Leg dich mal fest, Dennis. Irgendso ein Previously für 200 kann man das ganz gut verwenden.
Ich sag euch, so ist es.
Naja, wir wissen es nicht. Wir wissen nicht, was für ein Fernseher gebaut wird. Wir haben keine Ahnung, wir sind überhaupt unwissend.
So.
Ren Mimbi heißt das. Ja, das chinesische Geld heißt Ren Mimbi.
Eigentlich eine der wichtigsten Währungen der Welt und wir haben keinen Blassen Schimmer, wie es heißt.
Ich weiß nicht, ob sie eine der wichtigsten Währungen der Welt ist, aber könnte sie auf jeden Fall werden. Ren Mimbi. Ren...Mim...Bi.
Aber die können doch gar kein R aussprechen.
Aber die Komponente ist doch dieses Yuan oder so. Also Y-U-A-N. Hier steht...
Yuan, ja das hab ich auch schon mal gehört.
In der Zeitbar bei Wikipedia steht Currency Ren Mimbi in Klammern Yuan oder wie auch immer.
Das ist sozusagen die Subunit 1.
Und das jetzt die kleine Yuan ist dann die große, oder?
Wieder was gelernt.
Wieder was gelernt, ne? So, während sich der Chat im Wesentlichen über den Zustand meiner DSL-Leitung unterhält. Ehrlich gesagt, dem reißt ab. Ich weiß, er tut es. Ich kann aber nicht sagen, warum. Ich weiß es nicht. Also ich bin wirklich vollkommen im Unklaren darüber.
Tim, so wird es nie was.
Ne, so wird es nichts.
Ich steig hier aus. Ich mach hier nicht mehr mit.
Machst du Schluss?
Ich hab keinen Bock mehr auf dir, sag mal.
Ich bin raus.
Ja.
Hättest du mal, hättest du mal hier... Was gibt's denn noch überhaupt so? Hättest du mal eins in eins bestellt?
Du hättest mir also koll zu einer Leitung gelegt.
Wir werden das hier auf neue Beine stellen. So, aber jetzt ist raus, Max.
Aber nichtsdestotrotz, das war kein Scherz, ich hab irgendwie schon vor längerer Zeit beschlossen, dass es Zeit ist, mal was anderes zu machen. Und das ist... Man soll gehen, wenn es am schönsten ist.
Jetzt hat man eigentlich so, nein, doch! Den brauchen wir jetzt.
Ja, und für mich war das jetzt quasi die letzte Sendung.
Max steigt aus, das ist die bittere Wahrheit und da kann nicht herumgedeutelt werden.
Ich bin nicht rausgemobbt werden, weil irgendwann war ich mal bei einer Sendung nicht dabei und dann bist du etwa rausgemobbt worden. Das ist nicht der Fall, wirklich nicht. Das war meine Entscheidung jetzt hier zu sagen, nee, das hast du abgesprochen. Tim, nimm die Waffe weg.
Max will sich anderen Karrieren zuwenden.
Genau.
Wieso hast du noch andere Podcasts neben uns?
Schlafen! Ja, ihr könnt mich weiterhin bei WMR hören oder bei der kleinen, aber feinen Märchenstunde.
Genau, die wirst du ja auch noch produzieren.
Viel zu selten leider.
Aber jetzt dann wahrscheinlich öfter, wo du mehr Zeit hast.
Das ist bisher auch nie an mir gescheitert, sondern an Björn Grau, weil der jetzt zwei kleine Kinder hat und einen anstrengenden Job und so. Hey, jetzt hab ich auch einen Chatraum gerade verlassen, sehr lustig.
Das ist der Podcast.
Also daran scheitert das. Genau, also insofern viel Spaß ohne mich dann demnächst.
Und hast du auch irgendwelche neuen, also ich meine, hast du irgendwas wildes in Planung?
Ich überlege was, aber es ist noch viel zu früh, um irgendwas darüber zu erzählen. Aber mal gucken.
Und wer kontert dann, wenn wir über Android herziehen?
Wieso, Android basht doch, hat doch der Max auch jetzt in letzter Zeit gebasht.
Das war ja nur so eine Phase, wo ich das mal nicht so ganz so schlecht fand. Ich fand's ja nach wie vor.
Da haben sie ja schon die ersten Ausstiegsmerkmale, lassen sich daran festmachen.
Das war mir egal.
Max hat was gegen andere gesagt.
Du hast es schon nachgegeben jetzt. Bevor du ganzes wechselst, hast du gedacht, jetzt reicht es.
Bevor du dir doch ein Mac und ein iPhone kaufst.
Und ab nächste Woche dann bei Mobile Android.
Na gut, aber so ist es nun.
Wie geil, hier kommt gerade die Idee, dass meine Verlobte mir den Ausschied schicken. Dass sie mir den Ausstieg aufgezogen hätte.
Weil Mobile Max zu macho und sexistisch und sowieso, das geht nicht.
Ich glaub, meine Freundin hat das nie gehört.
Einfach nicht so viel Zeit verbringen sollen mit den anderen Jungs.
Mehr um die Katzen kümmern.
Der Max, der wird jetzt erwachsen.
Max kümmert sich jetzt wieder um die Katzen. Genau.
Irgendwann müsste sie auch noch... Die wissen schon gar nicht mehr, wie ich aussehe.
Wieso gibt es eigentlich kein Katzenpodcast?
Das stimmt, das fehlt noch.
Ich meine, diese ganzen begeisterten Katzenmenschen könnten doch auch mal... Die ganze Zeit wird darüber geredet, dass das Internet im Wesentlichen eigentlich nur aus Katzen besteht, aber niemand...
Oh, ich hab übrigens eine sehr schöne Katze gefunden.
Außerdem stimmt, ich mach eigentlich alles nur Marco Ament nach. Der hat heute auch letzte Sendung.
War das heute?
Ich hab's nicht gehört, ich hab nur gesehen, dass vorhin...
Nicht nur Marco Ament.
Was macht der denn von der Sendung?
Auch John Siracusa stellt seinen Podcast ein. Du bist ja eigentlich in besser Gesellschaft.
Die stellen alles nur nach.
Hier, guck mal, klick mal auf das Bild. Das ist hier das beste Katzenbild 2012.
Beste Katzenbild 2012.
It's so trippy.
Das hat aber auch LSD auf der Zunge.
Das hat sich auf jeden Fall einer sehr große Mühe gegeben, ein wunderschönes Gift zu produzieren.
Das ist doch wahrscheinlich irgendein Effekt.
Das ist mein Abschiedsgeschenk. Ich hoffe, du richtest es dir als animierten Defqon Pentegrin ein.
Der Dezember 2012 ist der Podcast-Mörder.
Aber machen die jetzt gar keine Podcasts mehr?
Ob die jetzt gar keine mehr machen, das wage ich zu bezweifeln. Aber die beiden Sendungen bei Five by Five sind da jetzt erstmal no more. Also Built in Analyze und Hypercritical laufen jetzt geradeaus erstmal.
Wo sie noch hin und wieder mitmachen, es gibt diesen neuen Podcast, diesen Crossover. Wo sie auch, zumindest Marco Amendt, jetzt in der ersten Sendung direkt dabei sind.
Wo sie ab und zu mal zu Gast sind. Ich meine, wir können ja Max dann auch mal telefonisch reinholen und so.
Genau, leg ich mein Eis vorbei. Als Android-Experten.
Wenn ihr langweilig ist mit den Katzen.
Ich bin allergisch gegen Katzen.
Genau. Ja, und wir haben natürlich dann auch weitere Pläne, die wir jetzt allerdings nicht verraten werden, sondern dazu gibt es dann mehr im nächsten Jahr.
Das war auch unsere letzte Sendung für dieses Jahr.
Das war definitiv die letzte Mowamack Sendung in 2012, weil danach gibt es ja nur noch Kongress und in eurem Fall halt hochgelegte Füße, wenn ich das richtig sehe.
Richtig.
Ritsch hoch. Ritsch hoch.
Ja, schade, dass es mal hier wieder so unströmig war. Ich bin nur in Rätseln, aber wir haben schon die Streaming-Polizei angerufen und die ermittelt. Haben wir alles jetzt gesagt.
Dafür, dass wir kurz vor der Sendung noch gar keine Themen hatten, haben wir es ja doch wieder ganz gut hinbekommen.
Genau, so sind wir.
Ist nicht aufgefallen, dass wir keine Themen hatten, oder?
Ich hatte Themen, aber die habe ich erst kurz vor der Sendung, sind mir alle eingefallen.
So, dann suche ich hier nochmal die richtige Taste und ich glaube, ich habe sie auch schon gefunden.
Das ist Dennis Abschiedsgeschenk.
Du hast uns ja die Taste gegeben. Gib uns mehr Tasten und dann...
Wiederschauen.
Das war's für heute.
Danke für's Wissen. Wir sehen uns bald.